everybody hello hello i'm sorry i'm a little late uh i had
some behind the scenes work with matara earlier today for
zippungu for this we didn't know uh matara and i will be at
uh zippungu a japanese music event that's right let me grab
oh let me grab professional professional streamer here let
me grab the png real quick oh my gosh where is it but we're
doing we're supposed to we're we were supposed to do a
recording together in preparation for the event.
It's a mixture of mean and greets, live stuff, and also like
pre-recorded jokie the year.
So it's a mixture of everything.
And it was supposed to be really quick, like a quick, quick
recording, and then we're good to go.
And then Matara and I started yapping for four plus hours.
We were like, let's do it at 1 p.m.
Let's start our recordings at 1 p.m.
And then we all together and then oh oh it's 3 p.m all right
let's let's let's record one first let's do one recording
first and then i was just like all right okay okay and then
we're like all right let's just take a little break and then
whoops another hour passed and then it was uh four four 50
and we're like oh we gotta do our second recording like oops
um she was like girl did you have a stream we can do it fast
don't worry we can turn this out fast uh and where did the
time go uh so so it's okay we got the job done though uh
matana got the job done we sent it we sent in our recordings
we click hit the chat box and now i'm here i wasn't stalling
because i was afraid of anything okay i'm not i'm not afraid
of dinosaurs with the double d's or anything i'm not
intimidated at all so locked in um anyway let me grab the
png next seat thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you and you'll never know what we have to vote what could we
have talked about you'll never know no the fomo oh no not
the fomo all right so anyway here's the png yes so Kyushu to
fantastic reality uh they approached me to do a little uh
meeting tree and a little event there's gonna be a giant uh
a little event at uh zippungu oh my god i always said
zippungu um and it is a japanese music event so there's a
lot of amazing japanese artists that are there uh headlining
this event let me grab the website real quick it's crazy
they literally just announced Teddy Lloyd um a couple of
days ago so it got even create like the set list and the
headlines got even crazier so basically Ado's here uh Yuki
Chiba Atarashi Gakko man with a mission Chamina 10 feet and
Hana like those are all the performers that yeah they're
literally there they're going to be there at Pasadena um on
uh May 16th at the Rose Rosebow so yeah and then they
announced Teddy Lloyd as a little prize dessert too it's so
stacked uh yeah it's incredibly stacked so it's incredible
uh it's a huge honor uh to be one of the invited vtuber
guests at their event like a little vtuber pop-up event
there's gonna be a giant truck billboard where you can meet
me uh matara emmy uh darrell starlight darrell and anumi as
well so we're gonna we are each we each have like a little i
think my meeting great time if you're there my meeting great
time will be with matara and we're gonna greet and it's
around six ish i think it's 6 30 p.m slot um and yeah it's
gonna be super exciting um it's actually a huge honor to be
one of the invited vtubers to be a part of this event um
this is uh i'll when well for meeting greets i'll be around
i think let me see they just gave us the slides around yeah
it's around 6 25 to 6 40 would be me and matara's meeting
greet so we'll be there live um at the event um and um we
don't know when the other record the other videos will be
shown on the truck uh but matara and i recorded a lot of
content for you guys so it's gonna be super exciting and to
be part of their first like it's their first japanese music
event as well so the fact that they got all of these amazing
jp uh talents um to perform at the first event is insane
like oh my this is so stacked just looking at it let me grab
the image for those who like and that they're in japan you
don't Like, Matara and I were talking about it.
Like, the best part is that, have you guys ever done the,
like, lottery for concerts in Japan?
And it's, like, you need a Japanese address.
You need a Japanese phone number.
It doesn't even guarantee that you win the ticket for the
lottery.
And usually, that's for, like, the individual talents, too.
And for this concert, you get to experience all of these.
The tickets are still right now, by the way.
You get to experience all of these talents in one show at
the...
uh zippongo and i think that's also like that's insane it's
yeah it's so but they're here right now in america uh well
not i don't know not right now maybe they are actually they
have to rehearse and stuff but they're here they're gonna be
here um on on saturday i was gonna say when is 16 on
saturday and get to experience all these amazing talents and
also me well well i won't be singing I'll just be there.
And we'll be hanging out with you guys too.
Tanukes.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That's all really cool.
It's only a little hard to focus on and knowing what the
stream is.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
There's no jingle jangles yet, guys.
I am not intimidated at all.
I can do this.
I can talk to women with double Ds.
Okay, for those who don't know, the member goons suggested
this game.
They tricked me into...
usual for the non-member goons um we had the usual the
battle royale uh selection of what games i'll be playing
this week and um i got tricked into putting that into the
selection of games that we're gonna we're gonna fight it out
because i thought i was talking about like dino crisis and
like dino shooter games and then someone was like you should
check out dot dd dinosaur with double like a shooter that
sounds like an FPS game since I was on the topic of FPS
games and shooters I was like oh man I wonder what does the
double D stand for the bullets right the double the double
bullets that that's the size of the bullets right and it's
two D's on the dinosaur because it's like the stream the
death donos because it's like double dinosaur and marvel
rivals like yeah double these bullets you know like and then
in the middle of the battle royale selection we're like
we're doing the bracket so it's like this game versus that
game someone chow was like i can't believe we managed to get
dd dinosaur into the bracket i was like why do you mean you
can't believe it it's a shooter right the dd bullets the
double deagles you know because the reason why it's two d's
is that she's holding two deagles you know the double d's
and then we all and then all of us looked it up on steam and
we finally realized what the double d's mean it's
wait we realized what the double d stood for and it was not
bullets
I can't believe it's not a gun.
I thought she was...
When I said, is that a gun or are you happy to see me?
It was actually not a gun?
Damn, yeah, it was a cannon, Doki.
Oh, my God.
Donkeys, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I would not normally do this, but you deserve it for that
backstory.
these nuts thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
golden thank you the super chat thank you thank you uh lord
corrosus thinking of the super chat thank you thank you many
noble dragons fell in the oh yeah our usual civil war i
think i don't even know how many civil wars we've had it's
surprising that we keep coming back you dragons keep
agreeing to kill each other uh in minecraft to ensure you
play this but may their sacrifices be remembered um what did
what did won over like some there was some major upsets and
i don't even remember which game they won over zell fuse
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you i clearly
said it was a comedy visual novel when i suggested it as a
curse joke i only expected a story page reaction but the
spike goons took this curse game all the way to oh yeah it
beat slay the spire by the way we could have had slay the
spire too they unionized to work together so i would play dd
dinosaurs with double someone in Twitter being like, oh, I
thought that was, I thought you're playing Devil Dancer for
Marvel Rivals.
I thought that was what the DT Sandor had.
What a surprise when he looked it up, looked up the game,
and it was not related to Marvel Rivals.
It was like, oh, I thought you had early access to Rivals on
that day.
NSD, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um, certainly will be shooting something.
NetBears, thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
DD, dinosaur, huh?
Sounds like Turlock.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Oh, thank you for the Super Chat.
Community note, Donky Bird is Lion Pink.
I did not know, if you watch, re-watch the member vibes, I
did not know what that game was just until someone was like,
I can't believe I got the game in.
I was like, what do you mean you can't believe it?
What do you mean?
Why are you so surprised that I put a shooter game in the
Battle Royale?
Let's see, where else?
Dorky, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Lolly, thank you for the super chat.
Yeah, guys, I have no idea why a lot of longtime dragons
will fall on a comedy game with Tetra romance where the main
girl has a lot.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Jakarta, thank you, thank you, thank you.
We get Dede, Dinosaur, and Devil Dinosaur and Marvel Rivals
in the same week.
I guess it was just fate that Dede, Dede, Dene, ended up
winning the bracket and got revenge for Marvel Cosmic
Invasion, falling early.
Yeah, he's still on about that.
That was his game, by the way.
Dede, Dene, Dinosaur beat that game, guys.
He was fighting so hard for it, but as we all know, we all
know, As we all know, which game won in the end.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I know for sure that it's one guy that voted for Slay the
Spire in the end.
Out of pure spite.
Yeah, we lost Panzer Dragoon for this.
But yes, today we're going to be playing DD Dinosaur.
If I can get away with Honeypock, maybe I can get away with
this.
Honeypot never got age-restricted.
Let me double check.
I think that's crazy that it never got any.
I've had, by the way, FNAF got age-restricted.
If you guys didn't know, I had the FNAF into the ball pit
where they were all pixels got age-restricted, and yet
somehow Honeypot survived.
Let me double check.
Honey.
All right.
honey pop I'm pretty sure it never got it never got hit all
right what is action oh yeah because I swore too much oh
yeah I remember I was we asked our YouTube manager and being
like um how come this game got restricted and he's like
there was a lot of profanity I remember now there was a lot
of profanity during during the fit friend the FNAF ball pit
game yep never restricted monetization on visibility public
all right what about ball pit did they ever took it out or
is it self-restricted they're like surprisingly you swore
you were just way too much profanity so we couldn't we
couldn't keep it we had to age age restrict it what the fuck
is it called why can't i find it oh yeah there we go limited
18 plus only five nights at freddies into the ball pit yep
It got 18 plus age restricted.
I was too wholesome in honey pot.
You're right.
All I wanted to do was take them out on a date.
And then we each go home to our separate locations.
That's all I wanted to do.
I was just like, all right.
Now you go back to your place and I go back to my place.
They even listed for chat.
Thank you.
need to update the history books it was not one but two
asteroids that killed the dinosaur all right sound guy let
me know um let me know sound is okay all right and my head
doesn't even cover up now it's just d dinosaur with one d
okay wait wait what do you mean by twitch is there like
twitch integration let your chat help vote on difficult
decisions and dilemmas don't worry you still have final yeah
no
wow oh my god she has two she's carrying two volleyballs on
her guys oh my how is she holding up her phone with those
two volleyballs that she's carrying
and us i'm not there's nerd guys do not have the right to
vote on this stream right now there's this is this is a
monarchy not democracy we can help you we can be trusted
this is not a democracy right now consider turn nope nope
that's okay i make the choices of power people of France
people of dragoons all right use a headset for the best
experience dinosaur with double d people of red delusion oh
my god we lost our Thanos with double d's How could we, how
could we, how could this happen?
It still amazed me you said, I just answered almost all the
way through Honeypot just to look at the phone gallery.
Lolly, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
And I still didn't get age restricted.
Oh my god, the dinosaurs.
What?
And ass too.
That's so true.
All the fat rotted away.
We never knew the true size.
It's like, what if they had others, like cows?
Oh, he's not lying, though.
Imagine those biggest others on a T-Rex.
True.
What?
What about the ass, though?
Who's going to represent the ass?
How could we have been so ignorant to mislook such an
important detail in life and history?
Oh my god.
These guys are pioneers.
Who would represent the Donald Kicks?
Where is...
the equality guys i love history millions of years later
what is this we're learning about history right now we're
learning about dinosaurs dd dinosaur looks around the room
while moving her knees up and down nervously she anxiously
look around the unfamiliar room her eyes wide open it's an
old musty room just like in the movies this is the history
channel it's like the one where they talk about the aliens
it's an old musty room just like in the movies a therapy
room so stereotypical that almost seems to be a parody she
can't help but be a little bit nervous billy thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you history channel at 3 a.m
now that's why couldn't science be like this when i was in
I'm quite introvert, and I'm not used to talking to others
about my feelings at all.
But Mr. Robson was right.
It's time I start working on myself.
She hears a mature hand confidently push down the handle of
the door to the office.
That must be the doctor.
Wait, do I look presentable enough?
Wait,
are you sure they're D's?
Maybe lower music, but bring up overall lower music.
Maybe they stop counting.
They got...
They stop counting because they suffocated.
Wait, do I look presentable enough?
Quickly, she snags a mirror from her handbag to inspect
herself before he...
enters the room oh my god what what do you okay
okay okay okay um
i think she might need to get it checked out i think she
might need to see what we're gonna call all those doctors
for for the Vagini I think no oh no no yeah she might need
to say gynecologist yeah I think vulva F I mean isn't
exciting when it talks back
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
A dinocologist.
Papa, thank you for super chat.
Thank you.
There's booms that go.
Now, Robert, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We're going to go with F.
Perfect.
A deep manly yet reassuring voice is heard from the entrance
behind her.
Good afternoon.
My heart.
Apologies for the long way.
The sequel of the Jurassic World went crazy.
Patrick, I said thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
He reaches out his well-manicured hand as he introduced
himself as Dr. Lino Pogistot, but she mainly calls him Leon.
Oh!
It's in good knowing, you jockey.
for the super chat, thank you.
Chris Pratt!
Do not the dinosaur, Chris Pratt!
You raised her!
As the rough texture of his callous fingers gripped her hand
tightly, a warm feeling comes over her.
With a friendly smile, the imposing doctor takes a seat
opposite of hers.
The chair creaks under the weight of his massive, body.
Wow.
What a man.
She slowly looks him up and down from head to toe.
A voice like a subwoofer.
Arms like a tree.
Turn the volume to 200.
A voice at arms like a tree truck.
And those trows of this if they're put a push up for all of
us.
She can hardly focus on what Leon is seeing while her mind
wanders.
I have never kissed someone with a mustache before.
I wonder what that would feel like.
Get it together, DD, dinosaur.
What is wrong with you?
You're normally not like this.
let's have a look impatiently he goes through he looks like
omni-man I think that's that's really omni-man I mean if he
decides to retire it's not with his pants damn I understand
oh shit you just need him to turn around and start twerking
what are you I don't think this is a doctor.
I thought he was an author.
Bro, it's that show on Amazon.
He patiently goes through his papers.
Maybe he's looking for a new pet.
You know what I mean.
I didn't know you had a persona.
Thank you, it was super chat.
I'll thank you.
I see you're here because you're a bit, you feel a bit
confused.
Is that correct?
dinosaur has a chance to answer.
He continues.
Sorry.
What was your name again?
Uh, stop.
AP.
Why was there a timer to type my name?
Sorry.
AP.
Yeah, England.
Yeah, AP.
I'm taking AP studies right now.
I fell in the quick time event.
They guess your AP now.
English, yeah, I'm taking English AP.
English lit AP.
Are you sure?
Space, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Why is naming myself a quick time event?
I am distracted by Omni Man right now.
It does seem that you're a bit confused indeed.
With a friendly smile on his face, he glances over the
papers in his hand.
Didi Dinosaur notice that there is a very calming aura
surrounding him.
I see here that your name is Didi Dinosaur.
Is that correct?
Oh, wait, she does have cake, guys.
It's just not equally distributed.
That's right.
dv dinosaur with double ds oh no nice omni man discovering
his purple woman fixation early i see how would this affect
the power scaling though thank you the super chat phase
thank you thank you yeah he hasn't been the same since
debbie left i must admit i am quite nervous game right now
don't worry there's fps later there's there's no need to be
nervous this is just an initial interview to get to know
each other a bit because the more i know you the easier it
will be for me to help you this is why we're going to do an
introduction test first so that if you turn out to be dumb
like a stupid bitch i know it I should talk to you in a
condescending tone in the future.
Lord, Wahoo, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I shouldn't be watching this in public, but I know there
won't be a vibe.
Not to worry.
There are no right or wrong answer in this initial
interview.
Are we sure this is a real talk?
Do you not see the degrees on his desk right now?
Yes, I am.
Look at all those degrees behind him.
Look at that.
He has trope.
Oh, my God.
He is proud of it.
A doctor can have hobbies.
Deity dinosaur is a little nervous, but not as determined
towards Lillian.
All right.
Time for the first question.
In a few words, how you describe yourself of being, I'm
pretty hilarious, insecure, anxious.
Oh, I'm so insecure about my double Ds.
I feel like they're a bit too small.
Leon takes a good look at her.
Yes, I can understand that.
I'm so humble.
on to the next question don't you guys oh my don't you ever
feel so insecure because you feel like you're just too small
what is your favorite activity bowling going to the gym
dancing and somersaulting uh i guess Uh, where's gaming?
I guess dancing.
Oh, really?
So you really enjoy being physically active.
Didi Dasa doesn't really answer his question, but instead
it's just creepily grinning to herself.
All right, then let's move on to the next question.
What is your favorite song?
Hull again.
Ding, ding, a dong.
We're the champions by Crazy Frog.
You really call me pathetic, but I can't listen to this song
without getting choked up.
If you choose anything else, that's wrong.
So I didn't even super tell you I saw the stream on my
recommended feed.
Now I would carry the knowledge that this game exists for
the rest of my life.
Make sure to wishlist this on scene, guys.
Le Pen, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
So you too can have your own personal DD dinosaur.
It makes me cry every time.
Let me open up overall.
volume and then turn down the music again wait what's
outfits oh okay cute next question what is your favorite
snack I like to use a lifeline a lifeline it's your own
opinion yeah but what is your favorite snack I like to call
him like sweet cat Mr. Robson.
I'll give you like, it's you.
Because you're a snack.
And calls your cute cat Mr. Robson.
Oh, is that the buff-ass cat in the trailer?
Oh, look, Mr. Robson.
Hello, Mr. Robson.
Hey, Robson.
I don't have line.
Here's the question.
What's my favorite snack?
Meow.
Are you sure?
Meow, meow, meow.
Okay, thank you.
Just before the time runs out.
Okay, well, what's your answer?
Wait, yours are the same.
Okay, extra large cheese, peach.
episode.
Oh, what a good choice.
I really enjoy that, too.
Especially when it's extra cheesy.
You know, for the mozzarella pull, you know, guys?
I feel like I'm really getting to know you a bit already.
On to the next question.
Did you know that some claim that people who cry during a
movie, have a higher emotional intelligence?
Personally, I'm a bit skeptical about that.
I doubt whether people who cry over a drawn deadline are
really more intelligent.
What is your favorite movie?
Carfield.
Oh, is there, I mean, no hesitation there.
Honestly, honestly, God's gift to the world world.
Dick Omni, man.
Only click, they go to Super Chat.
They have frame one.
No, not even a choice.
It's not even a choice.
It's a path.
All right.
Oh, he's such a sweet little creature, isn't he?
Wow.
I didn't expect us to have that in common.
Too bad I don't have anyone to watch movies with.
It's just so hard to be so hot.
I just intimidated all the women away because I'm just, oh,
so hot.
It's so sad, guys.
Honestly, what a depressing life.
God so sad it's hard out there for people who are just so
hot in this world
anyway next question what you did you not see those dialogue
it was like right there you not see it I was just reading it
anyway next question finally someone Who understands me His
life is so sad Name something you really enjoy Alright let's
see Biceps, long mustaches Hard six pack Well groomed
Cuttercutters That's a long mustache Even his ass have
cleavage Thank you for the super chat Thank you Oh yes I
love a man that looks like a Viltramite.
Oh, oh, wait.
Oh, I don't have, I'm shit.
This was the easiest, this, sir, this is not professional.
Sir, sir, this is not professional.
Patient, doctor here.
This is an HSHR violation.
well that wasn't too bad was it guys it could be a gun the
shooter part could start here guys the fps part should start
here guys that's the gun he's packing
dude you dinosaur is feeling relieved although jenna i think
you was but you attend give the chips thank you thank you
she was very lucky to open up like this it wasn't all that
bad oh by the way i almost forgot what is your favorite
dinosaur what is she oh no does he know why is he what he
asked that question the dc dinosaur starts sweating between
your sensual thighs and underneath their breasts this was a
mistake i never should have came here oh wait I have to
answer.
I heard somebody come across even more suspicious.
Um, T-Rex!
T-Rex?
Hmm.
Okay.
Your answer.
Very peculiar.
With a questionable look on his face, Dr. Leon turned his
attention to his notes.
Oh, all right.
All done.
Believe it or not, those answers can teach you a lot about a
person.
Everybody's favorite, Dono, is the T-Rex.
And I, as a therapist, have already gotten to know a lot
about you.
That you take these kind of tests very seriously, for
example.
Dr. Leon points out her sexy sweat, her hands, her tissue.
That is a good thing.
It means you take the session very seriously and are willing
to work on yourself.
This is the first step.
Very impressive.
Thank you.
Didi Dinosaur feels the stress leaving her body.
It looks like he didn't notice after all.
I'm way too stressed.
Maybe therapy is a good idea after all.
If something like this already sends my stress levels
through the roof, DD dinosaur takes the tissue from Dr. Leon
and wipes the inside her moist thighs dry.
I'm sorry.
Where can I put this?
My favorite dinosaur changed after watching this stream.
NSD, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Don't worry about it.
You can just give that to me.
Your favorite dinosaur might also have double Ds.
You don't know that.
Science will never know.
All the fat, rotten, melted away carefully maybe they were
all they all were double d's guys we'll never know how else
would they feed their babies carefully he grabs the dampen
tissue and stores it in his cheek like oh like a hamster
he's just he's testing it he has to test the sweat to make
sure um to make sure i'm healthy guys he's got to make sure
he doesn't lose it what's for science Looks like you have
had enough for today.
I was just making new appointment for next week so we can
really get into it.
All right, that sounds good, doctor.
Please calm me, Leon.
I will, Lion.
All right, week one, bedroom.
Press space.
Oh, I did.
I finished day one.
Didi dinosaur is lying in bed.
A thin sheet just barely covers her enormous body because
it's quite warm and she is not wearing any other clothes.
Curled up against her is her best friend who also happens to
be the cutest cat ever.
That was a strange day, Mr. Robson.
They're usually my only conversation partner.
Billy, they give a super chat to you.
Thank you.
Guys, it's because she's a reptile.
overheater or she'll die you don't want that but today I was
sharing the most personal opinions with this random
attractive stud well there he is I have I don't know why but
I feel like there might be a that might be a fursuit now am
crazy or something for thinking that guys no no way right no
my favorite dinosaur is the thick sword perhaps even a super
chat thing how can we compete
looks like a norm you're right it is a normal cat you're
right it is it's that's a normal cat i don't know why i
thought it was a for a furry
you're so sweet and cute she tickles his cute little cat no
no things you do with your cat guys what a normal day is
that great she's bonding with her pet she tickles his cute
little Kathy he likes it
Mr. Robson is my oldest and most loyal friend.
He may not be that talkative.
And sometimes he paused, at least when I'm in the middle of
a sentence.
But I feel I can always talk to him about anything.
Say thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, Dan.
Do not your cat.
I don't know what's there for you.
What do you mean?
She's just tickling his paws.
Don't you do that?
Do a little tickle tickle with the cat paws.
It's totally normal.
Pet owner pet behavior.
or if i'm just glad it's over i feel a lot lighter already
maybe it's a good idea to go back for another session next
week after all i must say it was quite a shock when dr leon
sprung that dinosaur question on me what did he find so that
i'm actually the dinosaur on the other hand there will come
the point i wish it would be inevitable to share the real
reason that i'm visiting him
years now Jill that's not a sad sigh no it's just so hard to
have such small boobs I know I feel you but thankfully I
have you mr.
Robson hey I love you too mr.
absinthe you're right mr.
absinthe nobody can truly love me if I don't love myself
please mr.
absinthe don't get political oh week two oh that was fast
what did he say a week has gone by already he's like I don't
think dinosaurs her fright when Didi Dinosaur finds herself
in Dr. Leon's waiting room again so you can feel her
sexually attractive belly rumble with nerves.
Did I really know for sure that I want to go through with
this?
It all feels so vulnerable.
She arrived early so she doesn't feel like she had to go in
right away.
But despite her hesitation, the clock on the wall seems to
be ticking faster and louder than usual.
Maybe I'm making a mistake by coming here.
Bye.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What the hell is this?
Don't worry.
The shooter part.
It's an FPS game.
It's going to come up soon.
Guys.
The bullets are in the boot.
Change.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Then Didi Dinosaur noticed the overly attractive man that's
sitting just a few seats away from her.
From the corner of her eyes.
Didi Dinosaur sneaks a peek his way.
Where she sees him.
barely believe he is real a jawline that seems to have been
chiseled by a sculptor a hairline that could break off a
hedge trimmer and that body wow as if his place of birth is
dreamland it's like he stepped straight out of a ken box
well he he has a little extra in the in the crotch area so i
don't think it's as accurate to ken it's not one-to-one act
it's not one-to-one model it's like you stepped yeah but
then instead with the essential part yeah from an actual
Kendall yeah toes oh yeah toes you're right toes yeah yeah
he doesn't even notice me he must think I'm a monster is my
boobs too small he was wiping with seems to be cat hair from
his shirt while he's unintelligibly muttering to herself.
Didi Dinosaur does something that even surprises her.
She muster up some courage and Ashley decides to speak to
him.
Huh?
A cat owner, I see?
Oh.
He looks up.
Poor Didi Dinosaur.
Being secure, being flat just like doggy unless there was
some stream appropriate jangle jangle bunch top thank you
for the akasufu thank you thank you i'm so insecure chat
oh i don't i don't like being next to it it's how he stores
his wads of cash guys you know how like and he where will he
fit his wallet guys he rolls up all his dollar bills into a
bomb and it stuffs it in his boxer to keep it safe guys uh
there's no pockets where else would he put his money left
side joki right now it's true i also store my cash there see
if everyone does it Wait, oh, these hairs?
No, it's just that I just can't stop strangling cats.
That's the reason why I am meeting with Dr. Leon.
Bro, what?
Bro, this man, what?
Oh, I'm sorry, just kidding.
The JK.
I know.
Not funny.
There's home lander.
Oh, it's not mine.
It's my bad.
I guess I'm just a little tense about my appointment.
That's a good one.
I feel like, no, that's Soldier 67.
That's him.
That's before he... That was him in the army.
I'm in Overwatch.
Well, you wouldn't be the person who doesn't understand me.
He then stares at the sky for...
About two to three seconds of emotional look on his face.
Very so, so sad.
Yeah, before the PTSD, guys.
Oh, my God.
It's so sad.
Why does bad things happen to beautiful people?
No.
They shouldn't have to deal with this.
He's too beautiful for that.
But yeah, anyway, I actually got this free fur coat.
He just dressed the hair on his shirt.
The crime model reminds me of the Mia Freddy Fazbear in a
shower with a fat ass saying, Why is everyone so mean to me,
Jade?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Because I just can't leave my house without cuddling my cat.
Call me a little bitch.
just love that for real little guy, you know?
I find it very endearing.
Deity dinosaurs taking back about easiest for her to talk to
his attractive stranger.
It's normally never this easy for me.
She looks her way around in her purse.
It must be here somewhere.
Here it is.
What?
Why did...
Wait, is that?
that triceratops like she can top you anytime you know what
i mean
dd dinosaur hands in one of those cat hair rollers
his sexy fingertips accidentally touch triceratops touches
dd dinosaur hands lightly a wave of goosebumps rolls over
her shoulders oh no she's getting it ha ha horny I get it
handy thank you oh whoa no problem oops
just a tiny growl to assert my dominance just a small growl
oh bless you you luckily didn't notice it means that it
means i love you he starts brushing his tight shirt
While holding his shirt up To brush it T-T-T dinosaur clad
Oh now she sees the six pack Out of excitement A dro- Sweat
The squirts out from one of her pores Which makes her catch
herself Peaking just before he makes Eye contact with her
again Wait that is a four pack What time you have to go in
again?
Go in bro huh have to go what well i assume you're not just
here for the comfortable chairs you're waiting for your
appointment as well right he makes an xd face xd oh uh yeah
i swear to you guys this if this game doesn't get age
restricted i swear dd dies so it looks at the clock because
she In just three minutes already?
That went by fast.
Huh?
In three minutes?
Oh, wait.
Me too.
You're not going to tell me that I'm...
Gosh, I'm an hour early again, am I?
I'm such a hymnal.
That sucks hard.
Um, if your appointment's at 11 o'clock, then yes.
Well, then.
At least I still have plenty of time to be ashamed.
Beat he dies or accidentally lets out a giggle.
What a friendly nod.
He reaches out to give back the cat hair roller.
Don't let him keep it.
It's my little gift to you.
Oh.
Oh, hope is lost for me anyway.
That's how much hair loss Mr. Robson has.
He has a taste for a moment.
Is Mr. Robson your husband?
been huh oh he's fishing he's fishing right now wait a
second is he trying to get each one oh my god he's trying to
no or is he just not funny well just before she's about to
reel to them that she's single a door to dr leon's office
swings open dinosaur with double these come on in what bet
was lassa led to this that the member member goons chose
this man it was their choice oh well i wish you the best of
luck with your strangulation problem wait what how do you
know about that oh it's not so much more problemless it's
it's a solution.
I wasn't talking to... Oh, no.
Oh, no.
Omni-man!
I thought you were reformed!
Oh, of course.
Come in.
Alright, we're at Leon's office now.
Oh, he freaky.
Welcome.
Please take a seat.
Dr. Leon gestures to a chair that clearly has a whoopee
cushion on it.
I knew he was attractive, but I didn't know that he was a
comedic genius.
I love a man with a brilliant sense of humor.
Wait.
I wonder if this won those psychological tests.
We'll sit down.
We'll humor him.
We're going to be like, you're so funny.
Dinosaur sits down.
Oh, oh my god, you're so...
Oh, you're so funny!
Are you happy?
Oh, he is so funny!
Ha, ha, ha, ha!
She noticed a sparkle applied in Dr. Leon's eyes.
Peek, everyone, shut it down!
We've reached the peak of comedic genius.
I might as well retire now.
Uh-oh, stinky.
And she knows...
Notice the spark of pride in Dr. Leon's eyes.
Leon's sneak increased to 100.
Oh?
Oh, he leveled up.
Good.
How are you doing this week?
It's all downhill from here.
I'm a bit nervous.
I'll be honest.
Don't worry.
We will take it slow.
Leon's warm voice alone calms DD dinosaurs.
a bit after all coming here is a big step already so be
proud of yourself that you're choosing to work on yourself
lady dasher appreciates his under i'll miss you toky ellie
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you and that he
leaves some of his buttons on his shirt open i don't think
he chose to leave i i think that shirt is one size too small
I don't think you chose to leave the buttons open.
Those buttons are not going to fucking make it.
This is also why it is common to do a relaxation test during
one of...
Yeah, one?
A relaxation test?
Yes, this often helps people calm the chaos and busyness in
their heads, which in theory should make communicating about
problems easier.
Didi Das looks again Dr. Leon's strong fingers that look
like they could be world heavy weight thumb wrestling
champions.
I hope this relaxation test is a massage.
We will try to achieve this through a massage.
Oh, I played these games before.
Jackpot.
Okay, please lie down.
He gestures to the couch in the corner of his office.
She bears her neck.
Oh my god.
Slash down on the table.
Slashing her colossal.
Slabbers on to the table.
Bada-da-da-bomb.
Ooh yeah.
But she carefully rests her.
head on her arms she feels her heartbeat vibrating through
her bosom into the that was not leather that was that was
not that was like a fucking a plank draped over with white
cloth that was not that was not leather calm down dd
dinosaur i know i've been lonely for millions of years but
he's just doing his job she can't help being a man god
either isn't to get isn't to get cracked and her ass sister
did over 65 million years ago trash thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you are you comfortable and ready i'll
do a victory dance i'll show her i'll show him how quirky i
am oh my
She's so quirky!
Oh my god.
Donkey bear would do...
What is this?
Shady, thank you for the Akka soup.
Thank you.
Oh my god, nobody was where I thought I thought she was
gonna do a four-night dance
Okay, now close your eyes and try okay.
It's good.
He's overlooking that guys.
That's good That's a that's that's a green flag right there
not a red flag guys.
No red flags here breathe in and breathe out presses his
manly palms on DD dinosaurs' scary shoulder blades or scaly
shoulder blades, waves of goosebumps rolls over her entire
exposed body.
Now try to calmly get all your feelings in line.
Do this by pressing space bar the right time when emotion
blocks are floating above the pillar.
Keep the tower as straight as possible to keep your emotions
balanced the space what oh he's uh you guys run i'll handle
it i've been thinking for your noble sacrifice i've been oh
no dad wait we'll relax right now while i feed him i'll get
back aren't you all so relaxed guys aren't you all so
relaxed right now what the leon gently begins to apply
pressure to dd dinosaur's sexy back and gently rubs her body
up and down
When Leon rough fingertips gently touched her shoulders, she
actually lets out a sensual.
It's so relaxing, guys.
Sorry, did I hurt you?
Um, no, sorry.
I normally, DD Dinosaur, you're making it awkward.
Longing.
It's like those stacking games at arcades.
Do I stack it all the way up?
I win a plushie or a Nintendo Switch, guys.
When Leon's moist, warm hands apply light pressure to
attract his shoulder blades, T.D.
Dazher feels like she was being wrapped in a blanket of
peace and quiet.
She noticed her heartbeat calming down.
The familiar chaotic thoughts are slowly fading as Leon's
voice keeps sounding a little further away.
All right, luck.
Okay, interested, afraid, breathe in.
And breathe out.
Okay, disgust.
In full control, his strong hands glide over his hips, over
his hips, again followed by a wave of goosebumps.
Didi, dinosaur's eyes almost disappear in the back of her
head.
She is overwhelmed by the ecstasy of the relaxation.
Of course, he is a prof...
Oh my god!
But she's...
I'm surprised at how comfortable she feels with Leon.
Alright, anger, arousal, repulsion.
She began to wonder if she had ever felt this comfortable
with someone before.
Okay, I gotta be careful with this.
Fear, relief, stress.
stop her mind from wondering Leon's powerful hands near
amphibious legs.
Oh my god, I gotta be careful now.
I don't have much to work with.
It is like those stacking games on the arcade.
I gotta win the switch, guys.
Her cheeks slowly turn red as her thoughts.
One day, she has never felt such powerful hands to be so
gentle.
Oh my god.
I don't have much left.
Oh, I just made it.
Oh, she bites her lower lips.
As she noticed, its hands smeared with massage limes are
getting closer to her tail.
Oh, no!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, she lets out
another growl.
Are you okay?
Oh, don't.
Don't.
Lying.
Oh, my God.
with the weight of all the stress lifted from her shoulder
she struggles not seeing things she normally would never
dare to oh my god guys i'm so locked in
oh she knows it's daring but dd dinosaur is concerned i'm
locking in for the people right now Oh, God.
Leon.
No, don't do this to me.
How is there?
Could you maybe?
Oh, my God.
Oh.
Move your hands.
No.
Don't do.
Don't wait.
Okay.
Oh, no.
Guys, this might be over.
No!
Why?
Oh, my God.
You failed us.
Everything glows black from one.
While she almost drowns in tidal waves of distress, one
overbind thought can no longer be suppressed.
But what if he knows that I'm a dinosaur?
Her head spins like a carousel when she is overcome by her
negative thoughts.
Beneath his callous palms, Dr. Leon feels Didi Dinosaur's
heart suddenly speed up.
Didi Dinosaur?
What did you say?
Dinosaur?
She starts breathing faster and deeper.
Didi Dinosaur, are you okay?
He knows.
I knew it was a mistake coming here.
It's not becoming too much for Didi Dinosaur.
The millions of years of build-up emotions are too bottled
up to be revolved in just one session.
Didi Dinosaur, listen to me.
Stay calm.
This deep, soothing voice almost immediately calms down.
The world with its thoughts in their head.
Breathe in and breathe out.
It's hard for Didi Dinosaur not to calm down around Dr.
Leon.
presence makes her feel like she has known him for a
lifetime oh my god breathe in and breathe out Didi Dinosaur
notice that she is slowly calming down again are you feeling
a little better now yeah that was loud I think that was a
sound effect don't worry Let me...
She feels her...
When she slowly calms down, she instantly starts feeling
ashamed of her thoughts just now.
Oh, sorry.
I... I don't know what I...
There's no need to apologize for anything.
No one expects you to solve this in just two weeks.
You did great.
What?
Devour it?
I'm doing it.
She said he said I did great.
I'm in a dinosaur eyes aren't very good, but they can detect
movement When Leon puts his pen away, she strikes
Game over I ate Leo, but I was so hungry I who told me she
killed him So in terms of power scaling DD dinosaur is
stronger than a Viltramite.
Okay, I can't, guys, I can't eat him, apparently.
I'm...
But I'm so hungry.
DD Dinosaur appreciates words very much and starts blushing.
After all, it is common knowledge that the opinion of an
attractive person is more important.
Still somewhat dazed, DD Dinosaur who smiles gratefully
after hearing his reassuring words.
Leon takes a seat back at his desk while he gives D.D.
Dineshers some space to get dressed again.
Hmm, this was an intense session.
So, I think we did more than enough for today.
He remarks as he takes some notes, like a doctor would do.
Oh, and by the way, before you go, I notice you're talking
an attractive man out there in the waiting room.
Well, I'm not allowed to share anything personal about him.
Do you talk to patient confidentiality?
I would still like to advise you to be cautious when talking
to him.
That's all.
Uh...
Oh, sorry.
I got, like, a voicemail from my university, my old
university, and I was just like, who's, why did they call
me?
And they're just, it was just alumni stuff.
They're like, don't...
You know the usual alumni stuff?
They're like, please donate.
you donate to our thing
I'm sorry I'm too busy playing a video game give us money
they saw us play they saw me playing this and we're like we
gotta call it please come back we saw this amazing stream
you're doing it was better you are the alumni of our
university We need you to represent, um, we need you to
represent our school right now.
No other alumni is so courageous and so humble to play this
game.
So brave.
She's so brave.
She, this alumni is so brave.
They want me to be the graduation speaker after seeing me
play this game.
They, uh, Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
They are watching.
They want their degree back Braver than a firefighter Be
cautious That's strange.
I didn't get the impression I couldn't trust them at all But
then other than the whooping question from earlier, I have
no reason not to trust Leon We saw the brave choices you
made on stream.
Would you like to donate to our new t-rex display?
Thank you the super chat vehicle.
Thank you.
Thank you up leon confidently sinks back into his chair oh
my god he was so good that he fooled himself fuck all right
bedroom i'm back with mr mr robert dd dinosaur is lying in
bed with her tone stomach with her long legs raised high up
in the air her turtles curl as miss oh mr robinson i was
almost right was snugly sweetly against her with his little
paws.
Another intense day.
Who would have thought that getting a massage could be so
tiring?
I'm a bit ashamed, though, of how active Leon today.
What in the world possessed me?
Mr. Robson lies down on his back.
It's a way to tell D.D.
Diasco to stroke his chubby belly.
Touch my belly.
A loudcast don't like their belly rub.
So this means he really trusts me.
It's so cute.
look maybe she actually puts steroids in his food maybe it's
just a normal cat guys he just grew up a bit bigger than
other cats you're so cute a cd dancer slowly runs her nails
over mr rob's his belly she can't help uh but think back to
that man in the waiting room help but think back to that man
i met in the waiting room robson this is a perfectly normal
cat all right he just had he just grew a little bit bigger
than other cats it made me feel something in my gut that i
felt since the jurassic second and middle period of the
mesozoic era that attraction but still i keep thinking about
what dr leon said about him be cautious oh well it doesn't
matter we never speak to that mysterious hot male again
anyway well i for sure won't if i stop going to a therapy
session i just don't know if it really suits me you know i
mean what's the angle i'll never tell dr leon that i'm a
real dinosaur or colloquially large reptile from the
subclass this the sita and the infer class arcosauromorpha
anyway now yeah i know you're probably right only two
sessions may not be enough to know his therapy will help me
get over my problem my loneliness I can't believe I'm just a
five in this world it's just so hard to be so ugly I'm still
not promising I'll keep going you cute little guy robson
close his eyes contentedly the way cute cats do is oh my god
is her university asking for money too her phone vibrates
next to her on the bedside table well what the mr robson was
just beginning to drift out to sleep so it's up for a moment
and then slowly close his eyes again cute what is this a
message from an unknown number appears on the screen you see
she's a five in the dinosaur world you haven't seen the 10
yet
hey is this you I have no idea who this could be last time I
gave my number must have been that time a guy stopped me on
the street about charities but only because I didn't want to
say no because otherwise the world where charity would make
me feel like a bad person the 10 is EE dinosaur you mean GG
dinosaur but that must have been a year ago or so how should
i respond to the message uh no message that to me this is
you no sign whatever it's getting late could be spam guys it
could be telemarketers can't let them know my information
because then they'll win to her.
She feels Mr. Robson twitching in the sleep.
He must be playing in the sleep.
So goddamn cute.
She takes a photo.
See?
I told you!
He's a perfectly normal cat!
Then her phone vibrates again.
It's another message from an unknown number.
She gets a funny feeling about it while reading the message.
What do you find more important in a potential partner?
personality or looks what is this yet for some reason she's
intrigued by the question and decides to answer in all
honesty personality message said what a weird question so
interesting to think about is that how I really feel I mean
I think I think she has a very big personality sorry she
almost dropped her receives yet another message huh did you
know that this is what most people think personality 65.7%
oh wait oh it tracks my data looks 34 point oh my gosh I
mean you know what this game deserves to track my data
do you want my social security number two uh okay I guess I
agree with most people on this.
a bit creepy.
I wonder who that message could be from.
She looks at Mr. Robson, who is taking a nap in full ball
form.
Oh my god.
He's loathing.
You're not stalking me, aren't you, Robbie?
He doesn't respond to her because she has no interest in the
subject.
But he's still cute because he looks adorable.
Yeah, good plan.
I should go to sleep too.
It's already getting late.
When she lies down on her sides, her breasts slaps together.
Startled, but with a tired look on his face, Mr. Robson
looks up.
Meow.
Don't worry, Robson.
It was just my gargantuan bosom.
Just go back to sleep.
I'm good.
Don't you just hate that?
Robeson behave.
Besides, I'm... Oh!
Oh!
Week three, waiting room.
I blacked out for a second.
I didn't see what happened there.
Sorry, I...
Whoa!
Sorry, I just woke up from a coma.
I hope I didn't miss anything important.
Another week has flown by already.
Well, yeah, while I was about to pass up, my hand
accidentally pressed the space bar.
And then I woke up again.
um has already you know like you know like when your hand is
like spazzing and stuff when your fingers start spazzing and
then you press accidentally press the button when you're
passing out beauty dancer is sitting in with the waiting
room again anxiously waiting until dr leon calls her in
don't you hate that when that happens guys oh silly me i'm
so silly and quirky okay Colonel, I'm trying to lurk in a
strange dokey stream, but the clap of my humongous peduncas
keep alerting all the dragons.
Absolutely.
Super chat.
Thank you.
She looks at the clock.
It's almost time.
I'm curious what this week's test would be.
For a minute, she thinks about the possibilities of today's
test.
Hopefully one day.
It would be a pregnancy.
Okay.
I don't think a therapist does that, guys.
The wrong doctor, ma'am.
Ma'am, you're in the wrong office.
This is for mental health.
The door to the waiting room floor flies open.
She looks up when she hears someone jogging in the waiting
room, panting sensually.
Hey, is that babe from last week?
I wonder if he remembers me.
Hey, dinosaur.
Dinosaur?
What?
I'm sorry.
That is her.
These guys are really fizzling ourselves.
Getting red hot and stressed.
Something she feels like it's hard to breathe.
As if her juicy throat is being squeezed tight.
Oh, how do you know that I?
Your name?
I heard overheard Dr. Poljistat calling you into his office
last week, remember?
We gotta eat him.
Quick, quick, eat him.
I wrote, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
bring my cat never done anything weird with my cat oh yeah
right unless she feels reassured her heart is still pounding
in her throat and her mouth looks very small due to the
enormousness of her press because of the tension.
Our what took you.
They're they're they're solid.
They're oh dear.
I hope I did not come across this full-on creepy crawler
because I remember your name.
Don't come across creepy yeah no I mean you remember no you
don't worry about it I mean it was just such a unique exotic
name that I don't know for some reason it's
stuck don't worry I see it as a compliment I'm glad as long
as doesn't know my secret he's hot so he can't make mistake
that's so true he's hot so he You're not gonna tell me your
appointment is in five minutes, are you?
Uh, yes, it is.
Oh, you must be kidding me.
Oh, why does God give the hardest fights to the most
beautiful people?
Am I early again?
I really need to change my clock to date.
Oh, same here.
The daylight savings time.
Well, at least then I won't have to be bored in the next
five minutes.
You didn't ask me how boring I can be.
Did I really just say that?
Why do I feel so comfortable with him?
The most beautiful imbos.
Especially now with someone as attractive as him.
I bet his crotum is you.
You don't have to play fetch, you know, guys?
It's for fetch.
She loves...
Well...
Challenges to not get bored, accepted.
I'm sorry, I'm so wet, by the way.
Wait, I don't even know his name yet.
The man gestured to his tone body, dressed in sweat, that
looks like he just worked out.
I'm normally really not this moist.
Inhale his scent.
Dinosaur, no hesitation.
He's like, it's there.
See, this is why we don't need a vote on anything.
I know what you're going to choose anyway.
I'm basically picking your votes.
And hence this intense aroma.
You know, to get to know each other more, you know?
It's like when dogs dip each other's butts, guys.
I'm just trying to get to know more about this Kimbo.
That accidentally bites her lower lips while looking at
sweat-covered shiny bicep.
It would be arousing if it didn't smell so bad.
when she sees her own reflection, staring back at her in his
sweat.
Get a hold of yourself, DeeDee, dinosaur.
I just came back from a tense day of dancing.
Oh, see, he doesn't mind, guys.
He doesn't mind.
Oh, really?
Dancing?
I really like that, too.
Are you serious?
Awesome.
Yeah, I really challenged myself, but I couldn't really
concentrate today because the whole time, I had the song,
ding, ding, dong, we are the champions.
This crazy frog stuck you.
Me too!
Oh, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding,
ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding,
ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding ding, ding, ding,
ding, ding, ding, ding, ding ding ding ding, ding, ding ding
ding ding, ding, ding ding ding ding ding.
Wait, he's a cat lover, loves dancing, and he loves music
that is made solely for the purpose of being liked too?
I must be dreaming.
That's a beautiful song, isn't it?
But tonight, I'm going to take it easy.
First, I'll take a shower.
Now I'm going to sit on the couch to watch my favorite
movie, Extra Large Cheese Pizza.
Me too!
Oh.
I don't think I know that one.
same things.
Then it would be scary at how much we would be on the same
page.
The nervousness that Dee Dee Dizer fell in an avid earlier
has completely disappeared.
Her...
Are still rock hard, by the way.
He's not my husband, you know.
Mr. Robson, I knew what you were talking about.
I just wanted to come across, whatever.
I mean...
It's my cat.
He is very cute and sweet.
Speak up, don't you, cat.
I can't hear you.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
You might have to turn up the bot.
I think your volume might have cut out.
You might have actually muted the bot if you couldn't hear
that.
What's your cat's name?
Relaxor.
I love that little guy, you know.
Honestly, I just don't know.
what i would do about him i know what you mean oh what if a
charming smile that can hypnotize her the man smiles
gratefully then the conversation suddenly interrupted by a
door to dr leon's office swaying open dd dinosaur with
double d's please come in okay dd dinosaur stands up due to
the law laws of gravity different parts of her body
gracefully jiggled.
Doki, that take wasn't good.
Got it.
Go back and reshoot.
Gordon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, before I go, what's your name anyway?
Dr. Leon.
Are you dumb or something?
Anyway, come in.
We will start a memory test.
Alright, we're on week...
How many weeks?
Guys, how many weeks are there?
Dr. Leon sits down at his desk and looks through some of his
paperwork.
While reading, he holds onto his glasses as if that will
make them work better.
A full year.
There's no way.
There's 52 weeks.
What would I do?
I'll sit down.
But what smack her buttocks slap down on the cheese.
Yeah, how many weeks are in a year, guys?
How are you doing this week?
I'm still a bit nervous.
I'm still not sure if this is whole therapy.
It's something for me.
But I must admit, I'm starting to notice I'm feeling a lot
better lately.
It's all thanks to you.
I appreciate you saying that, but you're doing all the heavy
lifting in more ways than one.
Didi Dinosaur looks away shyly.
The only one that does the real heavy lifting is my spine.
Because of a gigantic jug.
As I said, she needs help, guys.
Don't worry.
I will sacrifice myself to help the greater good.
As I said before, this week is a time of memory test.
Hmm.
Not only because you seen I forgot my very easy remember
name, but also because you forgot that last week I tried to
plant a seed of distrust about that mysterious man in the
waiting room.
Thanks, game.
I wouldn't have noticed if you didn't tell me.
I know.
I was staring at her beautiful eyes, guys.
he did dinosaur staring at his broad shoulders I wish he
planted a seed okay I know what you said but honestly he
seems like a great guy to me look again I can't say anything
personal about him because of the whole doctor patient comp
oh my god maybe he's like a dinosaur hunter or something and
blah blah blah but trust me when I say I have to be careful
and just nod a little bit too maybe you're right but will
you be right we're gonna find out today in the memory test
dr leon takes a stack of cards from his desk and spreads the
cards face down try to find as many pairs of the same card
as possible be aware there is a time limit okay i got this
guys are you ready for the memory test um oh um oh but what
if i get a low score I'll give him, like, low expectations.
Don't be afraid.
Dumb people rarely realize that they are stupid.
That's why I'm not dumb.
All right, here we go.
Bam!
Easy.
I finished the game.
That was so easy for me.
That answer speculates about whether her IQ may be a genius
level.
This was just the first round.
It gets harder.
Oh no.
Bam!
Done.
Nice.
Are you starting to understand the game?
That's...
No, it was so easy.
It was so soft.
Yes, I think so.
But there's still some duplicate cards in the game.
Oh, whoa, my God.
Wait, I'm starting now.
Then she suddenly noticed something about I'm so locked in.
I don't know.
Guys, we're gaming here.
We're trying to lock in.
Don't get distracted.
Am I really that lonely?
Or do those images remind me of something?
We gotta win, guys.
Don't get distracted.
Time.
Leon sees dinosaur blushing while looking at his cards.
He proudly proudly nods.
Do you like them?
I made them myself.
Uh, yeah.
They kind of remind me of...
Fruit?
Yeah, I'm a real foodie.
That's what.
Oh, no.
There's getting too many cards.
There's too many cards, guys.
No.
Okay.
We're fine.
All right.
Add another one.
We're here.
We're good.
The hot dog.
The best fruit.
But you're doing great.
Deity dinosaurs staring at cards that they are praying while
her heart rate increases.
Oh my god, keep it up.
There's too many cards now.
Okay, nope, that big plant.
Nope, the big plant is here.
And then the hot dog was here.
And then, oh, where was the apples?
Yes.
Okay, the melon was here.
And then peach was here.
okay you're a natural talent DD dance just tells wag us with
enthusiasm when Leon compliments here alright oh my god okay
it was here yep and then oh that was carrots there you go I
saw it before oh my god there's too many there's too many
there's too many many things on the screen now okay what's
this oh no oh no i'm there's too many i can't remember
anymore all right there rice thank you for the gift of ship
thank you thank you that was close the channel rushed from
the revealing image has me td dinosaur is sweaty hot she
looks up at leon and hesitates for a moment like take off my
shoes for a moment leon looks up and surprised and then
shyly nods in agreement look it's like the the shoes are are
are cutting my circulation guys i can't concentrate oh wow
did he think she sees leon flushing but there is no time to
dwell on this because the next round is already starting
guys we're locked guys guys guys we're gaming we're just
trying to game We're just, we're just trying the game right
now.
We're, okay.
All right.
Okay.
I remember the meatballs were here.
And then where's the cherries?
Where's the cherries again?
Oh, where is the cherry?
Oh, I don't remember where things are anymore.
Okay, there it is.
Uh, that was, we're here.
Okay.
And then, uh, Peach was here.
Nano was here.
Oh, there you go.
Melon.
Wow.
Beautiful.
What did you just call me?
Adrenaline is rushing through DD dinosaurs voluptuous body
while she was fighting instinct to roar in excitement.
She looks at the card of pictures of above average moist
throat and then back at leap.
Hey, guys, it's above average.
Look at your lip list.
The mouse abducted leap.
Leon Procedo.
Oh, okay, okay.
It's so, guys.
Guys, I can't believe the air conditioning broke down guys i
oh my god it's so hot in this room keep going keep going
okay all right oh that's way too many now it is way too many
oh my god
okay all right there we go oh yes impressive.
Out of sheer enthusiasm, DD Dinosaur actually likes to have
the sensual ground slip.
Should you hear that?
What if you realize I'm actually a dinosaur?
But luckily, Leon is too invested in the game to notice.
I'm doing really, really well, guys.
Okay, last round.
Oh, my God.
Okay, I remember that one was here.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
This one was here.
Where is it?
Oh, there it is.
Uh.
Oh, my God.
I'm so confused right now.
Oh, there are so many bananas.
There are so many bananas.
They're...
They're all bananas.
They're just all bananas.
Okay, there you go.
We made it.
Oh!
He dies or did it.
High on the dopamine, rushing through her veins.
She jumps up, cheering, and gives Leah a big smack on his
cheeks.
I told you.
I told you I was locked in.
I won't get distracted.
I didn't even, I didn't get distracted.
It's as though she's being electrocuted by the wave of
goosebumps that follows from pressing her wet lips against
his face.
Oh.
I'm so sorry.
I let myself go for a moment.
She see Leon nervously trying to avoid eye contact while
blushing a little.
He then tries his best to muster his professionalism back
up.
Leon then studies the notes on his paperwork closely.
It's the adrenaline, guys.
It's the adrenaline of doing...
I survived 10 rounds.
You know, it's like a victory, hooray, a victory reward.
You made it through 10 rounds.
Wow, a world record.
Leon is perplexed.
I'm really impressed with you.
But not just the looks of what smart...
See, I told him I'm so smart.
He's sandwiched for a moment.
My apologies.
That wasn't very professional.
I don't know what came over me.
Did he dance or...
giggles.
He probably says that to everyone who is attractive and
intelligent.
But what did you think of the test?
I worked quite hard in it, and you're the first one to play
it.
Don't worry, I can add a criticism.
Does the title roll off of the tongue nicely, you think?
It did seem a bit familiar.
I don't know.
I don't even know what the fuck is the second option.
I'm going to pick it.
Okay.
Thanks for coming.
No!
left seems meaner they both seem mean apparently don't keep
i didn't even know what that option means i'm bumble it's
okay i have three more i have 50 i have 49 more weeks to go
guys in a year dd dinosaur is lying bed with mr robson
snuggle warmly against her you try so Wash your feet, bud.
Okay, I will say, I can tell what kind of fetish the devs
have right now.
You can tell.
I know it's very subtle, chat.
It's very subtle, but I'm happening to notice a pattern of
what fetishes the devs have.
While I'm making this, it's very subtle, though.
You might not see it.
What could it be?
I just took a naked shower already.
What a day, huh?
Did Dr. Leon really accidentally tell me he finds the
attractive?
I never see him lose his composure like this before.
It's kind of made him adorable.
I can't deny that it made me feel good.
Especially since it came from someone with such impressive
traps.
The trapezius muscle or monkhood monk's hood muscle is a
diamond-shaped muscle.
at the top of the back in human anatomy.
But I was kind of shocked when that mysterious sexy man just
called out my name.
You know what they say, don't you?
So thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Did you think he noticed that I reacted so intensely to it?
Sometimes I think it might just be easier.
People knew that I'm actually a dinosaur that emerged about
230 million years ago in the tricycle as a split within the
broader group of dinosauriformis.
It would be just so easy, guys.
But I'm afraid that people will not accept me.
Maybe he or Leon will understand.
They seem like such a warm people to me.
Or maybe they'll never talk to me again because I'm such a
freak.
I'm blind, Turkey.
Can you smell it out for me?
Mr. Broken Bot, thank you.
Listen, chat, thank you, thank you.
me for who i am i will just eat them mr robinson is okay is
just doing what cats do guys he's just doing what cats do is
licking his anus with great precision look he's trying to
clean himself guys stop watching dd dinosaur let's uh giggle
at the site robinson always puts a smile on her face but
during moments like these where she feels insecure and
anxious He was there for me from the first moment I met him.
It's been years now, but I still remember it as if it was
yesterday.
Didi Dinosaur looks up, trying to activate a flashback.
I still remember him lying there.
It was a rainy night when Didi Dinosaur was sobbing on her
way home from a bad day.
Who was he?
I just need his number.
I just want to talk to him very nicely.
How could they hurt you?
When she suddenly heard a strange noise coming from the
alley.
What's that?
She could barely hear the sound above the sound of the rain
splashing on the street.
She ate him.
That's why it went bad.
Oh, man.
Not another one.
Mr. Robinson promised and got rid of this bottom two rib.
And his deed.
Thank you.
The super chat.
Yeah, I just want to talk to him.
But even when she thinks back to the moment, she can still
hear that desperate cry.
A few final breaths, desperately trying to squeeze the
helpless sound out of an exhaustive set of lungs from the
bottom of a dumpster.
When she opened the dumpster and carefully moved some bags,
the faint sound becomes a little louder.
Then she saw the bag, the bag that Mr. Robson was in.
A bag with just enough accidental air holes to barely keep
him alive.
When she opened the bag, she saw him, curled up, shivering
from the cold, so thin and stark that it really made his
six-pack pop.
He's so dehydrated, guys.
But still, it was a very sad moment because of the almost
dying part.
Mr. Robson had a tough life.
Mr. Robson was just a cute little kitten.
as a model cat.
Day in and day out.
He was placed under blazing hot steel lights so that his
owners could take pictures for things like memes, social
media, greeting cards, and similar things in chat in that
vein.
They only gave him just enough food so that he wouldn't act
up and stay calm while they put him in awkward positions in
funny outfits in front of the camera.
I would never do that to dad.
But Robston didn't know any better because my outfits are
really cute.
He gladly did it for his owners.
Even under the hot lights, he cherished those moments
because they're only moments when his owners really paid
attention to him.
when things were wrong the day he got dressed up as a cowboy
although it looked very cute and funny he had not eaten for
two days when he was tired to muster up the strength to stay
on the rocking horse that is an expensive cat the folded
ears cat that shit is purebred and those cats are like
really expensive he felt dizzy for a moment and slipped off
the horse with his cute little kitten body he didn't feel
the impact he made from rolling off the table he only saw a
bright light oh my god it's so sad i can't remember what
happened next yeah the scottish fold but when he woke up he
heard his owners discussing what to do with him they sounded
concerned and even though robson was very weak and made and
feel good only then did he feel the burning sensation of his
burn on his paw he had rolled into the studio lights during
his fall and his hair had been burned away by the heat on
the way to the vet Robson was very scared he could not see a
thing and was not used to the loud hum of the car he had
been a car many times before but he knew he had to put on
free face so his owners wouldn't about him.
Mr. Robson wondered if his owners had maybe put him in his
bag because they knew he was very scared of the vet and it
would be less scared for him this way.
They're so considerate.
Then the car stopped.
He felt that he was being picked up feeling the texture of
the burlap sack scraping against his wound as he was lifted
up.
He staged strong.
He knew they were almost at the vent now.
But then he found himself suddenly being thrown down.
The chaos made it difficult for him to hear why his owner's
muffled voices were saying.
But when the water started to seep in from the bottom of the
bag, Robson realized he wasn't going to the vent.
He had been thrown into the water.
This has to be a mistake, right?
My owner would never do this right.
right confusing and desperate thoughts race through his mind
the water slowly rose to his chest muscles his neck and up
to his chin funny enough the feeling of panic decreased the
higher the water rose we mean now I can finally get some
rest This is like my Tom and Jerry episode.
As he thought this, he felt just how exhausted he was.
In the past years, as if he was finally allowing himself to
relax, now that he no longer had to pretend.
A tear welled up in the corner of his eyes.
Not because this was the end, but because even then, He
couldn't believe that his owners would do this.
As the tears run down his cheeks towards the rising water,
he slowly closed his eyes.
Save him!
His owner's voice sounded panicky from outside the back,
while Robson now finds himself being carried away by the
water.
Robson opens his eyes.
I knew it.
Then he hears the voice of his other owner.
Hurry!
I told you guys.
I told you.
The owner accidentally tripped and fell and the bag
accidentally went into the river.
But it's already too late.
The water was already up to his eyes.
But despite that, Mr. Robson feels happy.
Happy because he was so wrong about his owners suddenly the
water descends at a rapid pace from the holes at the bottom
of the bag and robson feels himself being lifted his owners
open the bag carefully but hastily robson fights the
instinct to squint as the bright sun like shines in as they
open the bag just so he can see his owners again as soon as
possible but when his killer little cat head peeks out from
the edge of the bag.
The first thing he sees are not the familiar faces of his
owners, but a lens of a camera pointed at him.
The years of being a cute kitten were long behind him, and a
burn mark isn't cute enough to be put on memes.
and happy birthday cards.
They threw him in the water just to be fished out again and
filmed it.
The video was then called Saving a Cat from Drowning.
The video received millions of views and its owners became
heroes.
I told you guys, IRL content, guys.
IRL content is not going to be the pain of our existence.
I told you.
Once again, money was made from his suffering.
Dozens of videos later, it took him longer and longer to
recover.
Mr. Robson was getting older and more exhausted than ever
before.
But his owners...
were happy so he was happy too until the day when they got a
new cat to replace him after years of treating him like
trash they eventually placed him in the trash wrapped in a
garbage bag dumped in a What Robson remembers most about
this is that they didn't even say bye to him.
This time there was no one around to save him.
If Didi Diaser wasn't there that night, no one would have
opened the bag before the garbage was picked up the next
day.
I still remember it so vividly.
Those big, frightened eyes that looked at me when I opened
that bag.
A frame that even his cry for help was something he would be
punished for.
But when I asked him if he wanted to come home with me, that
anxious looked, turned into a grateful smile.
Look at that.
Not only Does she have a big personality?
But she also has a big heart.
And even when there was no reason for him to trust anyone
else, he was there for me that night.
He picked me up and took me home.
Mistakes, the scheme has finally started to do it for me.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
She has such a big heart.
that's where she keeps her heart guys that's why they're so
big it's because they needed space for a big heart she's
just perfect since then home finally feels like home meow
next year in bed Mr. Robson looks at her questionly.
He then rubs his head on her as if he could read her
thoughts.
He is an old cat now.
But he looks great, by the way.
We're an old cat.
He looks great.
What's his routine?
I can't watch this side for thinking, but those super chat
thinking, because you're crying, right?
The tears, right?
You're crying.
It's so sad.
It's so hard to work when you're the tears but he has fully
recovered the hair on his paws grown back and love his burns
are so visible his shave legs grays an eddy dinosaur sigh so
cute i love him the phone at a bedside table vibrates as the
screen lights up one new message received She gets a bad
feeling in her tone, abdomen, as she hesitates to open the
massage message.
It's the same number as last week.
I have another question for you.
But think carefully about whether this is how you really
feel.
Are you ready?
She looks at her phone with a confused look.
What kind of strange thing is this?
I know this is my phone.
I meant that message.
question who is this she's visibly started when she merely
receives the next message the message only contains a
question a question that although a strange actually makes
her think can having a pet be a deal-breaker for you in a
potential relationship she doesn't know if it's because of
the therapies for sessions or if it's just an interesting
dilemma.
I was just plain bored.
But she decides to answer in all honesty.
Lafayette, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
First time watching.
What a great stream to come in.
No.
The more the merrier.
What's before she can even think about whether she fully
agrees with her own in fact, if they have 20 dogs, I'd be
happy.
I won't walk all of them.
them they have to walk it she received yet another message i
can create an army interesting did you know that 81.8 people
give this answer is that so wow how many dogs is too many i
need those dog shirts to go somewhere yeah you're right It's
getting late Robson you kiss your mother with that mouth.
Oh no.
He's from the old guys.
He's old.
Okay.
He's from he's from the later generations He in the in back
then he they were able to say that.
Oh, yeah, sorry
You unlocked an outfit yay What did I get?
Oversized shirt.
Unlocked.
Equip the outfit on the...
Guys, we're...
Yeah, no.
We can't cover up something that beautiful.
It's also so hot outside, guys.
It's summer, guys.
It's summer vacation.
We can't let her overheat.
Yeah, she's a reptile.
10 minutes early.
Luckily, well in time.
I guess there wasn't any need to rush after all.
Ew, I'm so hot.
See, guys, we can't put an oversized shirt on her.
She's so hot right now.
That's why she's dripping.
It's from all the sweat.
Waves her shirt in hopes of cooling herself down.
The movement makes her king-size breast slap against her
chest.
Nothing sexual.
It's just basic anatomy, guys.
Guys, it's just basic biological human body stuff.
Lady Dinosaur takes a seat in the empty waiting room It's so
weird that I dressed up this time Hoping that I would see
him again That's right guys, she wore an earring this time
Maybe he knew that He'd probably think I was some crazy wall
crawler or something It's kind of weird to think that I'll
see him again anyway Actually, it was early for his
appointment twice already Maybe it's for the best Dr. Leon
probably isn't warning me about him for nothing Still, she
decides to fantasize about the man for a moment.
Maybe I should...
His veins.
She fantasizes about the throbbing veins that are wrapped
around them, the serious man's arms, like eels.
Oh, the man...
Think about all that blood flowing through that veins, guys.
Oh, he is a very healthy man.
He's a...
Just think about all that thick blood traveling through that
body.
Can we get DD Dinosaur collapse?
Crystal, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
His heart is so healthy right now.
When he sees DD Dinosaur, he slowly starts rushing and tries
to take a seat in the waiting room.
Not chelantly.
With a big smirk, Didi Dinosaur looks at the clock and then
back at that beefcake.
Early again, are you?
I'm starting to think you can't tell time.
The man looks at her playfully.
That's because I was always late for my telling time
lessons.
X-D!
I laugh at this joke.
You're so funny.
Bro, you're so funny.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
Didi Dinosaur doesn't think this joke is funny at all.
Oh my god, did anyone tell you you're the funniest man I've
ever met?
Oh my god, huh?
He starts blushing.
I'm so in.
Tender moment.
Yeah.
Well, actually, if I'm being honest, I mean, he starts to
stumble over his words.
To be honest, cringe as F.
I want to be honest with you.
But not about to say, I'm afraid you're really going to see
me.
as a full-on crazy fuck Skywalker.
I'm sure it won't be that bad.
This time, I'm not really early, or well, not by accident.
I just really enjoyed our conversation last time.
And, well, I was hoping I'd run into you today, even if I
got a little earlier, don't get in.
He clearly sees how he finds it difficult to explain.
Oh, he's so embarrassed.
I don't know if you agree, but to me, our conversation
somehow feels...
so familiar so fast more than the conversation with dr
pojestad even is that crazy oh man i am a sound so insane
he's so cute and he's embarrassed oh he's such a himbo he's
so cute when he's so stupid maybe he likes it if i say all
right do i be understanding or say yep Bo, thank you for the
super chat.
Thank you, thank you, thank you for the absolute cinema
dokey.
Thank you.
You should say thank you to the member.
Oh, yep.
Yep, it is a bit crazy.
But so is Caramel seesaw.
And we all seem to act as if that's normal as well.
Beatty Dinosaur feels relieved and secretly lets strange
yourself for hoping to see him again today.
She sneaks a sneak peek at his voice.
I don't think you need to sneak a peek there.
It's just all over him.
You can't unsee it.
That makes any shirt look tight.
Oh my god.
She's letting out the animal inside her.
Let the beast.
down a few times to catch some of the scent all right guys
while you listen to this music i'm gonna get more water i
ran out of water i'm so thirsty right now i know you've
been terrorizing me yeah i'm always i knew you lost your
mind when you dropped that bomb girl are you crazy yeah you
must be crazy i've been thinking lately baby it's you
put it on me but baby it's you line like all right but take
your stuff back baby it's you
i'm back
rice forward and my Nick, Neppers, Alan.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Some wrecked house smell with your tongues.
Oh, man.
He's just trying to get to know him better, guys.
Say, what's your name anyway?
I already lost count of what week we're on, Zelf used.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Next thing, thank you for the super chat.
He hesitates for a moment.
My name is...
hunk.
I know, I know.
It's a dumb name.
But my parents are both obsessed with looks.
I can never live up to their expectations.
My mother was a model.
And my father is an actor.
And a plastic surgeon.
Day in, day out.
They're only busy with their appearances.
This is truly one of the key themes of all time.
Mr. Donald, this one's for you.
For the people with the special interest in dinosaurs.
This is like the game of the century for them.
Sometimes it even seems like looks are the only thing that
matters to them.
He emotionally tears into his face for a moment.
Don't cry.
You're too beautiful to cry.
Bear, coincidentally, this is also the direction of DD
dinosaurs' half-bear feet.
That's why.
I don't know if you guys got this stuff.
little hint there but there's a particular fetish that the
devs have in this game and it's very subtle it's like if you
blink it and you miss a type of moment you know not me I
think the inside is the most important super cute the names
hunk I've heard worse hunk I've heard worse but you just
have to think about it like this at least try to
At least her name is Doki Bird.
At
least it's not DD Donosaur.
I'll try to treat her as DD Doki Bird.
That's fucked up.
I got him.
Doki Five dead.
And honestly, I think I could piss you just by.
She's just jealous.
Guys, she's so jealous.
She's so jealous.
And I'm actually flirting?
I normally never do that.
I appreciate the compliment.
But to be honest, I don't like being that attractive.
I'm done with peeing.
Just see me as a piece of sexy meat that they want to have
sex with.
much more than that.
Didi Dinosaur stares at his breast while she barely listens
to him because he's so attractive.
it only makes me feel so lonely.
Gus, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, Evan.
Chat.
Didi Dinosaur's heart skips a beat.
Wait a minute.
Lonely?
That's how I feel too.
Oh my God, we're just so similar.
Tear almost wells up in the corner rise.
And then the door to Dr. Leon's office swing open.
The goggles, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank
you.
Didi Dinosaur with big knockers, come in.
It's time for your appointment.
Oh my god.
Oh, we're getting so close, guys.
He even gave me a nickname.
As she stands up, Didi Dinosaur looks at Honk with concern
and places her claw on his muscular shoulder.
I feel sorry for you.
Don't worry.
The doctor says that I've applied oi-man for two weeks.
He'll just go away.
Wait, apply for what?
Where?
Come in.
Alright, I'm at week four.
I have six more weeks to go.
Give me one moment.
In the meantime, please take a seat.
Dr. Leon says while he's sitting at his desk intently
looking through a book, Didi Dinosaur noticed that he looks
very...
Very intelligent, doing it.
The cover of the book reads, How to Pretend Your Reading for
Beginners.
Hmm, interesting.
Oh, he's doing really well, though.
He puts the book down and takes off his glasses.
While collapsing his hands together, he leans his imposing
body towards her.
I know you previously had doubts about coming back here
every week, so I think it's great that you're going through
with it.
Ooh, wait, I'm getting brave.
Good to see you again.
While hearing yourself talk, she's shocked by her own flirty
tone and tries to overcompensate by adding bitch to it.
Oh, because we're tight like that.
For today, I prepared a coordination test.
A coordination test?
What does that entail?
We will test whether you can visualize in your head.
You can translate, you can also translate onto paper.
Don't worry.
It sounds more complicated than it is.
Basically, we're just going to be drawing.
During the first round of this test, we'll see how good you
have visualized something you see every day.
Preferably something you care about.
Oh, I can do that.
Something that you associate with joy.
Like my sweet cat, Mr. Robson?
Correct.
I'll give you 60 seconds to draw Mr. Robson as best as you
can from memory.
Oh, I got this.
I have so much time with Mr. Robson.
Yes, I am.
I'm not that good at drawing.
You're not that good at warming yourself out of the
situation either.
You still try to.
Okay, here we go.
Alright, I can do this.
And then it's like...
And then he's like...
How do I draw six packs?
Is that...
And he has beans here.
And then he has his nipples here.
and then he's like
I think I'm right though oh wait but they're like toes
they're like human toes so it's like this and then he has
like I think that's pretty accurate guys there you go that's
Mr. Robson where is the tent over there it's on the left
side all right time's up i used to be an artist i don't know
if you guys can tell up uh oh yeah i forgot the badly neck
i'm so i'm so i'm so preoccupied with his abs let's see leon
doesn't move a muscle while holding the drawing in front of
him those are his veins by the way if you're wondering these
are his veins they're very thick briefly looks at dd
dinosaur and then back to the drawing are you proud of
yourself oh my god it wait i can't tell the difference
what do you mean you're not good that was a mastery crystal
thank you for the secret chat thank you oh my god i forgot
his pexcell it's one to one only thing I will say is I
forgot to draw his his pecs I know I'm so I'm so
disappointed in myself I know I can't believe I forget
something as iconic as his big pecs oh and his neck yeah
it's kind of this thing of it's kind of action pain you
don't know what my cat looks like maybe he does look like
this I'm pretty proud I am pretty proud all right for the
second round we're gonna do things a little differently I
don't want to ask you to firmly hold on to your pencil and
then close your We'll see if you can visualize specific
topics without looking.
In all words, drawing in the dark.
Didi Dinosaur closes her eyes gracefully.
She finds it very exciting because she cannot see what Leon
is up to now.
Could he be secretly watching me now?
Meanwhile, Leon picks something up from his nails and
wonders what it is.
Oh, gross.
Leon, that's not sexy.
I would not like to ask you to draw the following.
You got 10 seconds.
Are you ready?
Yes.
Start.
Where's my paper?
I think I got it.
I think I got it here.
That's an apple.
I hope that's where the paper is.
Time is up.
Let's see the results.
You can now open your eyes.
Oh, you know what?
That, yeah.
You see, the earth does really well.
that's a circle the circle connect connected in a way like
well it was with your eyes closed I guess whoops got to
distract I'm willing to be an iPad kid for a little bit
filled with pride Didi does it looks at a drawing and then
confidently looks nods at Leon all right for the next round
we're gonna make it just a little bit more difficult I like
you to take ask you to draw a clock in Tark including all
the numbers at the hands at 5 o'clock wait okay okay this is
a little hard because it requires me to count um that's not
my strongest skill please close your eyes um okay ready okay
five o'clock okay one two three four five and then this is
okay wait where's the six six seven eight nine ten eleven
twelve there we go it's not looking so good guys now put oh
time is up let's see the results um okay you know it's 12
two where the fuck wait what where's 11 okay 10 11 okay
there you go 10 11 and that fucked up on the 12.
I didn't know where to put the... Okay, this was me trying
to draw a circle within the circle and then I ran... I
mean...
100 and 112.
It wasn't so bad.
I just accidentally put one on the top.
Where there's what?
It's right here.
1, 11, where's... 10, 11 is here.
11, and then 12, and I put one here.
There's one is here.
All right, one, one.
No, that's one over there.
It's right there.
That's the one.
I started here.
And then 12 was here.
I drew the two too far away.
I was rushing.
Look, he said it was beautiful, guys.
Only my therapist is allowed to critique me.
Quite beautiful for abstract art.
Didi Dancer looks at her drawing with satisfaction and
wonders whether she might have bad powers because she
functions so well in the dark.
Guys, guys, it's like, it symbolizes how we have so much
time in the world that that's why we have 112 hours, guys.
It basically symbolizes how life sometimes feels like
there's so much time in the world and that the clock cannot
accurately represent time and how we personally feel in the
inside, you know?
We're almost done.
You know the message?
The symbolism behind the painting?
But we're bumping up the difficulty just a bit more.
For this round, I would like to ask you to draw a human
face, including all features with your eyes because okay all
right this is this might be the hardest okay
okay i'll start with a circle and then eyes and then no and
then the smiley face ears and then hair and then neck and
there i did it time is up okay let's see the results feel
free to open your eyes now oh my god that's basically what i
drew that's it oh my god oh that's the best works oh my god
that is exactly what i saw in my head too um i'm a prodigy
how does she do it it's kind of good i know right It's got
to be pretty all right.
Not bad, but you forgot the eyebrows.
Oh, yeah, that's true.
I did.
I did forget the eyebrows.
Okay, it's time for the last round.
This is improvisation round.
During this round, you can draw whatever you want.
A test of impulsivity and creativity.
Whatever comes to mind, even the possibility here are
endless.
people still feel that's more stressful than a clear
objective.
I have, I know exactly what I want to do.
D.D.
Dinosaur starts stressing because of the difficult
assignment.
Free will?
It can't be.
But don't worry.
If it makes you feel better, it's not like these drawings
will ever end up in a museum anyway.
Nothing personal.
I know, it's pretty amateur work.
D.D.
Dinosaur feels relieved by his insult.
Are you ready?
Here we go.
Okay, I got it.
Okay, there we go.
I got it.
You're done, man.
What?
Leo?
Dang it!
Leon softly whispers in her right ear.
Whoa!
That's, yeah, that's it.
Oh, my God.
Sends a wave of goosebumps.
over Didi dinosaur's voluptuous body.
It's like her goosebumps have goosebumps.
Wait a minute.
What have you done?
Huh?
Oh!
Didi dinosaur opens your eyes by- Did you ruin my empathy?
Like, they're sad right there.
Do you feel it?
Do you like my little smiley face?
I'm so sorry.
I couldn't see where it's trying because my eyelids were
covering my eye.
Okay, why was he not supervising this?
Why was he not supervising this entire experiment?
Leon tries to wipe the art piece away to no availability.
Like, what was he doing?
What was he doing?
But when Leon sees Didi Daedicers, uh, worried, look.
He is startled.
He was very distracted by something.
Maybe two big reasons.
It's okay.
He says in a soothing voice.
Can I make...
How can I...
Possibly make it up to you, doctor.
The answer looks intently in Leon's eyes.
Well, honestly.
There is something I could think of that would like from
you.
Leon just barely dares to look at her.
If you ever want to teach me how to draw a cat like that, I
would really appreciate it.
Freeman, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you,
prop, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
See, I'm so helpful.
I'm such a good person.
I'm teaching her how to draw cats for morale.
He holds up a drawing, Mr. Ross, and she drew earlier and
studies it with a satisfied expression.
Sweet little guy, he comments.
See, guys?
So PG.
stuff, guys.
That was my entire plan.
I'll hold you to that.
You're really talented, you know?
There is a moment of silence as they look deeply into each
other's eyes.
But then do you notice that Gileon nervously looks away for
a moment?
I swear to God if he looks at her feet.
I swear to God.
Well, I think we put enough effort in for today.
Will you be back next week?
I think so.
She hesitates because she knows that she continues therapy.
She will eventually have to share her say, don't take shame
him.
That she is one of those full-on reptilian species.
I'm sure I shouldn't fix the table.
No, don't worry about that.
You should probably first fix that little piece of snow.
nodding your nose.
DD Dinosaurs shocked and out-reflexed and immediately wipes
her arm across her nose.
A dumb choice because everyone knows that now the booger is
somewhere on her arm, which is probably even more
disgusting.
See you next week.
For the rest of the day, DD Dinosaurs wondered how long
she'd been walking around with booger on her nose while
anyone's saying anything about it at all.
They were just so distracted, DD Dinosaurs.
They weren't focusing on that face.
He'll He'll He'll Ditty dinosaurs exhausted And flopped into
her bed Without showering Her legs spread open Oh she's man
spreading So her feet are soft
Next year Mr. Robson is Purring Purring in her arm Up his
sweet little head He'll Aw, he is so cute.
This was another intense day.
But I do feel good about it.
Is therapy good for me after all?
Meow.
Yes, I did see him again.
His name is Hunk.
What a unique name, huh?
a modest man I don't know why he talks to dr. Leon Wow
you're right I know that's not a my business I'm still quite
curious Wow no I don't think it's his it's for his catnip
addiction that's generally exclusively a cat thing what are
you playing I'm playing an FPS game due to this exciting day
she is more comfortable than usual, and she starts to doze
off almost immediately.
Her phone!
Which is super coincidentally placed between her legs
vibrates!
Wow, what a coincidence!
Yeah, just a pew pew game.
Um...
You know, an FPS, you know?
It stands for...
D.D.
Dinosaur gets startled.
Huh?
Another message?
Again?
Are you ready to be honest?
First Batonker suitor.
Huh?
Yes, mom.
Message sent.
What do you find the most attractive characteristic in a
potential partner?
Is that a confidence or humor?
I would say humor more.
message sent she start again when she receives a message
back almost immediately one new message she hesitates for a
moment but then opens the message anyway did you know that
this is what most people think status 7.2 9.5 yeah I was
like is that a comment or humor and humor is a big deal huh
is that true she puts her phone on her bedside table and
plots back Let's go, I'm in the majority, guys.
Let's go.
Yay.
A serious look on her face.
Who keeps sending me these kinds of things?
Whether it's a wrong number or not?
D.D.
Dinosaur cannot deny.
That is interesting to think about.
I have to say, that humor does remind me of Honky's so
funny.
Maybe that's why.
I'm already secretly looking forward to next.
week I know I know I'm so normal of all the people that play
this game guys I'm the majority yeah of all the people who
play this game my the majority dude the average guys mm-hmm
but if it motivates me to go to therapy It might still help
me in the long run.
Anyway, I can't deny that Leon has also piped my interest.
Meow.
I know how it sounds.
It's weird to say because I barely know them.
Meow.
Who do I like more?
That's hard to say.
Oh, that is hard, guys.
So hard.
Do you want the Himbo or Omni Man?
Yes.
Himbo or Omni Man?
I was gonna say we couldn't explore, but guys, it's, I did
make progress with Omni Man though.
If only we had some sort of integration on stream that could
help us make this choice.
I'm gonna sit I feel like I want to get to know hunk more
though We already know a lot about Omni man So I want to
know more about hunk What is he gonna do?
He's so sad at the time We gotta fix him We can fix him We
can fix this depression With two very big solutions Didi
dinosaur dreams away for a moment Hmm Hunk Hunk For a
moment, she fantasizes about what it would be like if Hunk
were next to her right now.
But then, in the flash, as an unexpected lightning strike,
the flash fantasy turns into uncertainty.
But why would I even think about that?
As of anything, what even a spark of interest in me, if they
find out I was a monster, an actual dinosaur which emerged
about 230 million years ago in the Triassic Triassic era as
a display within the broader group a dinosaur reformist and
history channel goes so weird at 3 in the morning it's very
educational I will always be so alone that's a very
articulate and substantiated point you even made there.
Anyway, it's getting late.
Let's get some sleep.
BOW!
Robson, you really can't say that type of stuff in 2025
anymore.
Oh my god.
Robson slurred.
He's so cute though.
It's okay.
We forgive him.
He's so cute.
When Didi Dinosaur walks into the waiting room, she sees
Hunk already sitting there.
She noticed a knot in her stomach, which She always felt
before is less...
But you can in 2020.
That's true.
It's okay.
It's 2026 now.
Yeah, that's true.
Don't worry, he'll make a Google Docu.
And then everyone will forgive him.
I might have said that, but look at what this person said.
Release the alien files.
alone with hunk he dies or wants to play it cool but can't
contain the smile on the on the smile on her cold bloody
blooded face when she sees hunk sitting oh did i did i die
that they almost got oh my god okay she looks at the floor
shyly as she even better as she takes a seat next to him on
one of the hard uncomfortable chairs in the waiting room the
out the AI had to double check for a second and then the AI
was like no that's alright that I was like no that seems
right that seems fine a good morning hung it feels strange
to come by his name what a coincidence to see you here today
Good morning.
For some reason, he seems a little nervous.
He has a serious look on his appetizing face.
Still, he forces a smile at her.
I'll cheer him up.
Your veins look good today.
He takes a deep breath.
I need to talk to you.
I never heard him in such a serious tone before.
Is this going to be bad news?
I do respect you immensely I appreciate the conversations
we've had These eyes are not attentive But slightly
nervously I would even go as far as say that I feel like we
have Connection I agree Oh my god I want to share something
with you that's very important to me But man I'm terrified
that this is going to change Things between us Share
something He hesitates for a moment.
Then, he takes a deep breath and tend to muster up some
courage.
He then carefully slides his hands into his shorts.
Carefully.
He muddles himself as he appears to gently grab onto
something.
What else he couldn't show me?
He slowly, I told you.
I told you.
pockets, guys.
He slowly takes out a glass jar of his pocket.
There is a lid on it.
There are about 10 ants in the jar.
Oh my god, I knew there was something in his pocket, and he
is happy to see me.
Oh my god.
Ants in the pants.
He's taking it out.
There are about 10 ants in the jar.
Not an impressive amount of ants.
Impressive.
Thanks.
them all myself.
And that isn't as easy as it sounds as these little
creatures are tiny, fast, and fucking strong.
Did you know that?
Didi Dinosaur sees the weight has been lifted from Hunk's
shoulders now that he has shown his ass.
The stressed expression on his face turns to pride.
What?
This all happened too fast for me.
Hunk is too busy staring his hands to notice DD Dinosaurs in
sensitive comments.
Did you know that there is a spider called the Ant Spider?
The spider pretends to be an ant so it can live unnoticed
among the ant colony.
Follow me for more spider facts.
Can you imagine that?
The spider just lives among the population has no idea what
kind of monster the spider really is.
No one even noticed it's a spider and a liar.
Hunk couldn't be you DD Dinosaurs.
I bet it's feeling real ants.
Absolutely.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Did you guys directly smile as well?
Hunk is still staring enthusiastically into his pot.
Yep.
Really bizarre.
How cool is that, bro?
Living among the ants?
I wish I could do that, man.
I just love ants.
I can't believe he showed his ants on the first date.
Would you like to take an ant quiz?
Not really.
No.
Oh, I didn't really expect you to say no.
I prepared quite a few questions to.
Let him tell you about Aunt Stokey.
Didi Dinosaur finds his passion and enthusiasm endearing.
Hank Hunk wants to slide a jar back into his jacket pocket
for some wacky reason.
He misses.
Oh, how could you deny him of his ant quiz?
For some wacky reason, he misses, and a glass jar slips out
his hands.
Oh, the jar shatters on the ground with loud clatter.
Shock, Hank lets out a desperate cry.
No, my life's worth.
The dinosaur is not that emotionally invested in the ants,
that much.
No.
Why does it always happen to the most hunkiest of guys?
Why do bad things always happen to him?
No.
Hank, hunk, falls to his knees and desperately starts
searching for his ends.
Please, can you help me find the ants?
Hunk looks at Didi Dinosaur with pleading eyes.
But of course, a bird, natural-ish.
Didi Dinosaur pauses for a moment to leave room for a
compliment about impressive language skills.
Thanks for wanting to help me.
All right, we gotta find it.
Oh, it's like find my cat.
but with ants.
Oh my god, where are the ants?
What do the ants look like?
You guys see any ants?
Is that an ant?
Oh my god, I found one!
Hunk's eyes start to sparkle.
Okay, it's like they have like little...
The little ears.
No, that's not an ant.
Oh my, this is a lot harder.
There's 10 of them.
Okay, I found one here.
Oh my god.
There's more up here
I know it's time guys.
I'm trying.
They're so tiny
Lookie there is where where is there
Sealing oh my god.
There's one he's just hanging there.
Well, I found another one Nice job.
And that's number three.
Just shut the fuck up.
Oh my god.
Doki, they're right there.
They're right there, Doki.
Why can't you see it?
It's right there.
Oh my god.
Where is there?
That's that hat.
Hello.
Is that an ant?
Oh my god, I knew it.
The way it does look different from this angle, don't you
think?
Below the cactus, there's another cactus?
Oh, there is.
What do you mean?
There's no ants here.
Are they got ant there?
Okay, some of these ants are like different shaped ants.
They're not the same sized ants.
Oh my god, there's an ant right here.
Oh my god, I saw the little...
years.
Does that count?
I don't think... Oh, wait.
I see it!
I see you!
Didi Dazer gets down to all fours to look under the table.
A lot of unnecessary moaning.
She manages to take a look.
Maybe the spider is also the ant.
Gotcha!
I found another one.
As she turns around, show Hank the ant, she catches him
glancing at her reptilian buttocks while she was bending
under the table.
Hey, I'm pretty sure there are no in there oh my god oh my
god there's a new timer I have three more ants where are the
last three oh my god I see it gotcha but she finds another
ant but she glances at hunt the sheriff find she see his
tone back glistening in the sunlight oh my god guys we gotta
lock in guys we can score with hunk and we find all or his
ants just imagine guys that's not an ant a lobster that's
not an ant that's a lobster
where's the i'm trying to lock in guys where the oh i see it
oh my god the tanias the tanias of ants just one more we're
trying to up there maybe you pick me up oh oh oh places his
massive hands on her hips okay here oh my gosh he's touching
a woman you know dance or tires over him how it raises her
in the air with the greatest of ease oh my god he's just
like woman the first time he's ever touched a woman before
Oh my god, it's literally one one last one last ant They
gave her the uppies Upies I found it, I did it I got it
Although hunk has a firm grip on her The slime texture of
her skills Makes her slip from his hands Mere inches before
she hits the ground her romantically causing to end up face
to face oh my god when their heads slowly move towards each
other she can feel the veins of his forearms pumping with
blood but there's suddenly the door to leon's office swings
open oh my god we got cucked what a shitty game S.S.
Alamander with big tits.
It's time for your appointment.
Home, I gotta go.
Will I see you again next week?
Depends on how...
As long as you don't lose your vision in the meantime.
Acute blindness is a real thing.
Anyway, come on in.
We got Dino blocked.
We got Cock Blocked there.
bazanga block.
please.
Take a seat.
Thank you.
Didi Dinosaur softly places her butt on a chair opposite to
Leon.
Can you imagine it?
Say, before we start, are you imagining right now?
Are you still talking that guy in that waiting room?
Oh, yeah, sorry.
Maybe I should have discussed it with you.
I was wondering.
Did you notice anything strange about him?
It seems like a nice enough guy with a six pack.
Is he jealous?
Do we tell him about the messages or the fact that he has a
six pack?
I'll talk about the messages.
Maybe we'll get answers.
Well, I don't know.
Maybe this has nothing to do with him, but I keep receiving
strange messages at night from an unknown number.
Oh.
Strange messages.
What kind of strange messages?
Are we talking about those gifts of birds with human art?
Oh, I love those gifts, though, by the way.
No, they're like love-related dilemmas.
But the six-pack...
Okay, the doctor is so...
Leon's so jealous because he has a four-pack instead of a
six-pack.
Hmm.
And you think this might have something to do with the
person in the waiting room?
Huh?
I have a bad feeling about...
Could it be?
Oh, I have a bad feeling about it.
I don't know.
But it's just strong to my mind when you ask me about him.
Somebody is sending me those questions.
Is there any reason you think it could be him?
Does he have your phone number?
Did he do something to make you think this?
No, nothing like that.
Leon looks up thinking.
watching for his brain and sent information to his mouth.
Have you tried asking who it is?
Uh, yeah, I have.
Was that sarcastic tone just now?
No, my mistake.
Suddenly, DD Dinosaur feels like she's turning one of those
mohills into a mountain.
Oh no, I'm losing him!
Sorry, it's probably nothing.
Forget what I said.
Oh no, I'm fumbling it.
I'm screwing it up.
Don't be too hard on yourself.
Listen to your feelings carefully.
Unless you're unreasonable and stupid.
I'm a woman, am I right?
Maybe you're right.
But why did you ask me to speak to the man in the waiting
room anyway?
Of course, I can't see anything because of the
doctor-patient bond I have with him.
But let's just say there's a reason why he also sees me
every week.
It's not my place to judge.
passionate of you.
You're a good person, DD dinosaur.
And don't make me blush, because it makes me aggressive.
Anyway, how are you doing this week?
I think I'm starting to feel a lot better about myself.
I don't know.
But I need another...
Guys.
I don't know.
I think I might need another massage.
Nice try.
Today we're going to go to the Warshak test.
In this test, I will show you a number of ink plots.
And since Mr. Warshak apparently wasn't a good artist, we're
left to figure out what these spots are supposed to be for
ourselves.
These interpretation tells me more about your character
traits and your subconscious way of thinking.
Oh, do you want that?
Well, we know exactly what she's thinking.
Oh my god.
There's an ad on my screen.
Oh that We forgot an ad I was like what the fuck is that?
There's one specific plot that I like to interpret for you
What what is that little filthy creature doing here?
The ad is launched from the desk that must have been one of
hunts and I thought we got all of them
interesting creatures though these ants have you heard about
that ant spider a beautiful creature that yep oh anyway it's
time for the word shack test are you ready dd dinosaur was
ever so ready for it yes i am i told you so all right dd
dinosaur here we go oh hey look there's my Leon takes an
image from behind his desk With an abstract and block on it
Can you tell me what you see?
I see a flower?
Leon carefully notes his findings on his notepad Then he
pulls out a second image What do you see in this image?
I see, I don't know if it's It's just me.
Okay, what kind of...
What kind...
It has two heads.
DD, dinosaur.
I don't know where the penis part is.
But I see an airplane.
Okay, bizarre.
All right, Leon scribbles his findings on his paper.
Also, what do you see in this?
The squeedest cat on the planet Earth.
Cute.
Yeah!
And what he's feeling?
Looking at the following image.
What the fuck?
Another bean.
You're fucking.
Makes another extensive note.
Technically, you can see it.
It could be fun.
And she follows this admin.
He appears to write down the letters.
D-U-M-B.
And then finally, this one.
Oh!
Full on penile.
Slightly resentful.
There was no.
The other ones did not.
That's just your interpretation.
You have to understand that these are abstract in plots.
Which use are in blocks supposed to are they are they
supposed to be mosaic?
You're asking what you want to see To one person this might
be a soothing field of flowers Where do you and let's
express your unhealthy obsession with genitals Oh Didi
dinosaur feels somewhat caught up with this revelation?
Leon finishes notes based on didi dinosaur's last answer and
hesitantly nods He scrolls through the results.
Yes.
I think I see what part of your problem might be.
It's just a really big hat.
Wait, what?
A diagnosis already?
Leon holds this index finger and thumb on his chain like no
one does when they're really thinking.
Your desperate answer sees that these abstract blocks makes
it all too clear.
How did I not see it before?
I would say that the one thing that may be big.
bothering you.
It's that you are lonely.
Oh my God!
He's only one step away from finding out what the actual
reason is.
Then I'm a huge carnivore.
I can grow up to 14 meters long and can weigh 8 tons.
A dinosaur.
Didi Dinosaur feels caught red-handed and starts blushing.
He's a genius.
How did he know she's so lonely do you agree with this maybe
you're right study shows that social interaction and
partnership are among the basic human needs for many maybe
that's something to think about oh my god i forgot to send
in my recordings give me i just realized the one i did for
matthias too i was That's two in the zone with DD dinosaur.
I need to give me a sec.
I gotta send this over.
I forgot to send the recording, guys.
Give me a sec.
I got too into the plot.
All right.
My recording.
I was so invested.
I knew I forgot some.
thing.
Maybe I was like, I had to upload it on Google Drive and
everything.
I just forgot to send the link.
Maybe that's something to think about.
Okay, Leon, I'll think about it in bed tonight.
Whoa, naked.
Leon starts blushing.
D.D.
Dinosaur surprises herself and doesn't know where she got
the goddamn nerve from for him to act like this today i'll
think about it very long and very slowly because of my
walnut because i'm so fucking stupid i'm a stupid bitch
leon's breathing oh my god the stupid fucking ad you don't
see it but the god the ad is back I'm serious, he's right
here.
This was like a, what is the end of bimbos?
Bimbification?
The dinosaur is close to him now that she can see his
goosebumps appear.
Ew, where did this filthy animals come from?
My apologies, this is no way to present my- God, I got ad
blocked, guys.
I'm gonna clean it right away.
See you next week.
Alright, week five, back to the bedroom.
We're halfway there, guys.
I can't believe it.
This has, it's gonna end soon, guys.
I don't know what life was like before it started to stream.
While she's patting dry, Summer hurts.
Zones, DD Doster steps out of the bathroom contently.
She feels a lot more relieved after today.
Punk shared something with me that I never dared to share
with anyone else.
His ad collection.
The way he opened up to me, gives me hope that one day, I
might be able to do the same.
Also, Mia's already found out that I feel lonely.
Do I really come across that desperate?
Or is he just bringing this out in me?
Oh, hey, Robinson.
Robson.
As she slipped into a slightly see-through nightgown, she
sees Mr. Robson already sleeping in his iconic ball shape.
As she prepares to carefully lie down next to him, He's her
phone screen.
Light up because a message has just came in.
Light, think of the super chat, think of thank you.
I just tuned into the stream.
What the hell are you playing, Doki?
An FPS game.
What a mood breaker.
Shuri knows what's coming next.
This must be one of those disturbing messages again.
On her phone, she sees a message from a mysterious number
with a question.
straight to the point, eh?
Do you believe that you can sense when something bad is
about to happen?
This question gives her an anxious feeling in her gut.
Yeah, I can.
I always have a gut feeling about people, too.
She answers the question and puts the phone away without
thinking about it any longer.
She's startled by the vibration of the incoming message.
Luckily, thank God the phone was placed between her thighs
so she could feel so she would know whenever she gets a
message, you know?
Don't want to miss those texts.
She puts her phone on silent mode, but still, catches a
glimpse of the message.
Do you know that this is what other people think?
Yes.
No.
Just leave me already.
Leave me alone already.
She catches herself saying this out loud by accident.
But luckily, Mr. Robson doesn't respond.
The owner of mouth curls up as she sees him lying next year.
Peacefully with his stomach up in the air.
Lady dies or smiles at Robson, jokingly says.
You're no use to me at all, aren't you?
Aw, it's a good thing he's so cute, right?
Looks like a perfectly normal cat.
Immediately, the stressful thoughts fall away as she gets to
realize how Mr. Robson always makes her feel better.
cute belly while he lies peacefully next to her but when her
hand touches a six-pack she immediately noticed that
something is wrong mr robson
a wave of terror shoots through her heart like an arrow
oh a hand on his thigh gently shakes him back and forth it's
mr robson This is the very first time...
Oh!
Mr. Robson!
It doesn't hurt when she touches him.
Mr. Robson?
Don't want to hear her voice.
Sounds concerning.
Is something wrong?
Let me help you.
Wake up, Mr. Robson.
It's already too late.
His muscles have already relaxed.
His body...
Has already cooled down.
Not blinking.
Dee Dee dies or his tears.
And Mr. Robson.
We're refusing to believe.
This is actually happening.
Mr. Robson.
No!
Tears well up in her eyes.
As she desperately tries to come up with a solution.
A solution.
That does not exist.
She tries to wake him up.
Oh, one last time.
But you know, I'll fail.
I'm her upset.
I'll straighten my tears.
Run down her face and her nipples.
Sorry, I know it sounds inappropriate this contest, but
that's just what is happening.
I'm just giving it to you straight.
Why don't you care for Lissima?
And hugs him tightly.
She sees a letter.
Ryo's just...
lying.
Her hands are shaking while she picks up the letter.
And she tries to wipe the tears from her eyes.
With her wrist.
The letter was written by Robson.
And addressed to her.
...
If you're reading this, unfortunately, I'm no longer alive.
No.
Although...
He's German?
I mean, I guess that makes sense on the stuff he was saying
earlier.
That's what we'd prefer.
Never think about it.
We'll both be with this event.
your god life would one day come to an end it gives context
on exactly what he was saying you know earlier yeah
i'm glad that in my case this was largely by your side i
know that you're afraid of being alone and this would be
difficult for you but believe me when i say that i'll always
be with you
everyone every one of our memories every adventure we
experience is now a part of you
I'll always be a part of you as well as I write this
realizing how cute that must look I wonder if cats go to
heaven probably not because I once played with a pigeon
until it was dead okay but what like a mass murder.
You don't know that.
We don't know that, guys.
What if?
I didn't even eat it.
Realize that.
I just, I did it for fun.
Anyway, I want you to know that I am proud of you.
You're afraid you're a monster.
when you were the only one who already treated me with love.
You're afraid of how people react to you, but I really got
to know you, and this really should be the greatest honor.
Oh, Mr. Robson.
We played a DD-Dano game for the double Ds.
but we leave we leave with a heart in those double d's
you're afraid that your pants are too tight while only makes
me see maybe it's a metaphor guys it's a metaphor
it's it's a metaphor.
You okay?
Didi dinosaur.
I hope did you pray.
I hope that even a few of these words can bring you just an
ounce of extra happiness.
Because if there is someone who deserves it, it's you.
I will wait until I'll wait for you until our paths cross
again.
Duck, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thanks.
I'm watching this with my cat in my arms.
I'm falling my eyes.
What is this game from?
I'll wait for you until except if someone makes a down in
the afterlife, then I might rub my sweet face against his
shin, and will maybe follow him, cats in my right cat.
It's understandable.
Mr. Robson, it's totally understandable.
I love you because I'm very sweet.
Farewell.
Mr. Robson.
answer yes for air and she sobbed uncontrollably oh yeah
just in case the rumor is true that you poop when you die i
put a 50 bill in your oh so so considerate guys get some new
seats sorry but you know i appreciate thanks mr ross so
thoughtful even in death.
He still thinks about others.
He thought of everyone.
So considerate.
Pour one out for a real one.
For a real cat.
There is no $50 bill in the envelope.
A tear falls on the letter.
Oh my god, who would rob us when he's a dead cat?
Who would rob a dead cat?
Rather referral as if it were a full stop, then it's the
letter.
he wrote his farewell note he only thought about me he was
so sweet he dies her struggle to realize what has happened
as she plans a kiss on his little cat face a storm of panic
and thoughts rushed through her head they all flow
chaotically through one another in all direction why aren't
you using the double d model to be in themes on her man
thank you for the super chat there i can't the spotlight
okay this is her day guys it's like why you don't wear white
at a at a wedding guys we can't get anger the bride uh with
only one conclusion also i might be pushing it if i also put
that i might if i if i free the sports bra i might actually
get the vine taken down we gotta be we're fighting it we're
fighting the system right now what do i do now it's all too
much for her she can't control the flow of tears this moment
is even more sad than when leonardo went under the titanic
the overwhelming feeling of sadness physically hurts her as
she cries She is gently pressing Mr. Robbs' body against her
one last time.
His dead face between those big, juicy melons.
Now I really am.
All alone.
Oh, I got the achievement.
It's called Farewell, my friend.
Week six.
It is now a week long.
later.
When Didi Dinosaur walks into the reading room, she sees on
the clock that she is five minutes late.
This is unlikely at all.
Normally, she makes sure that she's always on time so people
do not have to wait for her.
Didi Dinosaur is clearly still feeling down.
She even looks a little bit deceived.
She has bags in her eyes.
Her clothes are not ironed.
It gets held from her eyes that she has been crying not
long, girl.
Don't worry, she's still so sexually attractive.
You know what they say, but girl's prettier when she starts
crying.
Without even realizing he was there, hunk stands up to
comfort her.
What's going on?
Do you make onion hash?
Oh, thank God I was so worried she wasn't sexy anymore.
I know, right?
Thank God she's not an ugly cryer, guys.
Thank fucking God.
Doki is a real pro.
No, it's Mr. Robinson.
He's down for the count.
Punk's eyes open up wide.
Oh, no, that's horrible.
This empathy makes you even more and more.
I'm back.
Hello, everybody.
The PC died for Mr. Robson.
Oh, Mr. Robson.
Even the PC.
Even the PC couldn't handle.
Couldn't handle it.
I have to start.
Maybe I should start coding on my CPU right now.
I could do that.
Okay, we crashed.
My OBS crashed and the game crashes again.
Yeah, the PC became so...
sad that even he couldn't handle it.
We'll encode on the CPU instead of the GPU just to give the
GPU more space.
Oh, that's horrible.
Okay, wait.
There you go.
It feels warm.
He's, he got, even he got depressed.
He couldn't handle it.
It was just so sad.
This muscular human arms reminds her of those of her cat and
pet Mr. Robson.
Thank God we would miss the stellar storytelling experience
of this game.
Bye.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
But yes, we will encode.
We'll do CPU on my OBS.
Just so my poor GPU.
I know how you feel when you say that she hears him also
getting choked up the dinosaur looks up to see if he's a
bitch what after last week's fall one my ass also didn't
survive oh my god oh shit sorry diamond please oh that's the
end The lump in his throat grows audibly.
He looks up, points the sky, and then sends an air kiss up.
You're in heaven now.
Oh, no.
Was it Mike?
No, it was Cindy.
But still, D.D.
Dinosaur says, rest in peace.
We're running our thumb across your throat, like the
Undertaker.
Hunk grabs her shoulder and looks into her eyes, but look as
if he really means it.
Listen, if you ever need a distraction or just wants to talk
about it, you can always come to me.
I really appreciate that.
But I'm afraid I'm not going to see you anymore after today.
Huh?
What do you mean?
She can see his face that he didn't see this cumping.
I decided today it's going to be like my last.
appointment with dr. Leon I've been thinking about it for a
while now if he can actually do this did I ever be
completely open but now this whole mr.
Robson thing going on I don't think I could continue to do
this anymore for a moment did he die or notice panic on
Hank's face never see you again oh concern look how thinks
carefully about what he's about to say next never see you
again but do we think about right now is actually a good
time to try and open up all your feelings especially now
that you're not feeling well don't get me wrong but no one
ever really goes to a therapist for fun of all the
overwhelming negative feelings of the of the past week she
hadn't looked at it that way for some reason.
She remembers that Hunk and Leon have been nothing but a
source of positivity since she met them.
She briefly considers sexualizing him, but then realized
this might not be the most appropriate time for your cat
just died, girl.
Maybe you're right.
That's so sweet of him.
I really appreciate that.
And don't take this the wrong way, but this is my number.
It always bothered me if you want to talk about something,
especially since your cat died.
You don't need a new person or a new shoulder to cry on.
He takes a piece of paper and writes down a phone number
that consists exclusively of numbers.
His phone number.
That's so sweet of him.
Didi Dinosaur starts to blush.
Wow, what a long number.
say about men with long numbers.
Thank you.
I appreciate that.
Then the door to Leon's office swings open.
Check this out.
Wait, I can check if it's the mystery number, too.
A phone number that's made of numbers?
Leon storms into a waiting room while pointing at his mouth.
While you're late, I learn to blow saliva bubbles.
Oh, my My god.
Oh, Omni-Man.
Mr. Omni-Man.
As she watches Leon's sensual lips blow a bubble's lava that
just barely leaves his mouth.
The bubble bursts within mere moments.
Hold on.
I can't do it anymore.
Now you guys are watching.
He makes a few more tense.
While Hunk and Didi-Di.
Dinosaur watching patiently.
No intents are very impressive.
Look, he can't perform when you're watching him, guys.
Ah, whatever.
Come in, D.D.
D
.D.
Dinosaur, sitting slumped in the chair, opposite of Dr.
Leon, while our thoughts have not wandered back to the loss
of Mr. Robinson again.
She can hear Leon talking, but what he says doesn't quite
register because of her wondering thoughts.
What a concerned look.
Dr. Leon looks at her from head to toenails and notice the
bags under her eyes.
Had a rough night of sleep?
She snaps out of her wondering thoughts.
Oh, yeah, maybe.
You look stressed.
Is there a factor that has made you more stressed than usual
this past week?
That made me true.
Sweet cat, Mr. Robson.
Passed away last week.
Oh, no.
That's terrible.
Didi Dinosaur can see in his eyes that it really touches
him.
Quick, she's vulnerable right now.
It's your chance.
It's your shot.
How are you doing?
Are you keeping your head above water?
Didi Dinosaur shrugs her shoulder as she feels tears,
welling up the corners of her eyes.
Oh.
I know what it's like to lose a best friend.
Didi Dinosaur looks up at Leon questioningly.
I have a cold fish once.
I forgot what his name was.
Who also passed away.
Didi...
Oh my god, I'm so sad.
Everyone's pets are dying.
Didi Dinosaur looks at Leon emotionally.
I forgot to feed him, you know.
And then I just flushed him down the toilet.
But the toilet wasn't getting clogged up.
So he loaded back up to the surface.
So I actually defluxed him three.
Oh, that's so traumatizing, Leon.
Oh, my God.
He had to go through so much trauma.
Dinah Sir, Didi Dinah Sir looks at Leon with a sympathetic
look.
It must have been very hard for you.
Oh, no one deserves to do that.
see that oh yeah the bummer actually don't charge me more
money because it happened late in the evening oh that was
very hard on me oh yeah no it's definitely something with my
gpu nvidia's software is encountering issue send detailed
error logs and driver data all right thank you nvidia at
least i know it's something with my gpu So yeah, I know
exactly how you feel.
And the video app was like, do you want us to send her the
data over?
And the video can't handle the grief.
I know exactly how you feel.
I wish you well.
I really appreciate that.
Everyone's losing their pets and Tokyo's losing her GPU.
Deep Dizer does feel a little more understanding, and that
helps.
I understand it's all quite fresh, so let me know when
you're ready to talk about it more.
As always, his warm voice calms her down a little more.
Impactful events such as the loss of a muscular cat can not
only have a negative impact on your mental health, but it
can also affect your memory.
to test to stay up your stress level.
I'd first like to take some memory, another memory test
today.
You know, been test.
Just answering some questions.
Do you think you can handle that?
Wait, what test was it again?
I'm so funny.
Not that you live alone.
Alright.
Oh, what?
He roasted me!
I would like to ask you to close your eyes and relax as much
as possible.
Didi Dinosaur closes her eyes.
She likes it went gives her.
Now I'm going to ask you some questions.
That'll make you feel stupid if you get them wrong, okay?
Okay.
But before we start, I'd like you to ask her to remember the
following.
Okay, 1983.
Now, that's the bite of 83.
We'll start with an easy question.
Do you remember the following?
What is the color of my iconic tie?
Oh.
He doesn't wear a tie.
He's always shirtless.
That's right.
Yeah!
I find those things a bit too suffocating myself.
I was like, Ty!
He says as he nearly burst out the tightest shirt ever.
Time for the second question.
How many chairs are there in the waiting room?
Two.
Unfortunately- Oh, wait!
Oh, in the waiting room!
I was thinking about his office!
On to the next question.
How many frame diplomas are on the...
Oh my god, he had a lot.
We were...
Guys, okay.
Oh my god, wait.
He had a lot, guys.
Guys, guys, we have...
Guys, if we don't get this right, we don't get in with...
It was 7, right?
Guys, if we don't get this right, we don't get in with the
doctor.
It was 6.
Who said 7?
I don't think you're even trying.
I don't...
next question what was the color of your sweet cat it was
red it was red it was pink what is wrong with me how did i
forget what text is the book okay i don't know he's like
hang in there hang in there oh shit oh too busy with other
things the waiting room up wait is he jealous whatever time
for the next question um in weeks have you been coming here
by now seven seven weeks seven weeks i'm on weeks what what
is not in the waiting room uh okay this is not i'm at least
you have like it's over toky i thought my stupid one a size
Okay, guys, phone a friend.
Phone a friend.
Did you even...
I was so...
I was so distracted, guys.
Will anyone...
Would anyone remember this?
Guys, we were all so distracted.
Okay.
Oh, that's absolutely right.
Next question.
What color is the band in your hair?
Wait, where am I?
Wait, that's red.
That's red, right?
Or was...
No, it's not.
purple I know that it won't put purple on purple it was I'm
going through I'm going through so much grief right now
literally mr.
Robson just died it was red right mr.
Robson just died your photo friend says all therefore and
try again mr.
my fluffy can't even super chat think did I not have a band
I thought I had a band wasn't Wait, he's talking about hair
band, right?
He's talking about the hair band.
Oh my god, is this a trick question?
Is this a rant?
That's right, I knew it.
I know, see, I told you.
I was thinking about my hair band, not Mr. Robson's collar.
I'm sorry, I think you're just improvising these questions.
Next question.
What's the first thing you ever said to me?
it was our ap or nice to meet you or my name is dd dinosaur
with double d's oh wait or was it my name is dd dinosaur
with it was ap uh ap oh you remembered i thought it was the
only one who thought that was a special moment of course i
still oh my god i'm still in i'm still in they lock eyes for
a moment slowing down time next question necklace of the man
in the waiting room oh w e i oh that w e I remember I was
thinking about world's edge every time I looked at his
necklace I was like w e for world's edge oh that's right
indeed I expected to be so obsessed with it next question
what color are my eye oh fuck okay what color were his eyes
guys I do not look at his eyes his eyes were down there I
don't know do we ever look at his eyes it was green all of
someone's thing and brown he has eyes was it brown or green
was it brown or green oh my god it's a 50-50 it has to be
brown oh my god none of us remembers it's between brown or
green brown oh wow did he dinosaur i didn't know you were
actually paying attention to that okay we've got brown i
what um are you sure i got it right let me see again to dd
check dd dinosaur looks deep into leon's eyes brief moment
they forgot what they were doing which is ironic because it
was a memory test um Do you also happen to know what the
color of my belt is?
Oh my god, I can't seem to remember very well.
Is it okay to feel like I refreshed my...
What am I?
Braille text?
No, I'm just messing with you.
Sure, you can.
Oh!
He gets...
When did he get four more bags?
Down towards his belt.
She still has her eyes closed.
After all, this is a very seriously silent...
Biological test.
Pirate, remember, she says.
Chuckling after feeling for it, but...
Wait.
It was none of these.
Wait a minute.
Rock on...
ROG.
Rock RGB lights.
Wait a minute.
This was none of these.
Let's get the rock RGB lights.
That's when you know he's a real gamer.
Hey.
That actually deliberately gives the wrong answer.
Oops, maybe I should feel it.
Oh, I'm so smart.
I'm so fucking smart.
Oh, the door!
This time, I feel his size.
And then she's, oh, oh, oh.
He closed the door.
I don't want my...
I just, like, opened the door.
Just close my door.
And grips it tightly.
Oh, what are you doing?
Oh, by the way, before I forgot a door knob, a door knob, of
course, of course, what else could it be?
It's a door knob.
What else could it be, you guys?
What's the number I asked you to remember at the beginning
of the test?
the bite of 83 1980 1983 the bite of 83 that's right you
can't be fooled she says the DD dinosaur who just
accidentally sucked the door handle she just really likes
door handles guys oh I clever girl guys clever girl 7 out of
remember she's above average look it's above average I
locked in at the end DeeDee Dinosaur holds her hands on her
hips and feels superior over everyone that performed worst
in her.
Check out, you know, double D is fine, but for I'm just
seeing your triple A's every time you sprint.
Riji, it's because of the sports bar.
I didn't want to embarrass the DeeDee Dinosaur, you know?
This is her moment that performed worst in her.
And she literally knows the part where she was guessing some
of the answer.
I would never.
I knew every answer.
I'm proud of you for giving it a shot, DeeDee Dinosaur.
to take it easy for the rest of the day.
I will.
Thanks, Leon.
He decides to go home, but then changes her mind.
Oh, Leon.
I've been thinking about what you said, by the way.
How about open my heart to the possibility of love?
I think it might have been open to this day I first came
here.
Leon nods at her kindly.
That's good to hear.
Whoa!
Oh, Didi dinosaur winks at him as she walks.
Oh, my God.
I'm opening my door back up again because I think it's
cooling down as she walks towards the exit.
Well, see you next week, doctor.
We'll see you next week, doctor.
Leah stays with a maca.
Sorry, I had a bad night of sleep.
All I was going to say, what always week six?
Oh, I'm going to say.
Oh, there's no more...
Oh, I can't sleep.
Mr. Robson's gone.
He's gone.
I can't sleep.
Mr. Robson, she stares at the ceiling as she lies on her
back in bed.
The spot next to her where Mr. Robson used to lie feels
cold.
So incredibly quiet.
cold about you she feels tears well up on your eyes i missed
you so much and only i didn't feel so alone oh hey new
message she sighs when she feels her phone vibrating next to
her it's the message from the unknown number the message
contains another mysterious question which of the flying
qualities do you care about the least in a potential partner
the least If it's only to distract your mind.
I would say, is I arrogance or jealous?
I'll say arrogance.
Message sent.
When think about potential partners, her thoughts wonder to
hunkin' Leon.
I can't even think of one negative quality between the two.
She snaps out of her wondering thoughts when a second
meant...
Oh, mindless!
Oh, I thought it meant...
Oh, whoops.
Oh, sorry.
I thought it meant, like, which one do you not like the
most, type Dia?
I, sorry.
My bad.
I can't read.
Can't read.
I got the wrong meaning out of that question.
I thought it meant which one you hate the most.
I said arrogance.
I don't like arrogance that much.
Did you ask other people that think?
Grammatical error.
Okay, it's second.
other people didn't know how to read either.
Reading copper.
Guys, it's okay.
Other people didn't know how to read, too.
It's not just me.
Like, really?
But this time, T.G.
Dyser flops back down your bed and thinks about what Hunk
said to her.
I was right.
Yeah, grammar, the biggest crime.
I can't believe it.
How dare you There's not no basic grammar.
During therapy, I felt much better than how I feel now that
I'm sitting here alone with my thoughts.
I'm glad that he persuaded me to make another appointment
for next week.
That reminds me.
His number!
He gave me his phone number.
Robson, a feeling of in-ease, comes over her when she holds
Hong's phone number.
Oh my gosh, he's so loud.
Why are you so loud?
I literally...
eat them all this food
her hair that is worrying about hunk a shiver runs down her
nicely shaped eyes one the first digit of hunk's number one
the first digit the unknown number oh my god both numbers
start with the same digits this doesn't look good at all oh
my god they're from the same area code guys to build some
more tension she stares at two phone numbers in shock and
then she sees it.
It's a different number.
Oh, thank God.
Oh, it's a different number.
It's a sort of game of regular occurrence.
Thank you.
Yeah, it's an FPS game.
Tomorrow, I'm also playing a game about a dinosaur with
double Ds.
On Twitch.
Make sure to check it out.
In Marvel Rivals.
It's a different number.
What a relief.
Maybe I should send him a message.
But, do I really dare to?
He did say that he doesn't mind after all.
Yeah, send him a message.
But then, just as her fingers hover over the keyboard, she
drops her phone in the bed next to her.
This simply doesn't feel right.
Only Joss lost Rob's in him, where he'd try and replace his
presence.
Only a monster would do that.
trying to look for company.
I'm so lonely.
I know he would encourage me because he is sweet and just
wants me to be happy, but it doesn't feel right yet.
Didi Dias replaces her hand on the cold spot where Mr.
Robson used to be and closes her eyes.
Good night, Mr. Robson.
Meow.
Next week It's going to be another tense week.
So when she...
Just when she starts to drift off, she hears something
zooming past her ears.
Her eyes pop wide open.
She recognizes the sound immediately.
The loving nightmare of every...
Oh, oh, oh!
Yeah, I don't like that.
That mosquito.
You must be kidding me.
Writing.
She tries...
Oh my god, that sounded so real.
I actually jumped...
I actually, like, jumped up from my chair because I hate
that sound.
especially when you're sleeping, and you hear the mosquito,
like, meew.
That needs to, but, but, but, no.
She tries to look around the darkness of her room, but in
vain.
Please not, night!
And suddenly a sneaky voice appears next to her.
She swipes her hand across her hair in an attempt to swat
the mosquito away.
think you can hit me the mosquito demonstrates speed by
flying to her other ear within a second starts whispering
again please just go away all right but first i need some
blood oh no i have to hit him before he manages to penetrate
my skin oh my god where is he Oh my god.
Mosquito devour of sleep.
Ouch, my perfect skin.
It won't be Lambo, I get through your skin.
I have to hit him.
Wait, can I please have another one of those?
A cringe, dude.
No!
No, he's simply so fast.
D-Dazer gets a little light.
Hey, do the blood loss.
Focus D-Dazer.
I need him as a flash pass.
It's so hard, guys.
This is so hard to do.
No!
That's it.
Dazer, coming with me.
I have it in my arms.
He's gonna watch this game with me.
It was the ping.
I thought it was the ping.
I caught him.
At least I caught him.
my dog.
I miss oh no.
The mosquito takes a big sip of her blood.
Oh my perfect skin.
Okay, that's, that's, this is I'm getting unimmersed.
Actually, all mosquitoes are female, so there's no way a
male mosquito can penetrate my skin.
He then slashes the drink around in his mouth.
A rich, ripe taste.
He He's larping.
A delicate hint.
A sweetness.
Great structure.
Then he calmly spits the blood back into his wine glass.
He smacks his lips and makes the annoying ah sound that some
people make when they had something to drink.
A delicious.
What?
Why are you spinning it up?
At least drink it.
Excuse me.
I'm not a savage.
Now, can you please turn off the light?
I'm trying to sleep.
And that light is so tempting that I want to fly into it all
night.
Because I'm a mosquito.
Dinosaur, he hears his voice rattling further and further
away as she slowly falls asleep.
Dude, I'm blood lost.
Jesus Christ.
How much fucking blood did that fucking mosquito get?
Hero, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Technically, Doki, it is an FPS freaking purple sweater
puppies.
That's the best Akamai got.
I am sorry.
Oh, I locked in the outfit.
Nice.
What did I get?
A wedding dress unlocked.
Well, I know what outfit I'm putting on.
I'm getting ready.
here we go as dd dancer walks into the waiting room she
already sees hunk doing push-ups to help his muscles and
veins pop he's such a nerd when he hears her approaching he
looks up a concerned look good morning how are you I'm doing
a lot better, but it's still difficult.
It's been two weeks now, but Mr. Robson's appearance,
absence, it's so hard to get used to.
I understand, but I'm glad to see you back here.
Me too.
It's nice to have some distraction.
She says while looking at his nipples, wow, those areola.
Then Didi Dinosaur noticed something about Hunk's muscular
neck.
What did she notice?
Huh?
She mainly recognized the mosquito bite.
That's what was saying, Miss Gila, bitter last week.
Her soul fills up with guilt.
It seems that the events in this game could have serious
consequences after all.
Anyway, it warms Didi Dinosaur's prehistoric heart, knowing
that Hunk came earlier to comfort her.
the same mosquito oh my god a mosquito is cheating on me I
thought he said my blood was delicious but there are other
people thanks again for the pep talk last week a modest
smile appears on his charming face but how are you what's
new I'm sitting in the waiting room an hour before my own
appointment starts does it look like I have much going on la
mao She thinks it's funny because he's a trap.
True.
Oh man, you're so funny.
Oh my god.
Can't believe only hot people can be so funny.
Now I'm just messing with you.
I'm trying to figure out the following thing.
He gestures to his phone.
On his screen, she sees an app in which he is completing a
profile.
Did he dives her gasp of breath?
Is that?
Oh.
A dating app?
Yeah, I thought it was maybe time I should give it a try,
right?
It's pretty lonely.
Like, this with only nine ads.
I'm literally right here.
So, no, he's some guy.
He's just some guy who was also getting therapy lessons.
Not less therapy sessions.
So I'm trying to figure out this profile setup thing.
But I don't understand it at all, man.
Didi tries to hide.
Am I not good enough for him?
I could be Didi's 10th aunt.
Didi dies or tries to hide her surprise.
She didn't see this coming.
Wait.
A dating profile?
By fellow chance, Rose, I'm literally right here.
With my wedding dress.
How could it be so stupid to think that someone like him
could like someone like me?
A monster like me?
Who even likes gigantic breasts?
round buttocks sultry lips an hourglass figure no gag reflex
and a salamander tail that can fall off in case of danger
anything I'm hideous I'm so disgusting and gross I'll never
be as good enough for him no one of course I'm No one will
ever love you.
You're so ugly.
Meanwhile, Hunk is so clumsily scrolling on his phone.
How can anyone marry someone like that?
I am a man dying of thirst watching the sun fall.
So now I'm trying to decide on a profile picture if I can't
choose between these two photos.
Can I see?
Please.
He hands her his phone.
Didi Dazer looks at the selection of photos on his phones.
She gasps as her cheeks starts to feel warm.
He is barely dressed in these photos.
When she counts as abnormal muscles, she concludes that it
must be at least a 10-pack.
Where the fuck are they getting these 10-packs?
Damn, son.
But wait a minute.
She carefully looks at the two photos again as she holds
them next to each other.
But these are both the same photos, right?
Uh-huh.
They look very similar.
That's true.
But there are small differences.
10, okay, there we go.
10 differences to be precise.
So I'm still unsure which of these two I think is better.
With squinted eyes, D.D.
Dinosaur stares at the photo to see if she can spot the 10
differences.
Alright, let's see.
Okay.
Okay, oh my god.
Oh my god.
Okay.
There was...
This is a lot.
Whoa.
Okay.
Two.
Four.
Five.
Oh, wait.
The sharpen.
Wow.
Okay.
Oh my god.
There is a certain his ants too.
His nine ants.
Is it the veins?
Does he have one too many?
Oh.
It's the, but wait, what happened?
Is that before and after from one frame?
His wallet, that's true.
Oh yeah, one has his jar.
Wait, people.
Okay, I need a couple more guys.
It was gold, that's true.
It was so good.
Okay, there's one other one
Oh my god This is
Oh, I see it Okay, one, two, okay, there we go I'm so
distracted
Oh Oh, where else?
It's having such a great day at the beach, guys.
I'm so jealous.
Oh, there's a cloud here.
What's wrong with the sign?
Oh, I see it.
I see it now.
Two, four.
Is there anything?
Maybe whiskers?
I know that there's three whiskers.
Oh my god, that's this cat relax-a-ton!
He brought his cat to the beach!
The cat is so relaxed.
Oh, I see it.
The ant.
One last one.
I love the sun.
The sun is chill.
But the timer...
Oh my god, it is!
It's the timer.
I see it.
That giant timer to the right?
What do you think?
Which photo do you think is better?
That's so smart.
The right one because of the bulge.
The right one, I guess.
I don't know if you look bad on a photo anyway.
Even if you tried.
That's nice of you, old.
asking, is there?
Inducing, not sharing the most platonic way ever.
Her breast jigs are so platonically, you know?
You know, when your breasts start jiggling platonically with
your friend because they are huge.
Is she really going to date?
I thought maybe we had a connection.
You know what I mean.
Ask, is there supreme?
Why she forcibly... Oh, okay.
Alright.
Water, okay.
We go, Lily.
Move on.
Skip up.
But she's...
scared, too afraid of being rejected.
As you kiss your friend platonically, you know?
And you, like, you know, touch your bobs a little
platonically, you know?
That's like how friends do.
Too afraid of being rejected, too afraid to expose yourself
as a prehistoric creature.
And besides, it's quite difficult to make a serious
transition from making ass kissing sounds to possibly
declaring your love.
Damn, that really is when Aina's being kissed down.
Wait, how does he know that?
How would he know that?
Yeah, just bros being bros.
Bros being blows.
Well, I guess I'm picking the right photo then.
Thanks for your help anyway.
I feel like you always have my back.
Well, then, I'm going to upload the photo on a brand new
dating profile now.
And therefore, completing it, his maddening fingers floats
towards the publish button on his phone in slow motion.
So I can date other people.
Should I stop him?
This would be my last chance to share it with him that I
think we have a connection.
Or should I add my description?
That I'm very desperate.
Oh, I don't think he needs to be very desperate.
Nah.
His fingers hover closer and closer above the create data
profile button.
But he clearly doesn't like me.
I'd actually want to be looking for someone else.
Right?
With his fingers now only hanging a few millimeters above
the button.
It should now be any moment This is like the pacing of a One
Piece episode right now.
All right, Dad, you can...
You have enough.
You've been told enough.
That should be enough for you.
Everything does go a lot slower in slow motion, don't you
think?
But if I don't do it now, it possibly may never happen.
Then I'll never know if there was a possibility.
Maybe it's time for me to stop being a coward and to do what
Dr. Leon said to open my heart to find happiness and love.
What did you say?
Oh, sorry.
That was supposed to be a thought bubble.
NPE, no problem.
Tell him you might feel something for him.
I'm going to tell him before she can...
Oh, got Doc blocked again.
Before she can say it, even anything at all.
The door to Dr. Leon's office swings open.
A dinosaur with big tits.
You're up.
Damn it, previously a titty dinosaur.
or already time always flies when i talk to you thanks some
speculate is because of my very entertaining personality um
i wasn't talking to you while the man discussed her wacky
misunderstanding dd stands there somewhat bewildered i see
you missed your chance week seven
good morning Didi dinosaur please take a seat how are you
doing this week her thoughts wonder as she absently takes a
seat because of this she does not realize that she is
ignoring Leon wondered okay let's do Leon just because he's
here right now maybe Leon is the one for me after all she
looks at Leon from head to toe and cannot find any flaws in
it.
What a beast.
For a moment she tries to imagine what his tongue would
taste like.
A smirk appears on Leon's face.
Wait, but what about the shark tank idea?
Guess we'll never know, guys.
I guess we'll never know.
I guess you guys have to play your own play or do your own
play through to find out.
if you don't answer me that's fine too that's been barking
her attention i'm worried i she snaps out of her sinful
thoughts that i literally i literally had him picked up on
my lap and then like he didn't he was just fine but now on
steam yeah she snaps out of her sinful thoughts oh no i'm
sorry i totally missed your question What do you think is
the most important quality and a potential partner?
Huh?
Why is he asking that?
Alright, I'm back.
We're on CPU streaming now.
Okay, I'm back, guys.
We're on CPU.
Those double Ds, man.
Those double Ds are so...
Wow, they are stressing...
They are definitely stressing out my GPU.
what a stream we will finish this i need to know who is he
gonna pick who is he gonna pick who is he gonna okay all
right why is he asking that all right i will say we're back
we're back here we we survived the double d's i'm so sorry
guys right after this stream we'll do another we're gonna do
another stress test on members just just to figure this out
yeah Oh, is there frames?
Is there a huge lag?
Oh, is it... Oh, no!
It's Chaffee!
No!
Ah, okay.
Okay, we can't do CPU then.
Oh!
Raise it to... Alright, we're back.
Okay, we're back.
Okay, we're back again.
We're back again.
Okay, okay, we're back again.
We're gonna try a new GPU encoding setting.
We're back.
We will finish this.
I'll do a stress test on members.
We're gonna figure it out on members.
We will need you cannot stop me You cannot stop me from
reaching the end.
We're so close.
We are two weeks away from finishing the day we can do it we
might crash again because I'm still using the GPU but we can
still do it I'm sorry please bear with me guys we have to
see it to the end we have to I wish I stressed us during the
last two days but I couldn't I was so busy with stuff it's a
risk you cannot stop me from DD dinosaur all right I say
caring caring i think interesting did you know that this is
what other people think uh honest i mean yeah honestly but i
feel like if you're caring you wouldn't lie to me right the
dominance is more than caring fucking abuse me yeah come
hell or how while we're finishing this masterpiece of a game
very impressive how he knows the statistics by heart and
what about you huh what do you you think is most important
oh I uh I guess also caring yeah oh we're all on the same
page but enough about me let's focus on you today I would
like to do a general health test after all a law of stress
can lead to various physical elements this is why I would
like to check your current physical conditions I can do this
by taking a swab from your heart from her throat with my
finger before oh my god this is the board portion i saw it
on the steam page ring on that finger oh okay please open
your mouth so i can try to collect a juice sample from the
back of your throat oh what from the back of my throat oh no
maybe i spoke to soon if he collects a swab from the back of
my throat he might discover that I'm a huge carnivore that
could grow up as a 14 meters long and we eat tens.
The dinosaur!
Yes, I don't have a gag reflex.
Oh, don't worry at all.
It's a piece of cake.
Although she's nervous about the whole biggest secret she's
a dinosaur thing, she's conflicted with another thought
because she cannot deny that she would like to have Leon's
thick hairy finger down her throat.
Are you ready?
You know it.
Dee Dee Dizer opens her mouth As Leon's fingers approaches,
she has noticed that it is.
Oh, you know what they say about the size of their finger.
Nice.
Oh, my God.
There it is.
Yep, we got this.
We're getting there.
See, there must be a usable sample around here somewhere.
I'm doing Ollie right now.
We're doing Ollie.
Nice.
I like how it's Korean, like, K-pop.
Let's see, just a little bit deeper.
I slowly disappeared in the back of her head.
When Leon pushes his fingers deeper inside, he lets out his
sensual moan.
Are you okay?
She says because he's busy stirring his hand down her
throat.
Where does this reflex end?
All right, sorry, I don't speak Swedish.
Oh, I almost missed that.
That one was a tight one.
Leon's thick, vainy finger slowly slides along her uvla.
She produces more moisture with enthusiasm.
Y'all keep her triceroy, why do you ever buy?
I don't have to remember why I bought this game.
Very deep.
She lets out another enthusiastic moan.
This time she barely tries to hide it as she digs her nails
into the arm of the chair.
Oh!
And deeper.
Oh my god, my fingers, my pinky hit the back.
My pinky hit the wall.
While Leon's arms disappear deeper and faster and through
it, locks deep into his eyes.
My pink teeth.
Intrigued by a deaf.
Leah rose up his sleeve further, which exposes his
expressive visus.
They're like the double Gs under the arm muscle.
Oh, shit.
Oh, no.
Last life.
No!
Oh, God!
As I was told, she actually bites Leah on the finger.
I couldn't help it.
That was a fumble.
Fuck.
Leon recoats in fear.
His arm slides out of her mouth like a wildebeest calf at
first.
Oopsie.
While Leon looks at his fingers, he sees that he's collected
some dinosaur mud, DD dinosaur mud under his nail anyway.
But dead bites his eyes.
I couldn't I couldn't help it.
I got so distracted.
Are you okay?
Are you sure you have everything?
Um, yeah.
He holds up his slimy finger.
Okay, I put the sample into one of this pregnancy like test
what now so in a few minutes to tell us if something is
super serious is wrong or not i must say by the way guys
he's like he doesn't bark when i'm not streaming he i found
i found out he only barks when i'm streaming now it's like
it's crazy like the last two days He did not bark at all
while I was on my PC.
He literally, now he just barks when I'm streaming.
He's like, who are you talking to?
He wants to talk.
He like does, he knows.
Huh?
Your throat, death.
It's like she's talking to their voices.
I gotta save her.
This would be a great talent in some specific industries.
The sword swallower industry, for example.
Didi Dinosaur is feeling relieved.
Not only because Leon, for some reason, doesn't seem to find
her lack of gag reflex weird at all.
But also because he had washed his hands beforehand.
As Leon smiles friendly at Didi Dinosaur, his eyes fall on
the test results.
Oh, the results are in.
friendly smiles, turns into that of a professional, as he
examines the results.
Let's see.
Hmm.
I have good news, and I have bad news.
Give me the bad news first, Doctor.
The bad news is that I'm a liar.
The bad, there is only good news.
Oh, yay!
You're in perfect health.
Yay!
But what?
It seems that you have a of physical exercise in your life.
So we'll have to work on that somehow.
Oh, more physical exercise.
Still drunk on the adrenaline from the intimate test just
now?
She looks at Leon with blushing cheeks.
I really enjoy that physical test, Leon.
Oh, what the hell am I saying?
I'm normally never like this.
Ooh, T.
Can you think of another way to get physical next week?
oh what well hey he almost stumbles over his words oh
official exercise is what you seem to mean dd dinosaur dance
nice oh and by the way what a tease leon takes a
professional looking business card from one of his drawers.
Here's my phone number.
If you start to feel worse, or you want to talk about
something, you can always contact me.
Didi Dinosaur smile shyly.
Well, does he get this and know about a gag reflex?
It was good to see you again.
Pleasure doing business, doctor.
Didi Dinosaur flicks the coin in his direction as a tip.
Sorry about biting your finger there earlier.
When she gets up, she intensely maintains eye contact and
considers licking her lips sensually.
Oh, the distraction causes her to hit her knee on the desk.
The pain makes the entire situation awkward.
Are you okay?
Oh, look at that.
She's a girl failure.
Oh, she's so relatable, guys.
Didi Dinosaur say she's fine, even though it hurts a lot.
I can't really say that at a moment like this.
I guess that would be even more humiliating.
I'm fine.
I'm not crying because I probably hurt my knee.
She gives a thumbs up.
Trying not to show that she can barely put any weight on
your knee as she struggles to leave the office.
We seven.
Bedroom time.
Didi dives her as lying in bed under her covers, but check
this out.
It's completely naked.
Sad.
The boarding dress is all in our minds, guys.
Mr. Robson, I think I have a problem.
I think I like them both.
Mia really brings out the primal instincts in me.
That test today.
Wow.
I don't think my heart has raced as fast as that meteorite.
But wait, huh?
I feel like I can talk about almost anything.
He's such a sweetling.
You always say, nice guys always say, finish last.
Do you think...
No?
But then D.D.
Dazer gets started when she receives a message from an
unknown number.
When she opens the message, she sees the following question.
What is your biggest fear in a relationship?
Oh, here we go again.
Being cheated on.
I think that's the worst.
I feel like when you're abandoned, it's like being abandoned
or being cheated on, I think.
I don't even want to think about it.
She receives another message.
Did you know that this is what other people think?
Yeah, that seems right.
Getting aboard.
That's what a cheetah would say.
She sighs deeply as she falls back into the bed.
Another message?
That's unusual.
It's another message from the unknown metamumber.
as she hesitates to open the message she sees a somewhat
disturbing text thank you I almost know enough next week
it's time for the last question the last question the last
question before what she drops the back of her head and her
pill in defeat the bed suddenly feels so huge about Robson's
diamond hard body thanks to her so you'll never be able to
find off as cat.
It was perfect.
Then she's suddenly overwhelmed with loneliness.
What do I do about you, Robson?
It's such a pity that men never got to meet you.
I wonder what that would've been like for a moment.
Just men being men, guys.
Just bros being bros.
Between the men and Mr. Robson.
How cute that must have been.
The last must their cat on earth well wait a minute she
feels her phone in the palm of her hand i could send one of
the men a message after all that did indicate that they were
not mine but it is kind of late i should send hunk a message
we were gonna send it he gave me his number first guys he
you know he got he called dibs first she has sata for a
moment before typing her message but Doesn't anyway.
Hey, hunk.
You up?
Her fingers shake a little as she presses send.
Message sends.
Immediately after the message sends, she regrets it.
What in the world am I doing?
What if I bother him?
What if I wake him up?
What if he finds out that I'm a dinosaur that is warm,
blooded, and breathes using air sac that continuously push
fresh air through the lung in one direction?
Oh, hey, new message.
Before she can finish her extensive description of a
dinosaur, she feels her phone vibrate.
Hey, hunk.
Didi dinosaur is...
Where did she get that photo?
Yes, with the double Ds.
Nice.
I was just thinking about you.
Okay.
Is something wrong?
I don't know.
I just felt a little lonely.
Where's my boobs?
Did I got breast reduction?
My boobs should be covering my phone.
I shouldn't be able to see half of it.
I just felt a little lonely.
I hope I'm not disturbing you.
Well, it's a bit late to message you, don't you think?
Oh, no.
I was afraid of this.
Oh, where's...
Slash JK.
Sorry.
No, just kidding.
X-D-H-E.
See?
He said, J-K.
I just say he's always bothering me.
X-D-L-M-L-M-L-M-L-M-O.
Facts.
What do you want to talk about?
Nothing specific.
I was just looking for some distraction.
Uh-oh.
I'm starting to feel performance pressure already.
E-Dinosaur is giggling.
That's not necessary, because I have a question for you.
For me, now I feel even more pressure to perform.
Do you notice that talking with Hunk immediately calms you
down?
Like, he's a human tranquilizer or something.
What are you wearing?
Okay, I feel like bedroom would be funny, though.
I'm going to do bedroom.
What does your bedroom look like?
I feel like that would be a funny picture.
Okay.
It's pretty dark right now.
You're...
Oh, I could tell you, but why don't I just show you?
But I warn you, that'll be there too.
Oh, nice.
Flex.
There's so many.
I want to see how many ants he has.
What's she about to now do now?
Shocks her to the core.
A chronically shy and subtle...
I know she's so subtle, guys.
Has she ever felt comfortable like this?
someone before?
She points her phone at herself and poses sensually.
Wait, Oh, wait, ass?
Wait, I don't want to see her fins, though.
That's supposed to take a photo that...
What the fuck?
I was like, who the fuck is David?
That would make many men shivers.
Who is that?
But before there's time to realize, Hunk sends another
message.
But before we are intimate like that, I'll have to ask you
something first.
What?
Doki, there's the feed option.
But we've never seen her.
We've never seen her fins, though.
Well, I already do this in person.
We don't mind.
Did you ask her respect is respect for her?
Of course, that's fine.
What could you be talking about?
They'll talk to you next week.
Deal.
Sleep well.
Hunk.
Don't tell me what to do.
You're not my mom.
When I was joking for the rest of the night.
It's hard to sleep because of those exciting messages now.
I know.
I've heard that counting sheep's helped you sleep.
She looks up her favorite sheep video.
All right, this should probably help.
All right, time to count sheep, guys.
I still haven't played...
Oh, one, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine,
10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15, 15, 60, 70, 18, 19, 20, 21, 22, 23,
24, 25, 26, 27, 28, 29, 30, 31, 32, 33, oh, 35.
That was not 35.
Oh, I guess it wasn't 35.
39?
That's the right answer.
video cause, Didi Dinosaur can't sleep at all.
Boy, did this video just backfired.
Oh no, don't make me count again.
Oh wait, they're five.
Didi Dinosaur stomps into the waiting room because she's a
dinosaur.
Her hips moving gracefully back and forth as she walks over
and see Hunk already sitting in the waiting room.
After weeks, Didi Dinosaur is finally feeling somewhat
better.
It's looking forward to seeing Hunk again.
Wait, what week am I on?
I've lost track.
When she sees Hunk sitting there, Didi Dinosaur stares at
his broad shoulders.
She has large brain, and you know the deal by now.
When Didi Dinosaur, oh, he's blushing.
I'm on week eight.
Okay.
He looks at her nervously with a serious look on his face.
Didi Dinosaur, can I talk to you for a moment?
Didi Dinosaur looks at him like she's about to crack the
most hilarious joke ever.
Tata!
Achievement unlocked.
You're doing it right now.
Although this is not a funny joke at all.
Isn't actually the reason why Hunk isn't laughing.
Huh?
What's going on?
I should have been clearer with you.
Hank stays like so...
What if the reason why he's in therapy is because he's
attracted to dinosaurs?
And that's why the doctor was like, don't talk to him.
He's a freak.
He likes dinosaurs.
And she's like, oh my God.
I'm a DD dinosaur.
with double Ds.
It was still very unclear.
It's all coming together.
What the hell are you talking about?
My dating profile.
In the end, I was never able to put it up.
Have you tried pressing the publish button?
It's not because I didn't know how to do it, DD Dinosaur.
It's because I just Did it to make you jealous?
What?
Why?
Why would you want to make me jealous?
He sighs deeply.
Oh, it's Barra or something.
Because I was too scared.
Afraid to be direct with you.
Afraid to tell you how I really feel.
Afraid to be rejected.
But you deserve the truth.
Huh?
wait does he mean to be honest i feel a connection with you
since the first time i spoke to you i don't know you feel it
too or that you're just gonna laugh in my face what didi
dinosaur is speechless she didn't see this coming at all as
scary as this be treated rejected i have to ask you about
this okay carry He goes, do you want to go on a date with
me?
Did he dinosaur's heart skip a beat?
Did I hear that right?
A day?
I thought I didn't want anything to do with me before.
And now, all of a sudden, he wants to go on a date with me?
And what about Leon?
Yes, yes, Did he dinosaur.
All these thoughts chaotically run through her head, like a
colony of ants.
You didn't bite Hunk's arms off, at least.
While for Hunk, it feels like an internal silence.
These dinosaurs decided to give it a try after all.
They were ashamed to never explore whether there is any
potential between them.
Oh, I'm so speechless.
Awesome.
How about tonight?
I know.
The perfect place.
Sounds good.
You don't have to arrange anything at all.
I'll send you the details later.
I'm so looking forward to it.
Hunk does a wa-hoo!
Out of joy.
Didi Dinosaur giggles at the adorable sight.
Just don't forget to wear your skinny jeans, you skank.
The door to Leon's office swings open, and Leon's come
stumbling in the room as if he's from a sitcom.
Didi Dinosaur slumber whammer.
It's time for your appointment.
Hunk still looks lyingly at Didi Dinosaur.
I'll see you tonight.
Is that a threat?
Leon takes on a timid fighting stance in self-defense.
Oh.
I wasn't talking to you, Doctor.
Oh, okay, but of course.
Come in, Didi Dinosaur.
Oh, Leon.
Silly Leon.
Didi Dinosaur is filled with confidence after interacting
with Hunk.
In fact, it makes her feel quite aroused.
What the fuck?
Still, she wonders if she should tell Leon about the date.
Besides, the fact that basically has nothing to do with him,
she wants to keep her options open.
After all, she can't deny that she also has feelings for
him.
Please, sit down, Didi Dinosaur.
While I was eavesdropping on you guys just now, I couldn't
help but overhear that you have a date with Hunk tonight.
Huh?
He knows.
Um, yeah, right.
But it's all because he wasn't honest before.
I mean, it was all because of a misunderstanding last week.
Leon noticed her slip of tongue.
He wasn't honest?
I told you to watch out for him.
It wasn't that big of a deal.
He looks down concerned for a moment.
He's mad.
He's jealous.
He didn't get the chance.
It's so many chances.
Now you're too late, Leon.
please watch yourself the only thing she's currently
watching intensely is the half-beared photo of leon on oh i
noticed that on day one don't worry dd dinosaur by the way
it's been thinking i've been thinking about what you asked
me last week leon looks into dd dinosaur's eyes deep and
sultry when you ask me to prepare another physical test i
think you're right it's high time This is a soccer minigame.
This is a soccer minigame.
Oh my god, this is what I've been waiting for.
I was waiting to play soccer.
Play stupid mind and brain games.
We dance around and long enough.
So, as you requested, I prepared an intensive physical test
for you today.
He winks in a sexy way.
That would be creepy if you weren't attractive.
If you know what I mean.
Oh my, I've been waiting for this.
I've been waiting for this whole day.
I was waiting to ball.
D .D.
Dinosaur lets out a giggle.
This is what I've been waiting for.
This is the reason why I played D.D.
Dinosaur with the double Ds.
It's time for fifth FIFA.
D .D.D.D.D.
Dinosaur hopes it has something to do with his balls.
That's right.
Two big checkered balls.
I'm going to be ready to straight for you.
It has something to do with my balls.
He makes a rock and roll sign with his hands.
How does that sound to you?
Didi Dinosaur nods eagerly and desperately.
Is this a dream?
Is he really asking me to do this?
I don't know if I've ever felt so comfortable with someone.
For a moment, she seems to have forgotten about Hunk's date
completely.
Warren, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Leon is not jealous of Didi Dinosaur.
He is jealous that Hunk is into Didi Dinosaur.
I don't want to be said.
safe so I suggest we use protection the dinosaur giggles
this all happening so quickly with his hairy hand she sees
him open a drawer in this desk that's normally locked when
she sees what he takes up she accidentally lets oh my god i
love soccer his shin guards welcome everyone to this great
day of football today it's dinosaur versus dr leon and as
the whistle blows we'll find out how this match will go as
there is some definite tension there between the two okay
shoot tackle what the fuck jump is middle mouse button
off-site rule work again the referee is about to blow here
we go oh my god oh shit where's the get out of here there we
go
dd dinosaur dinosaur oh and it's celebration time great goal
by dinosaur let's She can keep this up Where's the ball And
he shoots on the go get out of here.
No problem for the goalkeeper at all great work from the
keeper still though Okay, dinosaur missing the ball.
Oh shit.
Oh shit goalkeeper.
You got this goalkeeper Go where I got him out Go kick it.
Yes
Let's go Oh, that seemed really unnecessary.
And now it's time to celebrate.
Great goal by dinosaur.
Go!
Get out of here!
Messy must be looking for the exact evening.
Get out!
Well done by the goalkeeper, but it's still a play.
This is my time!
And it's time for kickoff once again.
Nice save from the goalkeeper.
Get out!
That's not fair!
Get him!
This is not fair!
Red, red, foul!
Red card!
And there's the equalizer.
Who will win this match?
Okay, I gotta get him out of here.
The referee.
That seems to be a bad injury.
The leg is not supposed to bend that way.
Oh no.
My goalie!
My goalie wouldn't get it!
Goalie!
the chance okay it's how we're gonna win this get out oh my
god get up get up he doesn't know the red bull no it was oh
my god
the reactions there the reflexes I gotta get him out Brett
Brett's cheating Brett's playing for the enemy team No!
No, my goalie my goalie Goalie Goalie Nice, nice, nice,
nice, nice Nice, nice, nice, nice No, no, yes!
Goalie!
Go!
And it's time for kickoff once again.
Excellent goal.
Get him up.
Okay.
You gotta make sure.
The rep is not here.
Where's the ball?
My goalkeeper.
What's this?
No!
We got him out!
Yes!
Oh, four two!
That's the final whistle.
What a match.
Oh my god.
What a shitty game.
It was apparently we won.
D-D-D, D-D, D-D, D-D, D-D, D-D, D-D, D-D, D-D, D-D, D, D, D,
D, D, D, D.
I'm putting that.
She's fucking FIFA materials.
Check her out next in FIFA in July.
When he says this, she knows that he's in his ultimate form
when he's sweaty.
always bet on the dinosaur.
Dinos, steedy dins, her spots a puddle of her own sweat on
her seat.
Oh dear, sorry, Leon.
She was made for soccer.
She already has two big round balls to help her out.
Don't worry about it.
I'll sniff that later.
By the way, shouldn't you be hurrying for your date with a
hug?
Olee, Olee, Olee.
Olee.
Olay.
Because they're having so much fun, she completely lost
track of time.
She looks at her phone and sees that she's already late.
Oh, dear.
Periodically, D.D.
D.D.
D.
has all her things and storms out of Leon's office.
A bit bunda.
Leon is left alone.
The referee.
Yeah.
I think I'm going to head out as all.
For that match, I'm surprised he even had any yellow card.
All right, man.
Talk to you later.
Even the ref left Leon, guys.
The door to the restaurant.
Oh, swing open.
He didn't have time to...
Whoa, okay.
Where is he?
Is he already gone?
She looks around, but can't spot.
Knocks noticeable.
That's the first thing she spots, guys.
Oh no Leon sabotaged her date she kept he kept them over for
so long I screwed up then I Not the goalkeeper then leave
though You're right Just as he's cinematically and
dramatically turns around to go home She hears a male voice
Hey Didi-dano I'm over here As she turns around She sees him
sitting there in her favorite outfit of his I think that's
his only outfit of his Are you blind or something?
She didn't see him right Oh, they can't see They can only
see movement, guys She's a DD dinosaur Because he was
sitting still Because she's a T-Rex It's so great to see you
When DD dinosaur walks towards him He stands up to pull her
chair out for her Oh my god But DD dinosaur throws herself
Into his impressive arms to greet him football sweat smell
fills his nose sorry I'm late this muscular arms right oh my
god this is first spot first first date first date material
all right guys guys I am streaming our CPU again am I
lagging I'm doing it again guys we're gonna try again on CP
am I lagging am I lagging I've a cpu with new settings is
fine so far no okay we might have cracked the code we might
have cracked the code we all right i'm streaming with cpu
again all right not yet this part four let's we gotta skip
through that all right here we go we're back we will get to
the end we will We will see the ending.
Wait.
This is it.
Oh my god.
We will get there.
And DD Dinosaur walks towards him.
Alright, here we go.
We rise.
Sorry, I'm late.
We must.
PC Koon has been trying to stop us for so long.
Oh my god.
Even Dad's trying to stop me.
He's trying to stop me.
I'm glad you're here.
We will get to the end.
We will get the double Ds.
We...
Oh my God.
And he's just like...
He's just like, silence.
You know, he wasn't barking when I was trying to figure out
the problem.
He was just chilling.
The universe is trying so hard to stop me.
But I will persevere.
The world is against me.
But I am strong.
I just hope you don't mind that I've already ordered
something for us.
They're against me on my pursuit of double Ds.
No problem.
Not at all.
I'm as thirsty as a horse after all the physical exertion
with Leon.
Physical with Leon?
Hank mutters unintelligently.
drink with a small umbrella and a piece of fruit on the side
to make it seem more worth the price.
Such luxury.
Are you trying to get me drunk or something?
She says teasingly as she takes a big sip.
Hunk laughs while he is unsure whether she means it or not.
While she takes another sip, she looks around.
Fascinated.
What a romantic place.
I don't think I've ever been to this place.
is such a fancy restaurant before I will I don't care if I
crash 20 more times we will get the double d's if it's the
last thing I do in my streaming career I will finish this
game I before I fix my PC she's beating as she looks around
in amazement of the finished marble walls the romantic
colors of the decor the garden arches on the walls then
slightly nervously hunt clears his muscular throat it's the
only thing that matters the last dead you're not dying on me
PC cool if it's the last thing I do I will use your dead
fucking body to get those D-D dinosaur Ds.
And never give up.
Your final breath will take me to the finish line.
Where shall we start?
Oh, what holy?
Oh, wait.
What are your hobbies?
My hobbies?
I'm obsessed with horror movies and horror games.
The intensity, the tension, the jump scares.
Do you also love jump scares?
Jump scares?
Those unexpected scares?
Wait, why do you ask that?
She takes another slow retreat, somewhat tensely.
Oh, but absolutely not.
She sees Hunt completely light up when talking about one of
his bloody passions.
Well, like most, it's a slow build-up that always seems
to...
But then, before he could finish his sentences, the light
And the restaurant go out.
Huh?
Hello?
Why are the lights out?
What was that?
I better just wait here.
The complete science for the problem to be resolved.
Oh.
It's the FPS section guys.
We waited for this moment.
We're finally getting the FPS part of the game
There's someone behind me Oh
I'm T.T.
Titus's iconic look spills up the silence in the room
because of the...
You know, I chose that one for a reason.
Excuse me.
There's the light again.
I got scared for a moment.
Because someone told me about a cute blindness being a real
thing once.
One thing is certain.
Now that I can see you again, I'm happy again.
Tinky, what a creep.
Say, Diddy Dinosaur, can I ask you something personal?
Oh, thumbs up.
He cutely stammered for a moment.
Can I cast what your type is?
Types like you.
Hunk laughs as you see his cheek turns a little red.
Can I ask you something personal too?
I'm Zoe.
What is your...
I want to know, Ashley.
What is your reason for visiting Leon anyway?
Oh, I, um...
I, uh...
It's complicated.
I think he's into Dinos, man.
I think he's into Dinosaur.
That is a remix.
Dr. Doctor, like, D.D.
Dinosaur says, Mocking his stutter with slightly tipsy tone.
Again, she takes a big sip over drink and notice that she's
starting to feel a little lightheaded oh wait dance wait i
want to dance though didi does her is going for it i
remember the dance oopsie what in the world am i doing now a
bit confused hunk is looking at her and then at the empty
glass next to her uh you do realize how it's a non-alcoholic
drink right Huh?
It's literally a glass of orange juice.
They have so much fun that they barely notice that the
restaurant is about to close.
Only when Hunk looks around and see that they're the only
ones left in the restaurant, he noticed what time it is.
Wow.
Is that late already?
Then he has dates for a moment, but he gathers some
self-confidence.
Am I wrong?
Or did his date go?
Really well.
See, guys?
Look, I danced and he still thinks the date went well.
I'm almost as much.
I'm like, they're like, are you sure you want a pick hug?
They're like, are you sure?
Do you sure you want a hymn bow?
Or you can have a sexy doctor with a PhD dokey.
Are you sure?
Are you sure that's what you want for DD dinosaur?
Are you sure you want to?
We're still the doctor.
You can still have the doctor DD dinosaur.
I think you'd be like, are you sure as well?
All right.
I've made my choice.
I'm not backing out.
You're in 2D.
That's an MD.
Yeah, the doctor has an MD.
Are you sure you're picking him?
All right.
Well, the fun doesn't have to stop.
maybe like to have a drink at my place?
Whoa!
Yes!
Sounds fun to me.
I was gonna say, like, he sounds way too excited right now.
I don't think he's gonna last to the house.
Jackpot.
Didi Dinosaur is thinking like a creep.
But then she sees a little pop up on his 10 out of 10
Metacritic score phase.
Yeah, but we gave apparently we gave 10 out of 10 to, what
is it called, Mixed Ape?
And every once okay i saw the ending of mixed like you know
the the bio video of he's like um uh something daddy but um
i'm gonna go to my wicked ways but um i was just like that
can't be real
but i don't think it's smart i'm not playing the game i and
we're like there's no playing in that game guys uh i don't
think it's smart huh since when is intelligence your thing
um this is i i feel like i'm glad i'm playing this it's it's
just that yeah playing is a very strong word i i like i
think the style is cool i like the animate but i feel like
it would definitely work better as a movie or an like
because the animation is crazy i think the animation looks
really good i don't think you're playing the game i sorry
because it's not like funny like heavy rain funny where you
make you fuck up the mistakes and then you slam into
everything if you try to slam apparently you try to like
slam into stuff they like correct your choices so you don't
have like the funny shit any of your prompts.
Sorry, I have to go.
Wait, am I getting rejected?
I chose you over a fucking doctor!
My mom's gonna be so mad?
Song slips in his coat and promptly hurries away.
I'll talk to you soon, okay?
The dinosaur is left behind somewhat bewildered.
I literally chose this man over fucking over a doctor.
That's why they asked if you were sure, Toki.
They warned you.
They gave you five chances to go back to him.
Was I being too direct again?
Damn that orange juice.
Chase him down.
Like every night.
She is so hot.
Just look at her.
Like, oh, am I just gonna...
I'm just going to end up with a narrator at this end.
Amunan wouldn't leave us.
He can't.
He needs to repopulate the race.
What a day.
I'm still completely exhausted from that workout with Leon.
How exciting was that?
And boy, does he look good with a lick of sweat.
Jalette's on a deep sigh.
It's strange how things turned out with Hunk, though.
I thought we were having a good time.
so abruptly.
They say something that would have let him know that I'm a
dinosaur, which scientists disagree about as to whether I
can run, giving my heavy weight.
Didi die on through stairs at the ceiling, hoping to fall
asleep, but she's not even close to being tired, man.
Then suddenly, a brilliant but also exciting idea pops into
her large skull.
But maybe I should send him a message.
She picks up her phone and leers at the screen,
mischievously.
We're gonna send Leon go to we're sending leon a message
maybe the game was right when he was like asking if i'm sure
it's leon time hey are you still up a jazz i am whoa okay
he's funny he's funny have you recovered from your loss yet
you loser i do feel like the referee was quite corrupt i
don't know i think the referee was just um was just going
through a concussion like jazz but how was your day oh how
are i played somewhere football if you know what i mean bruh
flint flint
oh yes you said emojis
Bro, why are you ass jealous?
The two-timing poop!
That's not very professional.
We're not even going steady, guys.
He fucking ditched me.
Hmm, I guess.
About that.
I think we need to talk.
Huh?
Oh, my God.
Are they gay?
Are they both gay?
Are they...
Were they both...
Or bi?
Are they both bi or gay?
Oh my god.
Are they cheating on each other with me?
Is that it?
I prefer to do that in person.
Or are they both into dinosaurs?
Maybe they're both into dinosaurs.
Maybe that's it.
Not because then I would get paid per hour, but also because
it is more personal.
Oh my god.
They want a threesome.
They're an open relationship.
Are they gay or European?
Are they European?
Oh my god, they might be European.
They might be European.
Maybe they're trying to get Thruppola.
She is a bit fun.
Now she has to be in suspense for another week.
But she understands.
All right.
I'll see you then.
Maybe gay and European.
Good night.
Dinosaur?
D.
Okay.
D dinosaur.
Okay, he auto-corrected.
He auto-corrected, guys.
Was that smelly music, or does he really know?
Oh, what am I supposed to do now?
She can hear the soothing vibration of Robson's prayer in
her head.
You're right, Robson.
There's no reason he would know.
But just don't understand what else could be going on.
They're both into dinosaurs.
They're either gay, dinosaur, bi, or threesome.
I guess I'll find out next week.
Does it make me a bad... Oh, my God.
I was like, who's... What the fuck?
Why is she knocking the bed?
Because, yeah, I was gonna say, what the fuck is this
banging?
That must be the name of it because I was killed in Solali
during that nice conversation I had.
Oh, another message.
Last one.
Missing an attractive hand.
For some reason, the vibration seems louder and more
aggressive than normal.
pop up what do you think is the biggest turn off in a
potential partner okay my biggest turn off i think
selfishness because you can be lazy but still like you know
i think selfishness honestly because then he does like then
they you know they don't care really about you or sloppiness
actually is that a laziness or sloppiness because i don't
want to live in a dump You know?
Indifference sucks too.
Because then it's like...
You don't care what the fuck is.
I think selfishness.
I'm going to go with selfishness.
Oh yeah, I can be sorry.
I think that would bother me, yeah.
Did you know that this is what other people think?
Yeah, selfishness.
Yeah, I was going to say, is I selfishness or indifference?
Because then it's like they don't care.
Yeah, but then I can have someone else that's not sloppy.
And then they can clean up for me.
Then they can clean up for me.
Really?
And then she is overwhelmed by all the events of today.
And tiredness sets in.
Okay, because we can't both be sloppy, you know?
We can't both be sloppy.
One has to be like...
One has to have their life together.
The other one can just toast.
I want to be the other one.
Okay, tiredness.
to sleep oh another miss message oh yeah I almost forgot the
message from last week says something about the last day
don't be selfish toky when she opens the message her pupils
become tiny their eyes spread wide open what is this on her
phone she sees a message wearing even more threatening tone
than before she Do you really think you would notice?
Do you think you would notice if there's someone else in
your house right now?
What did
I notice?
Who is this?
Suddenly, she seems to hear some stumbling downstairs.
She sits up straight and holds her breath tightly to listen
if she hears something, anything else.
Say calm, Didi Dinosaur.
That must have been one of those classic house noises.
Oh, it's glitching.
She almost drops her phone when her phone vibrates again.
Do you know that this is what most people think?
Help me!
Who is this?
Tell me!
As Didi Dinosaur knows how fast she is breathing, she tries
to calm herself down.
Stay calm, Didi Dinosaur.
Everything is okay.
Oh my god, it's glitching out.
Again, her phone vibrates.
Another message?
Please make it stop.
When she opens the message, this time there's no question,
no question, just a statement.
I know enough.
I have collected all your information, and now I'm going to
sell it to the government, or multiple governments.
Did he die so he could cry right now?
What does that mean?
What do you want from me?
Please, make it stop.
Stop it!
Wait a minute.
When she reads the last message, she gasps for air.
Maybe it's cash app.
She hardly believed what it says.
What a deal.
Thank you for answering all questions for our customer
survey.
The results of the survey shows that our most expensive,
all-in-one package with the fastest fiber optic internet
with more than 623 channels.
Oh, oh, nice.
Oh, it was an internet question.
Oh, okay, nice.
better fiber yeah did you know that 99 people percent people
are satisfied with full power net do you want to switch to
full power net their contacts is now via this number and
receive a 20 discount oh they try to act quickly because
this offer oh she deletes the message it was rogers all
along i knew it annoying ads the targeted ads the scariest
thing of all time maybe I should just Google that number oh
week nine we uncovered the mystery guys it was targeted ads
all along all right unlocked another outfit what did I get
oh my god
oh oh with some reluctance the dice are nervously walk into
the waiting room she starts to feel restless where she sees
that he's not present yet that's nothing like him sure
sometimes he's late but never when i need him she anxiously
looks at the phone to see if he hasn't said anything nope no
messages from hunk yet why does it feel like someone's
trying to sell me something remember remember guys check out
dokeymerch.com to buy my dog shirts absolutely thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you Every dog's favorite
shirt.
But she does have excellent reception thanks to Full Power
Net.
Not sponsored.
Hashtag.
Hunk comes rushing in.
Have something in apologizing.
Hey, Didi Dinosaur.
Sorry I'm late.
I was just a little nervous about today.
And I...
A smiley me appears on Didi Dinosaur's face because of his
clumsy cuteness.
Not to apologize for anything.
I just got here, too.
Although...
Maybe you should apologize for why you stormed off last
week.
Yes, that's what I want to talk to you about.
Was it something I said?
No, absolutely not.
I'm sorry to make you think that.
It's just that...
Hunk sighs deeply and attractively.
They all hit a little too close to home all of a sudden.
What?
What are you talking about?
What hit too close?
My feelings for you Feelings?
Did he die?
Is there's hard to skip a beat?
Did he really say that I'm my delirious?
I have feelings for you too!
She can barely make eye contact because of how super shy of
a person she is.
But
I haven't been completely honest.
with you.
Wait, not honest?
Again?
First about that dating app and now this?
But then the feeling of hypocrisy overwhelms her.
After all, Didi Dinosaur has not been completely honest
about who she really is too.
I think it's, I think he's into dinosaurs.
I think that's my final answer.
He's not bi, he's not gay, it's not thruple, he's in the
dinos.
Specifically that she belongs to a group called
Arachosauria, Arachosaurs, the ruling reptiles, aka the
Dinosaurs.
Maybe he's a dino too!
So she decides to be open to what he has to say.
He probably has his reasons too.
Hunk himself barely seems to realize that he just made a
declaration of love as he continues to rattle on.
This is why I lived so abruptly.
It didn't feel fair that I'm on one it open with you then he
gathers all of his courage and looks are straight in the
eyes it has to do with why this is dr leon and he's not
european guys i think i figured it out i'm terrified of how
you'll see me after i i tell you but i have to be honest
with you where on earth could this be going i think doctor's
gonna come in the moment he says this the doctor's gonna
fucking come in if he starts talking about oh that's again
i'm I'm the reason why I visit Leon every day, every week.
I'm going to get docked blocked again.
I'm going to get docked blocked.
He takes a prehistoric deep breath.
I am.
With dramatic time, I knew it.
The door to Dr. Leon's office swings open.
Feedy dinosaur with sloppy sloppers.
It's time for your appointment.
Oh?
hunk looks at the ground in the feet and mumbles softly to
himself if only i could ever get to my point faster let's
talk more he could tell me right now he could tell me right
now sir sure what do you want to talk about disappointed
himself hunk mutters that he wasn't talking to leon as dd
dinosaur walks into the office she thinks to herself that
dramatic cliffhangers make less sense in real life than in
tv shows We got dock blocked.
I knew it.
It's so obvious it was going to happen.
It was right there.
DD, dinosaur.
Please, take a seat.
Take a DD seat.
Despite the strange interaction with Hunk, she knows that
she's so happy to see Leon.
Yeah, this is the one-piece pacing.
She sneaks peek at his chest here as he goes through his
paperwork.
That's a force I like to get lost in.
Leon, Barry looks like...
up strange leon seems less talkative than usual as if his
mind is somewhere else oh he's thinking about it oh tease
him still haven't recovered from last week's match have you
you know a real match last 90 minutes right leon looks up
with a girl he likes it he oh you tease oh girl you tease i
wouldn't talk too much if i were you because today i
prepared another tough physical test.
Didi dinosaur clenches her fist, knowing that it would
probably become unnecessary sensual again.
A healthy body contributes to a healthy mind.
We all know that dancing is a super real sport.
That's why we're doing the motor skill and reflex test
today.
Didi dinosaur noticed that she is very enthusiastic about
this test.
Oh, oh my god.
Is it dance dance revolution time?
After all, dancing is whatever things dancing and shedding
skin dd das or chuckles to yourself because it's ddr you
know dance dance do donkey do us a favor move your head just
a little bit away with you you mean like this like that like
oh like this right dd das or chuckles to herself that way
you would be so impressed with me he doesn't know what is
going to hit him because when she dances she always sweats
so much that clothes are always slipping off the test is
very simple don't worry don't worry guys i'll protect you
from i protect you from too much cake don't worry i know i'm
such a hero what a like that the test is very simple if you
can dance dance to beat and try to keep it up for as long as
possible this way i can clearly see how your physical health
is doing is that clear oh slow dancing nice try but slow
dancing isn't really the most intensive dance here we go Oh
shit
I knew I knew it was DDI
What's that sound?
Yes, hear that?
What the fuck?
Gotta lock you in, guys.
For DD dinosaurs.
Where's Jay?
Oh my god.
Numbers.
It's
a dance because I'm trying.
I'm trying to lock.
Oh, my fucking gun.
Oh, my God.
I don't know where the...
That's fucked.
I don't have F12.
That's fucking...
Okay.
Oh, my God.
What?
A.F.
G.
I didn't even get to see what she took off.
Who did she take off?
I'll never go.
I was so locked in.
I was trying so hard.
Why did I...
Why is so evil?
And I've seen a number today
What happened?
No, no, can't you take this away from me?
Don't you can't take this away What's next?
Am I going to get map problems?
It's like solve for X and then have to press To like the
right number?
Oh my god.
Oh no.
I don't even know what happened.
I didn't even see I couldn't even see what she was was
taking off.
All I could see was trying to hit the combos.
How could I screw this up?
I just wanted Leon to be impressed with me.
How could you do this to us, Tokyo?
How could you mess up the combo?
We flew a little close to the sun with that one.
I have to actually rewind the VOD after the stream is over
to see what you guys saw.
I did not see anything I literally the only thing I saw was
her taking it off her shoes And then I was just locked in
and trying to get the fucking like fucking buttons And then
as the thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That's my fumbling.
Oh, she never changed Wait, when she catches up thinking
that specific thought Suddenly a light filling a dark room
something unexpectedly becomes crystal clear Heartbreak Leon
I don't think I can see you anymore Why?
I tried so hard.
I couldn't even appreciate I couldn't even appreciate the
finer things in life My eyes were just up there I couldn't
even look down I'm afraid The Soffy Sessions Leon looks up
shock.
For a moment, it seems like he doesn't know what to say to
this.
Unexpected turn to vents.
Because I fucked up DDR.
Okay, that was a fucked up DDR, though.
Who the fuck puts, like, what are these combos?
Where does this suddenly come from?
I have a 60% keyboard, guys.
I don't have an F12.
I don't even know where the 12 is.
What does something come from?
Is it something I said?
she never heard Leon's controlled voice struggling so hard
to not stumble over his words no it's not you that's just me
realize that I'm no longer here to help myself first thing I
thought of to test just now was that I hope you would be
impressed by me I realized now I'm no longer here to help
myself I did I was the arrow keys i just don't know what i
don't have a 12.
i just don't have a 12 on my keyboard i now mainly just come
here every week to see you and hunk one step away from how
we were this close to greatness duck thank you with this
super chat thank you for for hunk and it's like what you
always tell me you can only help me if i want to help myself
By this moment, I realized I no longer come here with the
right intentions.
She has seen Leon's eyes that doesn't want her to be right.
Then I'm afraid that you are right.
Leon smiles her way with someone defeated, but understanding
luck.
They both know that they want to say goodbye now, but
neither of them will say anything just to postpone this
moment a little longer.
even if just for a moment while Didi dance her breast
bounced as she stands up she makes meaningful eye contact
one last time while Leon is still sitting behind this desk
somewhat dazed I appreciate everything you've done for me
and hopefully one day I'll be ready to do something with it
but for now it's time to take care of myself DeeDee Dinosaur
walks towards the exit and somatically looks over her
shoulder at Leon one last time I still don't know what was
he going to confess so Farewell, Leon An overwhelming
feeling of tragedy washes over Leon, DeeDee Dinosaur Harley
due to the music What did he want it to say?
What did he want it to say?
Okay I wish you the best, Didi Dinosaur.
It hurts that she won't be able to see Leon anymore, but she
knows it's time to take care of herself.
Wait!
If you quit, I'll quit too!
Huh?
With a pounding chest, Didi Dinosaur steps back into the
office.
What does he mean?
Leon stands up with confidence.
look on his face.
I will quit for you.
I cannot deny that I've been questioning my integrity as a
therapist for some time now.
What the hell are you talking about?
You're the most professional therapist I've ever played
football with.
You're the only therapist I ever played football with.
Because of my feelings for you.
I'm still in this game.
I'm still in it.
feelings so it means I can't see you anymore because of my
work I'm willing to give him my job for you that's so
romantic and not strange at all I'm still in baby I'm still
in although she has dreamed of the moment that Leon would
say this it's all very overwhelming at the moment not only
honk but also Leon has declared his love for her What should
she do now?
Never could she imagine that she would go from being so
lonely to such a luxury problem.
That's sweet.
That's so sweet.
Shiley, she looks at his true...
There's where?
But I need to think about it.
I was like, where?
No.
I understand.
And I'm sorry for overwhelming you like this.
I let my feelings run wild for a moment there.
When I turn, I might not be able to see you again.
But before you make your final decision, I also thought it
was important that you know how I feel about you.
Yeah, like it's definitely wax, guys.
Did he die, sir?
Appreciate his honesty.
There's no treasure there.
leading me where's the rainbow to where's the rainbow to the
golden cauldron dd dinosaur appreciates his honesty and the
content coconut shape bulge in his pants it's important that
you're fully behind your decision whatever choice may be i
will support you listen to your feelings carefully dd
dinosaur and while dd dinosaur walks out of the office
struggling with the weight of the choices on her shoulder
leon looks up oh did he dance or never forget that you're
beautiful just the way you are oh oh she's already gone okay
never mind she didn't hear we heard it though we heard it
leon don't worry we heard it it's okay she might not have
heard it but we heard it time.
Dini Dinosaur lies awake, thinking and worrying about the
choices to come.
Using our bosom as stress balls, of course.
I mean, yeah.
I mean, okay, but who hasn't done that, though?
You ever, you know, okay, look, it's a woman's day, you
know, when you're
unironically, unironically, we do, though.
I just girl thing is actually it's not actually a meme is
that not me I'm a dude unironically yeah it's actually
normal yeah makes sense why can't I mean you can technically
you can
I'm the choice between the two dreams men seem to hang over
your head Like, one of those Looney Tunes Anvil.
The most cyber, a lot of women do it.
It's just, we mean it doesn't hurt.
It's fat.
There's no, there's no like fucking receptors around.
Unless you're like, like, like, I don't know, fucking do a
death grip or some shit.
It's just so hot.
hard robson they're both so fantastic i can't keep treating
them both a lot so i have to make a choice and be honest
with them that's the least they deserve after everything
they've done for me yeah i'm leaking the girl's secrets guys
you know when when like when more than one girl goes to the
bathroom they're not actually peeing together do you guys
It's not because they all want to pee.
It's usually because of what they all were like, oh my God,
let's dish, girl.
Let's go gossip.
I'm leaking it.
If my stream dies again, if my stream dies again, they got
me.
The women got me.
The women's society.
They're like, she's leaking all our secrets to the men.
Her dad.
No way.
You heard it here.
I said, it was time.
Yeah, it's good.
By declaring my love to just one of these, a man, God, seems
almost impotent.
The women, Laminati, got me.
The women, counsel.
Shut her down.
Wait, no.
Oh, no.
They just sent dad over.
The women sent him over.
They both have their strong points and arms.
That's smart.
They give us super chat.
Thank you.
It's okay.
Some fat dudes.
use your stomach as stress ball.
Not quite the same.
They'll think it was a super chat.
They can thank you.
Then, 3D dinosaurs suddenly thought of something.
Her bus cat, Mr. Robson, once said, if you can't make a
decision on something, you could always make perhaps make
pros and cons list.
Maybe that could help you visualize who you think visualize
who you think has the most upside.
Smart plan, bro.
Oh my god.
She leans over.
the edge of her I don't know still would to grab a pen and
paper from her cupboard it's not you know the the face
enhances everything let me give me a sec let me position
myself right here just to we got censored this part a little
bit so I'll I'll be right here guys okay let me think which
quality is that I think are important.
Do I fit which man best?
Do I think fit which man best?
Oh my.
Okay, Leon obviously.
Communication.
I mean, I don't, I think Leon because Honk keeps, he can't
get his thoughts out.
Humor?
Okay, Honk is funny.
Knowledge of Ant-Honk.
Honesty?
Leon has been more honest than hunk caring hunk sexual
attraction oh that's guys come on that's hard do i am i
sexual are we are we okay this is a team game remember are
we sexually attracted to omni man or soldier 67 is oh if we
had to pick between soldier 67 or Or Omni Man.
I would say.
I gotta go.
Leon personally.
Don't put this.
Okay, this is a team game.
No, he's not Homelander.
Homelander is not a hymn bow, guys.
Is it pull time?
Alright, it's pull time.
We're risking it all for my PC crashing any moment for this
pull.
Omni Man.
versus uh soldier 67 67 omni all right oh my god she's
growling she can't hold it in guys she's growling right now
oh now it's if only we had an integration on a streaming
platform to help you make that
Omni Man is a Dilf, not a Himbo.
All right, Dilf versus Himbo, guys.
Omni.
Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you, coward.
Pick one yourself.
And I see, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
The Omni D is doing it for me.
You like how, like, when I was with, Omni-Man?
What else was with Leon?
They weren't like, are you sure?
Are you sure you don't want to pick the hymn boat?
Are you sure?
They were just like, alright, let's go.
Oh my god.
Dinosaur with double Ds?
That's me.
They're singing about me.
I know.
Why can't I pick both?
Looks like Omni-Man is winning, guys.
Are you sure?
Omni-Man.
rider time for my hymn book all right i'll give you guys
five more seconds to vote guys five four three two one no
our hymn book is losing adam's apple size okay all right
well i never really pay attention to that there was a lot of
other stuff to pay attention to mike thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you falling for the The Viltrum Empire
shake my head, yes.
Mike, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Damn.
Adam's Adam.
I feel like it'd be Leon.
Bold shape.
Okay, it's definitely a hunk.
Clothing choice?
Wait, where did it stop?
Oh, Winnie the Pooh and Donald Duck?
I guess Donald Duck.
Because they both don't wear pants.
Yeah, I was gonna sit.
There.
Close look at her notes.
Oh my god.
By one point.
We were so close.
Oh my god.
Leon.
Got it through with one point.
It was so close.
Why she sees the results like this.
Her feelings suddenly become a lot clearer.
Mm-hmm.
Then she nods determinedly.
I'm right.
Her final choice has been made.
She knows who she wants to declare her love to.
And who she wants to slam.
Dump.
Oh.
Okay.
Guys.
It's finally here.
We waited for this moment.
Guys.
We were here.
She was all...
The loudest, I like how the lurkers are Leon and the most
passionate is, hug.
You know your answer.
We need to, all right, I'll give you guys a recount, guys.
Dimbo versus Bill.
It's like, we might be quiet, but our numbers are numerous.
Screw the ball.
Our numbers might be small, but we are passionate.
Don't make me choose.
My loyalty is to the Viltro Vampire.
Jakarta, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Stop the count.
Oh my god, it's the recount.
The Dilt Believers Swap Sides.
They're flip-flop.
They flip to the Himbo.
I've never been so invested.
Dokey.
win make him both great again the right they hired the
Russian bots to rig the boats imagine if this was a time
decision balance bar thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you welcome home info brothers and both time is now.
It's a re-vote.
We had a re-vote.
Come on.
I thought what happened to the Viltrum Empire, guys?
Did they destroy the planet and now there's even less
Viltrumites?
Where did these voters come from?
They're making fake votes.
They fabricated votes.
They're letting a dead vote for the hymn vote.
Lurker lobbying, shake my head.
They lobbied for Hymbo's.
The Hymbo's supremacy.
I'm going to give 10 seconds, guys.
10, 9, 8, 7, 6, 5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
Stop the count.
The Hymbo wins.
with the re-vote.
I demand another recount.
Best of three.
Don't keep best of three for the Pilgrim Empire.
X, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's time.
After all these hours, after several PC crashes, We have
picked punk.
Are you sure?
Every time, every time we pick him, the game is like, are
you sure?
Are you sure?
Another ball.
Don't fall.
for it they should everything really don't want me to pick
the him though are you sure it's for a reason reconsider
looks like oh are you sure all right best of three guys the
best of three are you sure
For a hunk.
There we go.
Every time.
Are you sure?
I am so mad.
I love this.
Once and for all.
The vote to end all votes.
Are you?
No.
Seriously.
Are you sure for a yes for it?
Yes, I'm sure for a no for it.
No, I'm not sure.
I'm starting to doubt my answer Oh no, everyone is starting
to doubt I've never been more sure for my life For the
pilgrim empire we must prevail I have more polls.
I love democracy.
I don't even know what we're voting for anymore.
I just I'm gonna be involved.
No, no, you're not, you don't have a vote, Dad.
No, you don't have a vote.
It's never ending democracy.
Disserters.
So together, this is the last vote, guys.
This is the last vote.
Oh my God, the hymn votes, the hymn vote voters are starting
to desert the hymn vote.
They're flop, they're traded, they're deserting.
The most important election of them all.
Himbo or Omni Man.
Let him vote.
Tied one bark for yes, two barks for no.
Feels very thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
The Himbo voters have deserted their fan base And now
they're all in for Omni-Men.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Dragoons, the traitors among us might have won, but we will
purge them from our glorious democracy.
Space.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I was so invested in this election that I forgot about their
Titan bulges for a split second.
Can you guys think of the super chat?
Thank you.
Glory to the Viltrum.
The hymns, the hymns are lobbying.
The boats are getting close.
They're lobbying for more supporters.
The hymns won't back down.
We're so cookie-pushing hymns, bro.
We can do this.
Oh, the line, Bill Trump.
It's almost 50.
Oh, my God.
50 but oh if I end the poll and whatever comes first is
usually the one that votes the most so whoever gets to 51%
wins please I just want to sleep I work in five hours in 50
minutes thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
It's on your head.
That guy, Leo, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
This is why Plato hated democracy.
Truth, truth.
Everyone cast a vote.
When it hits 51%, it ends.
It ends.
Whoever hits 51%.
Oh.
It's over.
No!
Stop.
The comeback.
The comeback was real.
Oh my god.
No!
He did it.
He fucking did cool.
All the counts, him bows.
No way.
No democracy failed.
It's time.
I'm sure that we did it for him both.
Cyclos, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The create civil war.
Yeah.
I'm sure but of course we saved democracy guys hymbo's rise
up you've done it that's what I'm going to do I never stop
believing hymbo grows viral thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you like a sun coming through the clouds
it's suddenly all becomes crystal clear in her head now that
she has made her choice this is how democracy dies we did
best out of three guys the people have spoken
the hymn bros simply lobbied harder against the vilter mites
it was just not enough vilter mites guys this dino is not
yours to conquer on you man like thank you for this Super
Chat, they could make it.
This life, the pounds of stress have been lifted from her
salamander-like shoulders.
But she still has those double Ds hanging there.
So in reality, that's not even close to being true.
Darko is protesting your local street.
Write letters to your local politician.
To your local politician.
Dear local councilman, we must change the boat.
Tiki, it's a bit exciting knowing that I'm going to tell
him.
She falls back into bed.
The absolved burden is replaced by fatigue.
Fatigue that seems to be blocked by weeks of stress and
eternity.
For a moment.
She thinks about what she would do if a hug were.
We're lying next to her right now.
You voted for this hug him, bros.
There, this is your reward.
But before she can finish the explicit fantasy, she falls
asleep like a sweet baby hamster.
Raz, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's treason then.
She has to stay for a moment before stepping into the
waiting room with her feet.
Oh, well, there's the feet stuffed again.
Well, here we go.
Time for the moment.
It's a big choice.
As she walks into the waiting room, she hears her own heart
pounding under her gigantic whoppers.
And those are big dampers.
So you can imagine how hard her heart must be pounding.
Although she is nervous, she's now fully behind her choice.
If I had to be honest with him, I just have to tell him.
She repeats to herself inside her fossilized skull.
He deserves that.
Dee Dee Dinosaur is scared to make eye contact with Hunk
while entering the waiting room.
But once she mustered up the courage to look up, she sees
that Hunk isn't there at all.
Hmm.
huh huh he's not here why is he not here did I say something
wrong then she pulls herself together no it's probably
nothing everyone is late forgetting forget for an asshole
sometimes maybe it's better this way I must say in a way
it's a bit of a relief that he's not here because it's
pretty scary to have to confront someone like this.
Did our votes just never mattered, guys?
But then she hears a hand grab the door handle, the waiting
room door.
Her heart rate starts up again like a steam locomotive.
Here we go.
Around the corner of the door appears the face of a man we
haven't seen the entire game.
Oh.
Say, is this a dentist waiting room?
David kinker.
Uh, no, that's two doors down.
Okay.
Thank you very kindly.
Okay, that was okay.
Oh, no problem.
I changed my vote.
I want David.
David leaves the waiting room and carefully loses the door.
Oh, very carefully.
Still doing it.
Oh, there you go.
uh well i guess that's it a new contender appears she
suddenly feels so alone again coming in with a steel chair
it's david maybe it's because earlier hong said that he
would be there for her if she needed him and he's not here
now Didi Danistar drops her head for a moment, but then
picks herself back up.
Then I'll talk to Hunk later.
And going to have to talk to Leon first, she mentally braces
herself and stands up.
And this time, her breasts are actually silent.
But then, she suddenly hears a familiar voice.
But wait, is that Hunk?
His voice sounds muffled and it's hard to hear what's saying
But he sounds emotional Wait No, no, it's back It's gay
European threeple Or threesome Oh my god, it's back The
fucking the question I thought we figured it out I thought
gay bi European threesome threeple Or dino kink Or dino kink
Wait, is that sound coming from Leon's office?
Maybe this time, he had the earlier appointment.
TV Dinosaur immediately feels more relieved.
He's here after all.
I hope he's doing okay.
He sounds worried.
This is suddenly a startle.
She hears the madly low voice of Dr. Leon react angrily at
home.
like one of his usual sensual sessions.
Didi Dinosaur tries not to listen out of respect, but still,
it's very curious.
I should get involved in this.
It's probably just one of Leon's tests, which are always
entertaining for some reason.
Then she suddenly looks up and surprised.
Wait, what's that?
My name?
Did I just hear my name during their argument?
She has for a moment.
That can't be, right?
Oh, I froze.
Okay, that's a good sign, guys.
Guys, that's a good sign.
The stream is still on.
Guys, the stream is still strong.
That, guys, no, that's a really good sign.
That's a really good sign.
We're still in it.
We're still.
It's progress.
It's looking.
I will take progress here.
I take those.
But then she carefully walked towards Dr. Leon's office and
places her ear against the door.
It's so hard to understand.
She closed her eyes as if it will make her hear better.
Amazingly enough, she still can't properly hear them.
Down that ebony door!
There has to be a way for me to hear them better.
No, I still can't understand it.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
How is
I'll keep listening What?
It won't let me open the door What can I do?
I'll keep listening He keeps trying the same thing There
must be another way to hear them But what if I listen again
We put believe it not The exact same outcome She can't hear
them.
Wait, suddenly, I can hear them much better.
She puts her ear to the door.
Oh my god, that's so smart.
That is so smart.
That's crazy.
That is, this game is 10 out of 10.
Oh my, this game is actually 10 out of 10.
Because apparently she is a idiot.
I don't pay you Adele.
I'm paying...
I'm paying you to keep her here?
Without me?
She wouldn't even be here right now?
Didi Dinosaur has a confused blank stare on her face.
She can't understand it.
Wait.
What do they mean?
He really is on the bed.
He was a paid actor?
Then something in her primitive brain snaps.
And everything goes black for a moment.
Overwhelmed with emotions.
And before she realized what she is doing, she has rushed
in.
We were just a...
A pet?
Leon's office.
As DD dinosaur burst into the room, Dr. Leon...
And hunk, look up, and make some of the shocked anime
noises.
Oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, what do you mean with she is
here because of me?
Her voice wavers as she shouts while tears well up in her
eyes.
This is M.
Like Shama Lama Lama Ding Dong movie?
What is this plot twist?
deep inside she already knows the answer he betrayed you
what are you doing here this is a doctor patient
confidential conversation I'll call you in when it's time
for your appointment oh guess you're afraid to make eye
contact with DD dinosaur I'm sorry all this things you said
to me well no in the end it wasn't I I'm sorry I lied to you
no that didn't want it this way these eyes are seeing it
chokes up but feels no pity what a good actor you liar oh
shit sorry I was I wanted to I want to look at my phone real
quick I feel sorry about that too Nobody is perfect.
I know that now.
No one but you.
Hunk doesn't know what else he can say to save the
situation.
And walks right past Didi Dinosaur towards the exit.
Defeated.
He looks at Didi Dinosaur one last time.
Cleaningly.
What do I do?
I still have a chance.
I still have a chance, him, bros.
What even?
Do you still take him?
Do you let him spit on him?
But those pecs.
You're right.
He... Are you sure?
Are you sure, Imbrose?
Alright.
He betrayed our trust.
No forgiveness.
Spit on him.
Ha!
Roll that tie.
Okay, let's roll that die.
Surely we can spit on him.
You rolled high enough to perform this action.
Hey, look.
Buy my dog shit.
As hunk walk past her.
head bowed down dd dinosaur clears her throat loudly
collecting all the mucus and saliva she can as a preparing a
spirit bomb before you can even look it up she loads this
non-saliva cocktail with a sound as if it were a weapon oh
my but do it eat him and as thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you The snob bullet fires through the air at
high speed.
And with exact precision, the mucus ball soars right into
his ear canal.
The last thing Hunk hears is the loud snap of the loogie
bursting through the eardrum, followed by the thump of
phlegm hitting his vesticular organ.
Hunk staggers on his feet as if everything is spinning
before him.
for his eyes.
Hank hunk trips and stumbles towards the office exit.
Merry Christmas.
You filthy animal.
I told finally the FPS part.
I told you guys it was an FPS game.
I told we waited for this moment.
We did it.
Now it's a shooter.
In a happy new year.
Didi Dinosaur is very proud of herself with her own original
catchphrase.
Hunk didn't hear it because he is now deaf on that side.
Now that Hunk is gone, a cold silence fills the room as Didi
Dinosaur and Dr. Leon stare at each other.
What is the meaning of this?
What did you mean by making me come back here?
It doesn't matter anymore.
It does to me.
you don't understand it's over what's over all tests have
been successfully completed i just need one more question
answered from you and you already know the answer
oh my god am i a dinosaur the answer what answer i knew you
were i know you were in the love with one of us.
After all, we both have biceps and six packs.
So who did you choose?
Who did you come here to declare your love?
Do you have that answer for me?
See it as the love test.
Would I come here?
We chose, huh?
Sorry, Leon.
You may be a little too much like Omni-Man.
You fools!
Best out of four!
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, I thought they were ten packs.
What happened to the four other packs?
Two.
Hunk.
Oh, how touching.
DD-Taster turns away from Leon.
Emotionally.
Boat!
Another are you sure?
That doesn't matter anymore.
Oh, but nothing could be further from the truth.
He grabs a stack of forms from his desk.
The results of all tests.
His hand is shaking as he writes down Hunk as the final
answer.
His eyes eagerly scan the paperwork as he tries to calculate
the result.
A bead of sweat slats down his forehead.
perfect jawline then he closes his eyes a satisfaction a
devious laugh escapes his closed mouth yes yes it's true
what is true what were those tests i took over the past few
weeks my theories were correct the results are in he waves
his arms like a conductor as he steps in a dd dinosaur his
space then he looks her straight in the eye like when scar
told simba that he killed ufasa my research is complete do
you want to know the what the results say before she can
answer he interrupts her are you sure
are you sure
thank you thank you are you sure why are you absolutely sure
do i want to know what the yes yes i'm sure i'm absolutely
sure this time dr leon clears his throat theatrically the
results confirmed dd dinosaur eyes widened.
That you are a dinosaur.
Pure internal panic flows over a knee-dinosaur's entire
beating.
Paul!
She can barely breathe.
And now that this is confirmed, I can finally fulfill my
personal dream.
Conduct behavioral research on a live specimen.
Didi Dinosaur starts to get lightheaded.
She staggers on her feet for a moment as she almost loses
consciousness from the stress.
That's impossible.
How could he have known?
Was it the name?
Was it the no gag reflex?
How did he know?
Who could have seen it coming.
The past few weeks are flashing in front of her eyes like a
movie while all the puzzle pieces are slowly falling into
place.
Oh no, get a hold of yourself.
Oh, I did it.
Where is that at?
I did it.
Dance!
Oh my god, is Wario where?
Okay.
Oh.
I did it!
Look out!
No!
I did it!
Draw your feelings!
Wario, where is that?
Answer!
What is the truth?
I'm not alone.
It's over?
But I was doing it!
I did it!
Oh my god, the boss rush.
I did it.
Dance.
I just gotta dance, guys.
Oh, I did it.
Look out.
Okay, I did it.
Draw your feelings.
I did it.
Answer.
I am all alone.
I did it.
find a couple a couple what oh I did it find the differences
oh I did it feel what I see a dinosaur I did it take him
down where
is he
What?!
That one is so hard!
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, we did it.
I did it.
Where's that at?
I-I didn't understand it!
I didn't do it!
Dance!
Actual, why are you aware?
Okay, I did it!
I did it!
Okay, I did it.
Answer.
I am all alone.
I did it.
Get a hold of yourself, Doki.
Okay.
Okay, I did it.
Oh my god, this is the actual final difference.
It's Himbo Man.
Okay, we did it.
Feel.
Dinosaur.
I need to lock him.
Lock him down.
Boom!
I did it!
Break!
Realize!
She did it.
Dennis suddenly clicked.
Go!
When she
wakes up from the flashback, everything is suddenly Crystal
clear.
Those tests.
Your name.
Leon.
But you introduced yourself as.
Leno.
A paleontologist.
An anagram for.
Oh fuck, it was under our noses this entire time.
Oh my god.
It was right there.
I should have known.
That's right.
I'm indeed really, I'm indeed really bad at coming up with
fake names.
us he really did got us it was there since the start DD
dinosaur can't believe it how could have been so blind all
you had to do was make me laugh once you would have heard I
was a bad guy but what about but hunk was sweet so hunk was
just being nice to me to get me to come back here plus one
for team imbo team imbo gets wins again no we've thank you
for the super chat thank you thank you at first yes but that
argument just now was basically want to be honest and
confess everything so badly oh my god you the dad's amazing
how could he DD Dyser feels immensely disappointed in Honk.
Team Embrose was always right.
Embrose forever.
He wanted to confess.
But what about look out for Honk?
Yeah, then why did you warn me about Honk?
So you would never suspect that we were working together.
Pretty smart, huh?
What about that?
declaration of love then why did you tell me you love me I
noticed you starting to slip away and because I knew you had
feelings for me I used this to study you further nothing
personal kid give up your job but then why did you say you
were willing to sacrifice your job for me maybe I'll stop
coming to sessions I wouldn't be able to complete my
research feel nothing at all but didn't you feel anything
for me at all oh how sweet if it's any consolation to you as
a paleontologist I do love dinosaurs doesn't matter anymore
why are there any tears streaming down my face while i'm
feeling this broken inside that's exactly what i feared for
millions of years afraid that someone would find me so
vulnerable track thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you team villchum was so correct we wanted him for his
next not his morality he's both ripped and a genius that
someone would find out i'm a dinosaur i wish scientists are
still arguing amongst this episode, but whether I have
feathers or not.
Oh, yeah, where is her feathers?
You're right.
She was just the pet.
The dinosaur's head is pounding so loudly that she can still
barely hear Leon.
But enough of that.
First, I'll take a DNA sample from you so that we can make
even more dinosaurs.
After all, that's what you've always wanted, right?
To not be alone any longer.
He holds up a needle as he walks towards her menacingly.
It was all too much for Didi Dinosaur.
She's in shock.
Tears are not streaming down her cheeks as she fails to show
any physical emotion.
How could I've been so blind?
How could I've ever trusted him?
I'm so alone right now.
So Alone!
You are never alone.
A loud voice moves to the room from behind DD Dinosaur.
The sound of voice immediately embraces her soul like a warm
scarf.
Huh?
That's...
She doesn't have to look to... Is it the frog?
Is it the frog?
But she still has to see it to boot.
I fucking David.
I fucking... It was... I knew it.
David?
I feel like I knew it.
My boy is David.
Oh, it wasn't David?
A figure steps through the door.
It's the narrator.
It's the fucking narrator.
It's... I knew it.
I called it.
Yeah, it's in such a dramatic way that you can't quite see
who it is.
But Dr. Leon already sees it.
What?
How is this possible?
Mr. Robson!
Oh my god!
Leon is dead.
Yeah, okay.
I can't.
I guess none of us knew none of us the German cult.
Mr. Robson?
We none of us could have predicted This the plot twist after
plot twist after plot twist
Oh my god, I'm back Wait, wait, I still made it Wait, I'm
back Wait, oh my god It's okay, it's okay Oh my god, oh my
god Guys, the crazy part My OBS didn't crash It is, it's the
GPU It's the It's the There's so many The plot twist Guys,
we know for sure Since I went with CPU My OBS didn't crash
My OBS didn't crash It was literally Oh my god No, do we
have to go through all the plot twists again Oh Is it gonna
make me go through it Okay She is so alone She is so alone
guys oh my god oh my oh my god we might actually we're back
oh my god it is the GPU fully percent something something
got fucked up in the GPU after the drivers update something
something got fucked up on the GPU guys we at least we can
confirm that it's fully confirmed the stream went through so
many plot twists it just never stopped oh my god there's no
way where does it take me oh my god oh we can re-experience
the plot okay we'll go we'll zoom in we'll zoom in
it's not the game guys it's okay all right we gotta
experience the betrayal again oh my god spit on it we'll
still do it it's okay it'll always be a 10 oh my god it's to
perform this action here we go
all right go go fast fast gas gas we gotta know okay oh my
god please i need her we were so close to the end we were so
close hunk no we gotta stick to the ending guys we gotta
stick to what we chose guys we gotta stick to what we chose
we can't change we can't change the fabric of destiny oh my
god we're going so fast oh we have to oh my god forgot it's
the warrior where again it's warrior again okay all right we
can do this I did it we have experience okay I did it where
is that at I did it dance we can't change fate we were
destined to spit on him.
I did it.
Look out.
Draw your feelings.
I did it.
Answer.
I am all alone.
I did it.
Find a couple.
Find the differences.
I did it.
Feel.
Dinosaur!
I did it!
Take him down!
I'm going in!
Get over here!
Boom!
I did it!
Break!
Realize!
I'm just doing it!
I'm doing it!
Denison, we clicked.
destined yeah we were destined to spit on him we were so
close
it doesn't matter anymore here it is are you ready mr robson
mr robson
It was...
Mr. Robson!
It's everything!
That's impossible!
Even PC could not fucking believe in the plot twist!
Even he...
Even he couldn't understand!
Leon is dead.
Alright, there we go.
Yeah, whatever, dude.
Just kiss me.
In
the end, it all comes back to the cat.
I'm all for this.
Maybe we do the cat.
Maybe we do.
Huh?
Didi, dinosaur hearts.
Maybe a cat is fine.
But she hears Robson's romantic declaration of love.
How could she have not seen the one she was looking for?
It's literally always there.
Can I change my answer?
I think the cat might be the way.
Next thing, thank you.
And the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Sir, a cat is fine.
too i can see it now you're always the one i missed mr
robson that's like i do not i do not agree with this even
dad was like stop stop this right now he's like i do not i
object he's objecting right now there's
like tally does not approve the i go offline whatever oh my
god
no We were at home thanks for it, Lay.
She is so alone.
We made it.
There's no necker room.
my roblo do you but all i'll do james thank you with a super
chat hey thank you super chat thank you thank you put on the
ears right thank you with a super chat No.
That was a stream of all time.
So thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We were so close to the last crash.
Even the PC was like...
It was like even the PC was so surprised.
He's like, this plot twist.
I...
None of us could have predicted this.
Even he crashed out.
My GPU didn't want to render any further.
My GPU was like, it's over.
It's over.
Joki, who recommended this game?
I wanted to talk to them.
Thank you for the super chat.
Will the dragon please stand up.
That was our 10 out of 10 all along.
Finally, thank you for the super chat.
for Saturday.
If I...
Oh my god.
What a stream for a Tuesday night.
What?
The crashes were a warning to us all.
Oh my god.
Jokekeeper's peak as a streamer right here.
This is...everything's gonna go downhill.
I'll, I'll never find a game that will ever live up to its
expectations like I did DD dinosaur with double Ds Well done
DD dokey Just call me, thank you, thank you I think the
crash is added to the experience guys if you think about it
The crash is added to the stream.
Okay, I'm not explaining what happened to the purge goons.
Cinema of Barrett, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
In the end, democracy never mattered.
The cat was always end game.
Absolute Cinema Inepers, thank you for the Super Chat, thank
you, thank you
Seven hours Apeak Nexi, thank you for the Super Chat, thank
you, thank you Chikada, thank you for the Super Chat, thank
you, thank you Doki somehow found a way to get everyone
emotionally invested in Diti Dinosaur between a crazy added
plot twist and Doki's determination to beat the game.
We had to see it to the end.
And we did.
Rarely has the PC hated the game.
That was a new record.
The PC was like, please stop.
I have tried so hard to stop you.
Please.
First time watching.
And that, this is the greatest decision.
But I can tell you something is the greatest decision.
Oh, sorry.
I'm reading multiple super chats in wrong order right now.
I'm still registering.
everything.
First time watching live and that's some quality FPS
gameplay.
I told you I wasn't lying.
There was FPS in the end.
Too many.
Thank you.
What a first time live viewer.
What a first time stream to come in for it.
Thank you.
Super chat.
I'm surprised that this game is not I'm surprised that this
game does not is not as popular as I thought it would be.
Oh, wait.
It came out in February?
I regret nothing.
It's amazing you fought on till the end.
I'll just suggest this to one of your friends.
Continue this curse comedy.
Zelfius, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
This should have been a game of the year contender right
here.
Right here.
This should have been Game of the Year.
This should have got 10 out of 10 over in mixtape.
The romance.
The...
Like, we never expected any of this.
The plot twist.
The plot.
Two wonderful, lovely plots.
Oh, the story.
I don't win Game of the Year.
how could this not I think everybody I think everybody got
scared everyone were cowards they were too there were too
much of a coward to stream this game it's made by Dutch I'm
actually surprised that this was made by the Dutch I'm
actually surprised that the Dutch made this what a crazy I
can't believe I just put it on as a random Tuesday stream,
guys.
This deserved to be a Saturday stream to end the week
with...
I didn't know what I expected I will be honest.
I didn't know what was gonna happen.
I was like, oh man.
This might be this might just be like a silly one-off loot
game.
Boy, was I wrong.
Boy, was I so wrong.
This was more than just a silly, silly game.
It touched all of our hearts.
It really changed me as a person.
That's true.
The Dutch are freaks.
They do have the red, the, what was it, the, it's the red
light district, right?
They do have that.
That is true.
A big win for the Dutch.
papa we peaked on tuesday this will be a tuesday that will
all remember absolute w for the dutch oh it touched him i
touched more than my heart i feel like my life has changed
forever i i don't know like how I can go on how I can even
go on after that like I will never live that high again of
DD dinosaur with double Ds I don't think any game will ever
live up to that it was truly life changing I feel like I've
seen like I've seen the way I've seen the light it's all
downhill now like I went yeah I went through a meta I feel
like I've changed that as a person playing this game.
Yeah, yeah, how am I supposed to keep on streaming after
that?
Oh, yeah, don't worry, there's more Double D.
There's more DD dinosaurs with Double D's tomorrow, guys.
On Twitch, don't check.
Farmer Rivals with Double Dinosaur Tomorrow, the Early Axis.
There's more.
DD Dinosaur never ends.
Love us.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Are you using a stand?
Sorry.
No, I am not using a stand.
I'm sitting down.
I heard it is worth it, though.
It's nice.
From my friends that own a standing decks.
I'm too lazy to stand.
Fratus, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, we stay for life-changing experiences.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What a Tuesday.
What?
My brain chemistry has been altered forever, guys.
It's...
My brain chemistry is just...
My life trajectory has changed from this game.
I don't think I'll ever find the same happiness I felt
playing DD Dinosaur with double Ds.
I just your Tuesday there's no going back I'll never I don't
know how to move on after this what a Tuesday what okay also
member goons there will be another stream later on I'll be
but I need to fix this before tomorrow well I before the
sponsor tomorrow so I gotta fix this before the sponsor
tomorrow guys so um so we're gonna uh we're gonna we're
gonna have another bonus I need to downgrade my driver To
further Because I have my last The driver I downgraded to is
January So I might have to go even further back Because it's
Apparently it's not the January January driver does not work
with my driver right now So we gotta go even further back
It's 1am I know guys I I know Girl Guys I need to fix this
before the member the sponsor.
Before the sponsor did it.
Silas, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I don't know if I'll be able to sleep tonight after this.
When you close your eyes, all you can think about is DD
dinosaur with the double Ds.
That's all we can think about.
Absolutely.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
For dragoons, this was a turning point in lives.
But for Doki, it was the Tuesday.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh.
Thank you, everybody, for coming.
Thank you all for changing your lives with me today.
It'll never be the same.
But we're all here together.
All seven hours.
Seven hours.
We did it, dragons.
It was a journey.
It was quite a journey with all of you.
I hope I hope we'll remember this moment till the day we die
that we all celebrate that we all celebrated DD dinosaurs
with double D's every moment civil wars best set of two best
set of three omnimab versus him bro him bro in the end the
cat won maybe a cat is fine in the end guys Maybe a cat is
buying too.